Wir müssen mehr über Macs reden. So dachte sich Tim Pritlav Anfang 2008. Doch Tim Pritlav wäre nicht Tim Pritlav, wenn er dies wie jeder andere Mensch täte. Im Kaffee oder im Apple Store. Zweitens ging er auch schwer, da Pritlav sich als Wahlheimat ausgerechnet die Stadt ausgesucht hat, der mittlerweile sogar Sulzbach etwas vormacht. Einen eigenen Apple Store. Seither gibt es unter dem Hassgeliebten Namen Mobermax einen äußerst unterhaltsamen, die biswahl strukturarmen Podcast, der immer wieder den Spagat zwischen detailliertem Nerd-Talk und dem kompletten Verzicht auf Recherche wagt. Mit Ausnahme einer einzigen Sendung, die er alleine bestritt, versammelt Tim Pritlav eine feste Gesprächsrunde um sich. Dennis Ahrens, nicht bekennender Bitcoin-Millionär und Darth-Vader-Imitator, kühlt sein Rechner biswahlen mit Rapsöl und kann Krypto auf ZFS mit De-Dublication. Zumindest fast. Max Winde, seines Zeichens Twitter-Legende, kann mehr als nur über Max reden. Der iOS-Entwickler wagt häufiger den Blick über das Apple-Universum hinaus, da er immer noch denkt, dass Apple Snacks das größte Ding sowieso nur eine Uhr sei. Hucke, die Stimme der Jugend, ist seit Episode 36 dabei. Obwohl er den Apple Podcast regelmäßig dazu missbraucht, private Gitarren-News zu platzieren, sind ihm hunderte Hörer für den epischen Control-Shift-Eject-Shortcut dankbar. Roddy ist das Nesthäkchen im Team, stieß er doch erst 2012 in die Runde hinzu. Der zweite Musiker im Team zeichnet sich für die Bildschirmklaviatur in Garage Band verantwortlich und braut sein eigenes Bier mit Sirup, der Fäden bis in den vierten Stock zieht. Dazu wird seit mittlerweile 40 Episoden die Sendung durch ein sogenanntes Previously eingeleitet, einem Zusammenschnitt von Szenen der letzten Folgen, verpackt in einem Szenario, das Spuren von Humor enthalten kann. Nun aber ab ins Funkhaus der Meterebene, denn auch in der Sendung 1 vor 100 wird das Team wieder das tun, was es am besten kann.
Herzlich willkommen bei BUM ZACK RETURN!
Und jetzt?
Machst du dann mal unterm Tisch.
Ich passe für euch die Lautstärke an.
Warum musst du das jetzt unterm Tisch machen?
Weil das jetzt alles unterm Tisch steht.
Ja, dann pass mal an.
Hab ich ja grad.
Es ist besser.
Ja, siehst du mal.
Hast du gut gemacht.
Demnächst auf ihrer V-Mode, aber dazu muss hier noch etwas gehackt werden.
Oh, die Technik schreitet schnell voran.
Die schreitet sehr langsam voran, aber sie schreitet immerhin noch.
Die Hackung ist nie beendet.
Ne, das stimmt.
Vor dem Hack ist nach dem Hack nebenbei. Ich habe in letzter Zeit so ein Talente zu irgendwelche Redewendungen umzudrehen.
Die Stimme der Jugend.
Das macht man heute so. Übrigens dieser Control-Shift-Eject. Dieses Ding, ich habe ja das auch in meinem Blog gepostet und das ist nach wie vor so in jedem Monat so by far the number one Blogpost aller Zeiten. Wird immer noch tagtäglich hundertfach über Google gefunden und Leute bedanken sich auch nach wie vor dafür.
Und der macht was? Das sagst du jetzt nochmal für alle Leute, die jetzt gerade erst zugeschaltet haben?
Wer per Tastatur also seinen Screen locken möchte auf dem Mac OS, der drückt Ctrl-Shift-Eject und hat einen instanten Screen lock. Eigentlich ist es Screen sleep, aber wenn man einen Bildschirmschoner hat und dann die Passwortabfrage oder sagt halt in den Security-Einstellungen, dass man immer ein Passwort haben will, wenn der Rechner aufwacht, dann funktioniert es im Prinzip auch als Screen lock. Die Alternative wäre sich in Keychain das Menü-Item oben einblenden zu lassen für die Keychain und dann jedes Mal zu klicken. Und das will ja keiner.
Das muss ich jetzt auch gleich nochmal ausprobieren, ob das überhaupt noch Gültigkeit hat.
Also bei mir hat das große Gültigkeit.
Was war das? Control-Shift?
Control-Shift. Wenn du daneben haust und den falschen Key, dann schaltest du auch gerne deinen Rechner aus.
Aber eine Sache ist dann auch gefährlich, wenn man eingestellt hat, dass nachdem der Screenblanker kommt, dass man irgendwie fünf oder zehn Sekunden warten will, bis wirklich nach dem Passwort gefragt ist, das ist leider trotzdem immer noch drin. Das heißt selbst wenn man sagt, man will jetzt den Screenblanker haben, dann muss man noch fünf Sekunden warten.
Also was auch immer man eingestellt hat.
Genau, die muss man noch warten. Das heißt, wenn man seinen Rechner plötzlich verlassen will, wenn man irgendwie losflitzen muss, dann muss man eigentlich noch fünf Sekunden beim Flitzen nochmal kurz umdrehen, dass auch keiner dran war.
Aber man kann es sozusagen auf Immediately stellen, aber man macht dann den Screensaver entsprechend später.
Ich hab mir die fünf Sekunden eingestellt, weil manchmal beobachte ich nur irgendwas stundenlang starr, dann muss ich nur schnell draufkloppen, wenn der Screenwacker kommt und muss nicht immer wieder meinen Passwort vergeben.
Der Hydraw im Chat sagt übrigens ganz richtig, dass ich diesen Shortcut nicht entdeckt hab. Nein, das haben wir hier in dieser Sendung, haben wir darüber gerantet und dann hat irgendwie ein Hörer oder irgendjemand auf Twitter, ich weiß nicht, ob es sogar im Chat war, irgendjemand hat gesagt, hier Alter, wieso machst du nicht Control Shift, Deject oder das war irgendwie vorher und dann haben wir es in der Sendung erwähnt. Also das ist ja auch ein bekannter Shortcut, den kann man auch im Internet finden. Der ist bloß nicht...
Das sind nur die Resonatoren.
Genau, der ist halt auf den meisten Shortcut-Listener nicht drauf. Ich habe eine gefunden, die habe ich glaube ich auch irgendwo gebucht gemacht. Die habe ich auch gerne gleich nochmal in den Chat, wo er mit drin war und ich war, also wir waren hier wirklich nur der Verstärker quasi für...
Na der von wem wir das haben, war ja auch schon nur Verstärker, weil komm, tut es halt von Apple.
Wir stehen auf den Schultern von Riesen.
So ist es.
Podcasting ist ein Community-Projekt. Da gibt es Leute hinter den Mikrofonen und welche hinter den Lautsprechern oder vor den Mikrofonen und vor den Lautsprechern, worum man das jetzt sehen will.
Im Chat ist jetzt hier doch mal bitte auch die Liste mit wirklich allen Shortcuts, die man... Also wahrscheinlich fehlen da auch wieder welche, aber da sind zumindest so die wirklich eine recht umfangreiche Liste von Shortcuts, die auch nicht unbedingt jetzt halt überall zu finden sind.
Oh ja, das scrollt sich schon eine ganze Weile, bis man da durch ist.
Die werden bestimmt in den nächsten US-10-Releases im Zuge der Vereinfachungen alle rausgenommen.
Alles nur noch durch Gesten.
Also einen, den ich noch mal kurz hervorheben will, der mir mal den Arsch gerettet hat, ist, es gibt ein Shortcut für, also zum Abschießen von der Frontmost Application.
Ja, der ist auch da drin.
Angenommen, man spielt irgendwie ein Spiel und du kommst auch nicht mehr in den Final und nichts und hier Apple Alt Escape zum Programm abschießen geht auch nicht. Dann gibt's Eins und Kürze, mit dem kannst du einfach das vordere laufende Programm wegballern.
Command, Option, Shift, Escape, für mehrere Sekunden halten.
Dann macht's plopp. Also zum Beispiel, das war früher immer wichtig, weil dieses Front-Row hieß es so, das ist ab und zu mal gecrashed und dann kamst du davon nicht mehr weg irgendwie so und damit konntest du es dann irgendwie abballern.
Diablo 3 als Spiel, wenn das gecrashed ist, ging auch in dieser Shotcut nicht.
Da brauchst du auch kein Diablo 3, das krieg ich auch manchmal mit dem Safari hin.
Ach so, spielst du immer noch eigentlich?
Da hat sich die Ausgabe ja gelungen.
Ah, das war, ja, ich hab sehr viele Friend-Requests bekommen und die sind jetzt bestimmt alle ganz enttäuscht, dass ich gar nicht so oft spiele, aber ich spiel schon immer noch und dann sind auch immer welche gleich da und fragen.
Dann musst du immer mit denen zocken, mit den Jungs.
Das ist ja cool, das als alleine rumzurennen.
Apropos Friend-Requests. Da ich in meinen Game-Center-Statistiken mit meinen sogenannten Freunden immer so schlecht abgeschnitten habe, habe ich irgendwann angefangen alle rauszuschmeißen.
Deine Freunde oder die anderen? Ich habe ja die anderen alle rausgeschmeißen, hier unseren 500er, da habe ich alle entfernt, weil da mit 500 Friends, da bist du auf jeden Fall nie irgendwo ganz oben.
Eben?
Ja, deswegen sind die alle rausgeflogen.
Und ich bin eh schon so ein Loser. Und dann noch das? Das geht gar nicht. Vor allem, wenn ich dann mal so wirklich so im Wahn mal wieder irgendein Game, oh geil, und dieser Modus hier, und boah, jetzt habe ich aber drei Stunden, und dann gucke ich so in die Score-Liste, und dann bist du nicht mehr unter den Top Ten. Ja, und vorletzterferner liefen so, und vor allem Leute haben dann so das hundertfache des Scores, und du fragst dich, wie das überhaupt geht. Also es ist mir überhaupt nicht erklärlich, wie man überhaupt so diese mental-taktile Kombination aufbringen kann, um dann diesen Score zu erreichen, und das frustriert einfach.
Also ich hatte ja Mahjong mal gespielt eine Zeit lang, da gibt es so ein schönes Mahjong-Spiel, was ewig nicht abgedeckt wird, aber ist immer noch das Schönste, finde ich, von allen. Und da gab es auch so, da habe ich auch gesehen, boah, krasse Scores, und das kann nicht mit rechten Dingen zu gehen.
Oh, da hast du diesen Bug gefunden.
Und dann habe ich ja auch so lange rumprobiert, bis ich halt so ein kleines Loophole gefunden habe, und dann halt, es war halt Motivation. Ich habe da irgendwie mich hoch motiviert gefühlt, auch dieses Loophole sozusagen zu finden, war ein richtiger Cheat, in dem Sinne war es jetzt ja auch nicht, aber ja, das kann auch Quelle der Motivation sein, wenn das, das entspricht auch sowieso mehr dem Hackergeist eigentlich.
Ja, der Hackergeist, der Hackergeist.
Der über unseren Köpfen kreist. Es ist ja bald Weihnachten, da muss man schon mal seine Gedichte wieder...
Oh ja, es ist bald Weihnachten. Nicht nur das, wir haben auch irgendwie die 100. Sendung vor uns. Wir haben immer noch keine Ahnung.
Das gibt es nicht einfach, wir machen einfach 101. 101?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, da fange ich gar nicht erst mit an. Das haben wir schon mal bei Chaos Radio gemacht, das war eine ganz schlechte Idee. 36 oder 63 oder die Trocken-Sendung. Ja, und weil wir so pathetisch drauf waren, haben wir dann sozusagen auch noch die Nummer ausgelassen. Und damit wir dann später richtig die 100. feiern könnten, haben wir dann nach der 99. nochmal diese 36. gemacht. Und dann haben irgendwie jahrelang Leute mir E-Mails geschickt, um mich darauf hinzuweisen, dass die Sortierung im Archiv falsch ist.
Also Nummer auslassen ist eine ganz blöde Idee.
Ja, die Nummer zählt einfach durch. Und wenn du bei 99 bist, gibts einfach nur die 100. Und tja, jetzt weiß ich auch nicht so richtig.
Oder wir stellen ein. Wir müssen ja kein 100 machen. Wir hören einfach auf jetzt.
Bei 99 schon. Klar.
Kurz vor dem Scheiß, was Zahnbrochen.
Das ist ja ein bisschen Freiheit vor dem Feind, oder?
Ist kein Feind mehr da.
Na die Frage ist ja nur, was tun. Ich meine, ich weiß, diverse Leute schreien jetzt hier sozusagen nach so einer Präsenz-Show. Da können wir dann mal nach der Sendung drüber nachdenken. Aber es wird halt ein bisschen knapp.
Ja, aber machen wir die dann in der Sendung?
Naja, bestimmt nicht in zwei Wochen, wenn wir so was machen würden.
Warum nicht?
Wie willst du das organisieren in zwei Wochen?
Die Leute müssen ja überhaupt erst mal aus aller Herren Länder anreisen.
Wie war denn so eine Live-Show?
Die fliegen ja allein von Neuseeland schon 24 Stunden. Also 30.
Ja, sind von den 14 Tagen schon zwei weg. Mit Sight-Zone und alles.
Wir sollten vielleicht erst mal über Max reden und dann gucken wir mal, was uns da noch so einfällt. Ja, machen wir mal ein neues Thema auf.
Wollen wir vielleicht erst mal eins zumachen, nämlich das Fenster?
Was ist denn jetzt mit dieser Fenner Strata Caster mit iOS, USB, Schnickschnack?
Gibt es Fenner Strato Caster mit iOS, USB, Schnickschnack?
Habt ihr nicht gelesen? Gibt es im App Store, wirklich.
Was?
Hier Tim hat eh zu tun, wir googeln nicht mal. Also im Store, also ich weiß nicht, ob es hier schon drin ist, aber es wurde auf jeden Fall viel davon erzählt. Fenner.
Ja, die ganzen Gitarren Herrscher, die werden jetzt auch digital.
Oder doch, ist es die?
Strato Caster Gitarre und dann kannst du das...
Ich hab gar keine Ahnung.
Das ist doch nicht mehr Rock'n'Roll, ey.
Das ist doch nicht Rock'n'Roll.
Gitarre mit USB, ich bitte dich.
Ihr seid doch hier eh nur noch am Tunen. Spielt ihr auch mal?
Diese anderen, weißt du, wir hatten ja noch über diese Gibson Robot Gitarre mal gesprochen, wo wir so mit Mechaniken selber getunen haben. Und dann gibt's ja jetzt von P-Way auch eine Gitarre. Aber die haben in die Gitarre so ein DSP-Chip eingebaut. Und wenn deine Gitarre verstimmt ist und du spielst, dann korrigiert dieser DSP-Chip sozusagen nur das Signal und tune. Das ist halt so ein Auto-Tune-Basic. Also es ist nicht physisch getuned, sondern ein Software. Das ist auch mal richtig... Uah!...
reudig.
Ja und was macht diese Fender USB-Gitarre? Das ist eine richtige Gitarre und die hat ein USB-Out und dann steckst du es ans iPad-Radar und kannst da...
Ich bin nicht der Experte oder ihr?
Also das ist eine physische Gitarre, die du im Apple Store kaufen kannst. Das ist nicht im App Store, sondern das ist eine echte Gitarre, ja?
Für 200 Dollar, das kann keine gute Gitarre sein. Ja, du kannst im Apple Store eine Gitarre kaufen.
Also du kannst sie an dein iPad anschließen und kannst dann da Zeug machen.
Mit Fender geht es da hin. Ich meine, wenn die sich für sowas hergeben... Entschuldigung, also das geht gar nicht.
Tja, da liegt die Zukunft.
Nein, da liegt sie nicht.
Die liegt da nieder vielleicht, aber...
Ich war ja schon mal wieder in so einem Apple Store.
Welchem?
Nein, nicht in Berlin.
Diesmal war ich in Oberhausen und kann jetzt behaupten, dass ich mehr als die Hälfte der deutschen Apple Stores kenne.
In Deutschland gibt es 11 oder wie viele gibt es?
10. Und ich kenne 6.
Es sind trotzdem mehr als die Hälfte. Wer Kopfrechner kann.
Ja, immer gut Mathematik an Bord zu haben. Zum Beispiel ein, der sich für einen hält.
Ich bin Ingenieur.
Dem ist ja auch nichts zu schwör.
Das behauptet man immer. Aber das heißt nur, dass sie fuschen.
So, dann schauen wir noch mal. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10. Und wie unser Intro schon korrekt hinwies.
Vielleicht haben die den Kuhdamm schon mit reingezählt.
Sulzbach hat einen. Und Berlin?
Wo ist Sulzbach?
Jetzt wage ich mich mal wieder ganz weit vor. Ganz weit vor. Das wird nichts mehr dieses Jahr mit dem Apple Store sein.
Das ist ja wohl eh klar, oder? Die Frage ist, ob sie es noch vom Großlughafen schaffen oder nicht. Nachdem es ja noch mal verschoben wird, haben sie wieder Chancen. Der Großlughafen wird wahrscheinlich auch verschoben.
Also ich würde mich da jetzt fast festlegen, weil was so die Vögelein sagen, ist nicht zu machen.
Die sind alle nach Süden geflogen, die haben schon aufgegeben.
Die sollen nicht auch so schnell gehen, ich meine, das kannst du ja vergessen. Das Jahr hat auch nur noch 5 Wochen.
Es hätte ja sein können, dass sie vielleicht fast fertig sind.
Hab ich aber auch nicht gehört.
Gerüst? Ja, hab ich auch. Also macht nicht auf. Bist mir ziemlich sicher. Also müssen wir im Teufel zugehen.
Benutzen sie denn wenigstens die Mitarbeiter, die sie schon gecastet haben, jetzt zum Verbessern der Maps? Oder machen sie das nicht?
Also ich meine, habt ihr diesen Spiegelartikel gelesen über die deutschen Apple Stores und wie es da so zugeht?
Ich abgegärt keinen Spiegel. Und online ist es ja nicht, oder?
Ich rasiere auch nicht, wie man sieht.
Online gibt es mittlerweile da so einen Button, aber ich glaube der verweist auch nur darauf, dass man sich doch bitte den Print kaufen soll. Den habe ich mir jetzt nicht deswegen gekauft.
Sondern?
Der lag so rum. Und dann habe ich mir mal diese Story durchgelesen. Und... Ja, sieht nicht so gut aus, ne?
Jetzt erzähl doch mal, ich hab ihn nicht gelesen.
Naja, die steigen da irgendwie auch so mit 10 Euro die Stunde da irgendwie ein. Und wenn du irgendwie schon so ein bisschen besser pokerst...
Im Apple Store sind die, die zu gut waren für McDonalds?
Ja, es ist einfach mal keine besonders königliche Bezahlung. Da stand jetzt nichts über diese Genius-Geschichte. Genius werden glaube ich besser bezahlt, aber ich weiß nicht wie. Aber dann waren da irgendwie auch so Nummern drin.
10 Euro die Stunde, da kriegst du ja... Achso, das ist ja wirklich... Und das ist eine Schublade.
Bei McDonalds kriegen sie 8, wenn ich das mal richtig verstanden habe.
Ja, und ich glaube bei McDonalds dürfen die zwischendurch auch mal trinken und so. Also da waren ja irgendwie so Sachen in dem Artikel, da rollen sich einem schon so ein bisschen die Fußnägel hoch. Und vor allem, und das ist etwas, was ich auch schon im Vorfeld, schon vor einiger Zeit gehört habe, haben die wirklich überall Kamera-Bewachung. Also irgendwie auch so in den etwas persönlicheren Rückzugsräumen und so weiter. Und dann stand in dem Artikel, dass wenn die aus dem Laden rausgehen, da dachte ich auch wirklich, jetzt geht's noch irgendwie, dann müssen sie echt diesem Security Guard, die Mitarbeiter, müssen dem Security Guard irgendwie ihr Apple Gear zeigen, so die iPhones und so, die sie irgendwie am Körper haben, mit Seriennummern, um zu zeigen, dass sie jetzt gerade nichts geklaut haben. Dass man jeden Tag immer, hallo?
Das sorgt doch höchstens dafür, dass die keine Apple-Teile mehr mit sich rumschleppen, weil da hast du nämlich keinen Bock drauf. Aber ehrlich, machen wir uns mal nichts vor. Ich meine, Verkaufsjobs sind anscheinend nun mal nicht so gut bezahlt, oder ist es halt einfach so?
Ja gut, aber ich meine, sollte es schon einen Unterschied machen, ob du jetzt für so eine Low-Budget-Scheiß-drauf-Firma arbeitest oder für die Firma, die pro Quadratmeter doppelt so viel Umsatz macht, wie dennächst bessere Super-Luxus-Laden.
Trotzdem ihren Angestellten nur 10 Euro geben.
Ja, so Zahlen wie Wulfers, aber nehmen wie...
Was kriegen denn so Media-Marktleute?
Keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe da recht keine Ahnung.
So Saturn Media-Markt, die sind doch bestimmt auch eher nicht so toll bezahlt, oder?
Ich weiß ja nicht, was qualifiziert er denn für diesen Job?
Naja, du musst da erstmal durch diese Brainwash-Geschichte da durchmarschieren.
Die Brainwash-Anlage.
Die haben ja auch die Angular-Leute mit Ausbildung ein oder ohne. Ich kenn mich da nicht so aus.
Ich glaube, du musst jetzt nicht gerade studiert haben, um irgendwie iPhones zu verkaufen. Das ist für dich glaube ich nicht so wichtig.
Aber man kann ja schon so eine kaufmännische Ausbildung haben. So was gibt es ja. Aber das ist dann nicht Verkäufer, Verkaufmann ist noch was anderes.
Ja, dann leitest du Geschäfte. Also das ist ja eine andere Geschichte. Kaufmann und Verkäufer.
Mich hat gerade ein, mir hat auch gerade ein Vögelchen, was zum Apple Store Berlin zugezwitschert. Und zwar angeblich sind die Core Trainings jetzt in Berlin beendet und die Leute werden wohl vorerst die nächsten sechs Wochen in anderen Läden in Deutschland eingesetzt. Und dann ist erstmal Urlaub von Apple vorgeschrieben.
Also Februar, März.
Bezahlter Urlaub oder unbezahlter Urlaub?
Ja, unbezahlt. Weihnachtsgeld gibt es auch nicht, Urlaubsgeld gibt es keins. Nichts. Keine Boni, nicht mal eine Weihnachtsfeier.
Direkt zur Berlinale haben sie Urlaub.
Also das Scheißteil macht nicht auf. Das ist auch immer noch irgendwie eine Baustelle im Wesentlichen.
Genau, erst im Frühjahr steht er auch in diesem Vögelchen.
Ja, ich denke auch. Also ich habe jetzt noch keine konkrete Zahl gehört, wann es sein soll. Ich kann nur auf Basis meiner Informationen eine Einschätzung machen, dass es nicht technisch möglich ist, dass sie eröffnet. Bis dahin.
Ich würde ja gerade sogar mal hingehen, weil das Netzteil von meinem iPhone 5 geht.
Oh, ich hätte viele Gründe, da hinzugehen. Oh, ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mittlerweile fast kein einziges Gerät mehr hier, was nicht dringend Bedarf hat. Deswegen bin ich auch in diesen Apple Store in Oberhausen reingeladen. Vorher dachte ich so dumm die dumm. Und ich habe mich so ein bisschen gewundert, weil ich...
Dumm Kekse hast du nicht mehr gesagt?
Dumm die dumm Kekse, Alter.
Naja, ich habe ja hier ein Issue mit meinem iPhone 5. Da ist nämlich schlicht und ergreifend die Kopfhörerbuchse verreckt.
Ach.
Einfach defunkt. Passend genau zehn Minuten gerade auf dem Weg zum Flughafen.
Ach stimmt, hat es ja getweetet.
Getwitterte ich. Wie ich twittete.
Und als du ausgestiegen bist, hast du getestet, ob es auch wieder geht?
Nee, es funktioniert bis heute nicht. Und das war aber nicht so ganz so schlimm, weil ich hatte ja noch mein iPhone 4 mit dabei. Mein Unlocked-iPhone 4, was ich gedachte als Hotspot einzusetzen, weil diese ganzen Pre-Pay-Tarife in Kolumbien sind nämlich eigentlich ganz cool. Du kannst da wirklich für relativ wenig Geld einfach mal passable Internet-Connectivity kaufen. So, was weiß ich, gibst sowas wie 20 Euro aus und dann hast du da so No-Question-Ask, kriegst du da im Supermarkt deine SIM-Karte und da sind dann mal so 3, 5, 10 GB Daten drauf. Hallo, O2, Hallo, E+, da ist keiner mehr. Hallo, Telekom, Hallo, Odafon, da ist keiner mehr.
Ist ja aber auch ein bisschen Unterschied, 20 Euro ist in Kolumbien wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen mehr wert als hier. Die passen ihre Preise ja schon immer so ein bisschen an.
Ja, aber es gibt diese Produkte.
Also du meinst hier so Gigabyte-On-Surrounde.
Du kannst hier nicht in den Supermarkt gehen und sagen, gib mir mal eine 10 GB Pre-Pay-Karte. Du kannst dich in die Wüste stellen und schreien. Das kannst du machen. Geiles Echo. Jetzt kommt es aber noch besser. Ich kaufe dann diese Karte. War sogar eine Micro-SIM. Steck die in mein iPhone 4 rein. Und was sagt denn dieses iPhone 4? Ich will aktiviert werden.
Ich dachte, da hast du eine Karte reingesteckt.
Wenn du die Karte tauscht, will er neu aktiviert werden?
Was?
Was geht denn jetzt ab?
Das dachte ich mir auch. Was geht denn jetzt ab? Mein Begleiter hatte auch ein iPhone, hat mir eben so einen Hotspot eingeschaltet, sodass ich quasi so kurzfristig Internet hatte und dann durch diesen Aktivierungsprozess durchgehen konnte. Und dann sagt er, ja, jetzt aktivieren. Und dann so, ich aktiviere dich nicht. Dann habe ich so, bitte, hallo, was? Das ist ein Unlocked Phone. Ich habe das schon mit mehreren anderen Betreibern. Also es war halt mal, kam es aus England und ich vermute, es kam von O2. Weil O2 waren damals die, die es verkauft haben. Aber ich habe es nicht selbst persönlich da gekauft, sondern ich habe es über so einen Umweg, über so einen Reseller bekommen.
Du auch, ja. Ich meine, es kam auch aus London.
Und es lässt sich mittlerweile auch gar nicht mehr so richtig. Zumindest habe ich noch keine zuverlässige Information darüber. Da komme ich gleich noch zu. So, und dann habe ich über einen freundlichen Kontakt mit Zugang zu Apple-Datenbanken herausgefunden, was mit diesem Telefon ist. Und dieses Telefon ist tatsächlich doch gelockt, aber nicht auf eine SIM-Karte und auch nicht auf einen Provider, sondern auf EMEA. Europe, Middle East, Asia. Es gibt tatsächlich iPhones, die einen Region-Lock haben. Das sind Telefone, die kannst du überall in Europa, überall in Middle East und überall in Asia mit einem...
EMEA ist, glaube ich, Afrika, nicht Asien.
Afrika?
Was ist denn das für eine Scheiße?
Du hast recht. Europe, Middle East und Afrika, also noch schlimmer. Das heißt, ich könnte es noch nicht mal in Asien, geschweige denn Australien, aber eben auch nicht in Südamerika betreiben. Ja, was ist denn das für eine Scheiße? Und jetzt kommt noch das Geilste. Apple kann dieses Lock nicht zurücknehmen, sondern nur der Provider. Da hab ich natürlich geguckt, bei O2 in UK, wie es denn so ist. Meinen Sie, ja, kein Problem, nach zwei Jahren kannst du problemlos anlocken, wenn da eine SIM-Karte von uns drin ist, mit meinem Vertrag und geben sie hier ein und tralala.
Weißt du, also wirklich.
Nochmal langsam. Dein Telefon hast du wo gekauft in England?
Na wie gesagt, ich hab es über einen deutschen Reseller, die sich selbst in England besorgt haben.
Also diese kleinen Willigbuden, die ich verstehe.
Genau, die es jetzt nicht mehr so richtig gibt. Genau.
Das heißt dann ich mein Telefon aus England mir, also ich hab es glaube ich bei Apple direkt bestellt, hab es aber zu einer englischen Adresse liefern lassen. Das heißt ich hab ein Unlockedes, was komplett unlocked ist.
Hoffe ich.
Wenn es wirklich von Apple war?
Na ich flieg schnell mal rüber demnächst. Wo warst du, Kolumbien? Ich flieg mal rüber, test es mal.
Oh Gott, das kann ja auch nicht wahr sein.
Das ist geil, oder?
Das heißt, ich hab totaler Dreck?
Ja natürlich ist das ja totaler Dreck.
Da gehört Apple für erschossen.
Ja fuck you. Und vor allem, ich meine, hier erzählen sie einem noch nicht mal. Und vor allem, warum bitte, warum kann Apple das nicht selbst...
Na könnten technisch wahrscheinlich schon.
Nein, da war sogar echt die Aussage, ja also technisch im Sinne von, dass sie es natürlich als Hersteller dieses Phone machen können.
Die haben schon die Datenbank dafür, sonst müsste es der bei denen nicht aktivieren. Aber die haben halt ein Deal mit dem Verticker da.
Ein Apple Store kann es nicht tun.
Ja, die dürfen nicht.
Sie haben sozusagen keinerlei Zugang, dürfen nicht und die Verträge... Genau. Das weiß ja dann auch irgendwie keiner.
Ja, wenigstens bei den iTunes könnte ja mal so eine Meldung kommen, hier bist du im falschen Land, ist nicht. Also das könnten sie ja wenigstens machen. Wenn sie schon so eine... Also das Schlimmste ist auch immer...
Sie können es einem zumindest mal sagen, aber nur so, ne ich aktiviere mich nicht.
Genau. Also nicht sagen warum ist irgendwie das Letzte. Aber dieses e mehr habe ich schon öfter irgendwo gelesen. Ich würde mich jetzt nicht wundern, wenn ich bei dem iPhone jetzt hier, bei dem 5er oder bei dem 4er auch schon, wenn man da im Kleingedruckten liest, dass es Unlocked für EMEA, Region, Tralala ist.
Nee, das ist so eine typische Ami-Einteilung. Die teilen die Welt halt in Amerika, Kampen, EMEA und Asien ein.
Ich meine, Geh'n Europäer fliegen nicht mal rüber, oder was? Und wollen ihr Telefon benutzen?
Doch, aber da benutzt du mal schön deine Karte von zuhause, damit die Provider sich da eine Mark verdienen können, weil da verdienen die nämlich so richtig.
Ja, aber warte, du hast gesagt, das ist nicht Provider-locked, und das heißt, dass es ja dort drüben grundsätzlich gar nicht geht, egal was du machst oder wie.
Ich darf sozusagen jeden Provider aus Europa, Middle East und Afrika nutzen, egal wo. Aber ich muss halt eine Karte dieses Providers haben.
Aber wie sinnlos ist das?
Na ja, was heißt sinnlos? Es ist halt so ein, ja, plus, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, wurden diese Telefone, also ich hab noch nie, noch nie davon gehört, dass es überhaupt einen Region-Log gibt. Ja, noch nie hab ich davon gehört.
Doch, bei der DVD. Regionalcode 2 ist da drauf.
Ja. Wir fühlen den Schmerz.
Ihr fühlt den Schmerz.
Und was hast du dann gemacht?
Na, ich hatte dann ein geprägtes iPhone, weil ich hatte nämlich auch dummerweise keine SIM-Karte. Also ich hätte jetzt meine Nano-Karte aus dem 5, hätte ich mir dann sozusagen noch mit Schere und Messer einen Nano-to-Micro-SIM-Tray machen müssen, um das wieder zu aktivieren. Da hatte ich dann irgendwie keinen Bock drauf, nachdem ich vorher schon so eine ähnliche Aktion und so weiter gemacht hatte. War dann nicht so schlimm, weil ich brauchte das ja jetzt nicht unbedingt dringend im Sinne von, dass ich jetzt gar keine Kommunikation mehr gehabt hätte, weil ich hatte ja noch meinen iPhone 5, damit war ich dann auf den Straßen nicht online. Aber das ist in Kolumbien jetzt wiederum auch nicht so unbedingt das Problem, weil halt iOS-Maps so gut cashed, also hat es dann irgendwann mal Bogota einfach im Cache und das hat funktioniert. Und abgesehen davon hat da einfach wirklich jeder Scheißladen WLAN. Also echt jedes Kaffee.
Das ist wie in Bulgarien.
Hat da einfach mal freies WLAN. Ja und auch die Hotels. Ich meine, da muss echt 10.000 Kilometer fliegen. Und ich zitterte schon so ein bisschen, weil ich mir dachte, oh Gott, wenn das mit dem Hotel, weißt du ja, wie das immer ist, so mit ja, Internet haben wir und so.
Wenn ich da meine Dosis nicht kriege.
Ja, dann erzählen wir dir irgendwelche abenteuerlichen Geschichten, wie du jetzt Internet machst mit irgendwie 30 Euro pro Stunde oder keine Ahnung oder irgendwelchen Keys mit Windows-Sonderzeichen oder so, die du nicht eingeben kannst, alles schon gesehen. Oder halt irgendein Schmu, was ja das Schlimmste ist, mit so WLANs, die dich dann irgendwie nach Inaktivität immer wieder rauskicken und wo du dann alle 10 Minuten irgendwelche Catch-Pages kriegst. Also da möchte ich ja auch wirklich, da.
Und das heißt, es waren die ganze Zeit unverschlüsselte WLANs, ja?
Nicht nur unverschlüsselt, auch verschlüsselt. Also häufiger war es so, dass du einfach so den Key erfragst.
Und wie heißt Key-Erfragen auf Spanisch?
Los kios, por favor.
Ich glaube, mit Codigo kommt man da ganz gut vorwärts. Codigo.
Gib Stoff, Alter.
Ja, oder du guckst einfach verzweifelt, machst du das touristische iPhone und sagst, Internet. Meistens tragen sie dir den Key schon mit einem Kaffee an den Tisch.
Mit einer Leinenkugel.
Wenn ich da reinkomme, habe ich ja schon so diesen gehetzten Internetblick. Weißt du? So Schweiß auf der Stirn und den Blick so an der Wand entlang. Wo sind denn hier die Steckdosen? Daran erkennst du ja eigentlich, den Touristen heutzutage. Ja, also insofern war das irgendwie nicht so eine geile Experience so. Und ich fühle mich da schon so ein bisschen gefickt, weil das war jetzt einfach mal nicht der Deal. Vor allem, wenn man so ein scheiß Premium-Teil kauft und es dann noch nicht mal erzählt bekommt.
Wie gesagt, ich würde mich nicht verwundern, wenn es wirklich mehr... Versteht man ja auch nicht, hat man nie nachgeguckt, was das heißt und es so im Kleingedruckten steht.
Und vor allem, was soll dieser Kack mit nur der Provider kann freischalten?
Wir machen halt so ein Deals mit. Also Apple will halt die grauen Importe natürlich verringern. Das heißt, wenn da einer irgendwie...
Apple ist das glaube ich scheißegal. Ob die nun irgendwie da oder da ein Telefon... Ne, denen ist das wirklich scheißegal.
Ja, inzwischen vielleicht. Vielleicht war es dir nicht scheißegal, weil die anderen ja auch noch Deals mit denen haben. Telekom, Orange oder wie auch immer sagt, naja, wenn jetzt hier Unlocked iPhones in Europa verkauft, dann haben wir ja die Arschkarte. Und dann hat Apple gesagt, na ist klar, dann verkaufen wir halt hier nur EMEA-Locked Phones.
Ja, also ich meine, ich frage mich, wie lange das schon läuft und ob es auch noch andere gab. Ja, also was ist hier mit den U2-Telefonen, die hier verkauft werden, in Deutschland, die angeblich unlocked sind. Sind die wirklich unlocked oder haben sie nur keinen Provider-Lock?
Tja, gute Frage. Ich habe meins direkt bei Apple gekauft. Da müsste man das Kleingedruckte jetzt lesen.
Ich kaufe mir jetzt hier so einen Huawei-WLAN-Teil. Ich habe Schnauze voll.
Und dann?
Ja, dann kannst du einfach eine SIM-Karte im Supermarkt kaufen, steckst sie rein, hast ein WLAN, das Internet ist fertig.
Ist dann so eine Mini-Basis-Station mit GSM-Karte oder was?
Und Batterie?
80 Euro und fertig. Ja, die hat auch Batterie. Also ich habe jetzt noch nicht so viele Erfahrungen damit, aber das funktioniert wohl schon irgendwie.
Das iPhone 5 kannst du in Amiland auch nicht unlockt kaufen, ne?
Immer noch nicht? Nein, demnächst dann wohl. Also ich glaube, die haben da irgendeine Karenzzeit von ein paar Monaten. Jaja, nach ein paar Monaten verkaufen sie es dann unlockt.
Du musst mal nach iPhone und e-Mail suchen und vielleicht gibt es da was.
Das klang jetzt auf jeden Fall schon mal total legit.
Ja, außerdem hast du noch 10.000 Euro geerbt.
Gib mir nur Zugriff auf irgendwas. Achso, noch die andere Frage, die ich hatte. Warum hast du dein iPhone 4 nicht gejailbreakt?
Warum sollte ich das tun?
Na, weil es dann da einen Unlock gibt?
Ich will die Security meines Telefons nicht absenken.
Ist das denn so ein Unlock?
Ja, aber als Notlösung erstmal, damit du dafür zwei Wochen...
Na, so groß war die Not nicht.
Ah, also doch nicht.
Die Not war jetzt nicht so groß. Es war nur generell einfach das Entsetzen darüber, dass mir da einfach was verkauft wurde, auf dem nicht drauf stand, was es war. Weil ich hab da auch irgendwie Premium für bezahlt, dann will ich auch Premium kriegen.
Wir laden mal den Tim Cook hier zum Kreuzverhör ein. Ich schreib ihm mal eine Mail nachher.
Dann muss ich hier die Watschen abholen.
Und dann knöpfen wir uns den Burschen mal vor. Was ist das denn?
Willst du nicht wissen.
Wir hatten da vorletzte Sendung mal so ein Video, da kam das drin vor.
Das war eigentlich in unserer Sendung.
Voll letzte Sendung?
Na ja, das mit dem iPhone 5. Cinco? Wo der Steve Jobs, der animierte Steve Jobs irgendwie aus dem Boden macht und dann irgendwie einen absinkt.
Weiß ich nicht.
Du schwänzt ja von Zeit zu Zeit.
Ich weiß gar nicht. Ich war jetzt total am Rand zu 2D-Land. Genau, da war Clemens, da war ich nicht.
Welche war das?
Die 96.
Die 96. Aber ich erkläre dir jetzt trotzdem nicht, was T-Banging ist. Das kannst du im Internet nachschlagen. So, wollen wir mal über Apple reden?
Oh ja, wenn es sein muss.
Gibt es was Neues?
Naja, ein bisschen. Na, der neue König wurde außer Korn. Ist jetzt der King.
Nee, der King ist alle cook.
Der ist mehr der Geschäftsführer.
Das ist der neue Schlangenzunge, meinst du?
Schlangenzunge?
Nee, der Johnny Alf ist der neue Steve. Und Tim bleibt Tim. Mal ganz ehrlich, Tim ist doch nicht in der Lage, hier den Steve zu machen.
Johnny Alf macht den Steve.
Aber nicht auf der Bühne.
Der hat schon vorher den Steve gemacht. Vorher waren es die beiden, die immer zusammen gesessen haben und sich den Scheiß der Zukunft ausgedacht haben. Jetzt denkt er sich halt, ist der Alf alleine aus?
Ja, aber ich glaube, der Koch hat trotzdem das ganz oben an der Spitze.
Ja, der bleibt oben an der Spitze. Nur die Rollenverteilung ist halt die gleiche.
Der hat jetzt halt des Designzeugs wieder gesagt, hier Johnny, du bist jetzt hier Chef und Dolle Forster ist raus.
Ja, was halten wir denn davon? Also ich meine, ich fand ja, vielleicht ist das eine falsche Einschätzung, aber als ich diesen Forster das erste Mal überhaupt auf der Bühne gesehen habe, ich hab den irgendwie nie realisiert, dass der da in dem Unternehmen irgendwas zu sagen hat.
Doch, doch, der ist da schon vor lange dabei.
Naja, weiß ich auch, dass der lange dabei war, aber gesehen hab ich ihn halt so nie. Weil die Keynotes liefen einfach über Jahre im Wesentlichen eigentlich immer nur auf ihn und Phil Schiller hinaus und ab und zu mal irgendein anderer Scherge, der aus irgendeiner Abteilung berichten durfte. Und dann halt die ganzen anderen Hansels und CEOs von anderen Firmen, die sich da lächerlich gemacht haben. Aber es war jetzt nicht so, dass sie da so eine ganze Riege von Division-Chiefs irgendwie auf die Bühne gebracht haben. Das ist so ein Spaß, den sie eigentlich erst seit Steve richtig krank geworden ist.
Nee, der Forster war doch schon ab 2008 oder so iOS Senior Tralala oder Komplettchef irgendwie.
Aber wann war der das erste Mal auf einer Kino? Das ist halt noch nicht so lange her.
Ich glaube, 2, 3 oder so.
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Ja, gut, das ist auch schon ja vor Jahren her. Ach echt? Der ist ja auch voll jung. Ich meine, muss ja erstmal hocharbeiten.
Ja gut, aber der ist sozusagen ewig dabei und ich habe ihn ewig nicht zur Kenntnis genommen. Und dann habe ich ihn das erste Mal gesehen und ich dachte mir, so was ist denn das für ein Typ?
Ich fand den immer cool.
Ich weiß nicht, ich fand den creepy.
Das ist kein Hippie. Und ich finde ja, ich habe ja die These des IT-Leute.
Cislord?
Star Wars, Mann. Kennst du nicht diese Disney-Sendung?
Ja, ich habe das jetzt sehr deutsch ausgesprochen. Irgendwie, der hat so eine creepy Aura. Also irgendwie, ich habe ja immer so die These, dass so IT-Leute, die brauchen so einen gewissen Anteil Hippie in sich drin, um so cool zu sein.
Ja, der ist mehr so auf der Elvis-Welle, richtig?
Ja, und der ist nicht Hippie und der ist irgendwie, der ist so...
Nee, der ist mehr so ein Rockabilly-Typ. Aber ich fand den trotzdem eigentlich immer irgendwie cool. Aber wenn der wirklich schuld ist an diesem, wie ist das Wort, Skeu...
Skeuomorphic.
Skeuomorphic. Wenn der daran schuld ist, dann bin ich auch froh, dass er weg ist.
Also übers Skeu können wir gleich nochmal separat reden.
Du musst zugeben, er war der einzige außer Steve, der auf der Bühne was hergemacht hat.
Deswegen, ich fand den eigentlich auch immer cool.
Ich fand den Phil Schiller macht durchaus was her.
Ich finde...
Inzwischen. Inzwischen. Früher nicht.
Inzwischen. Aber früher hatte man immer so das Gefühl, meine Herren, wie viel Stöcke hat der denn im Arsch?
Aber der Scott, der war schon immer irgendwie so schleimig, eklig. Ich weiß nicht, ich konnte den nie...
Gollum.
Dass der wirklich was hermacht.
Das erinnere mich auch an so einen anderen creepy Hollywood-Schauspieler. Ich komme das die ganze Zeit nicht auf den Namen der auch so.
Ja, hier der mit den dicken Augen. Warte, der hat doch bei Reservoir Dogs und so mitgespielt. Warte, wie heißt der?
Kann sein.
Nee, der andere. Wie heißt der denn? Der ist ganz bekannt.
Ach, der so ein bisschen dickere, so ein bisschen stemmige Art?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, warte.
Ich hab's gleich.
Steve Buschkemi schlägt hier jemand im Chat vor.
Was? Steve Buschkemi oder Buschkemi oder wie auch immer der da.
Oh ja, stimmt. Steve Buschkemi.
Der von Empire Dinghans?
Genau, den meinte ich. An den hat er mich immer erinnert. Der sieht total aus wie Scott Fossel. Also erst dachte ich irgendwie, das wär der.
Doch, der hat so, ich kann das nachvollziehen, der hat schon so Züge. Also es ist nicht so wie eineige Zwillinge, aber ich kann diesen Vergleich nachvollziehen.
Okay, aber es sind ja eher so persönliche Dinge, die ihr da meint. Aber ich meine, so technisch und vortragsmäßig war er doch cool.
Seine Vorträge waren auch schleimig.
Puss Semi spricht man das wohl aus.
Ist auch egal, geht jetzt um den Vorstyle. Spielt man durch Vorstyle aus.
Aber die sind doch irgendwie, die sind doch irgendwie separated at birth.
Also der Steve, der kann auf jeden Fall auch prima creepy Characters spielen.
Ja, also ich meine, ich will ja nicht, ich will ja nicht jetzt hier vom Äußeren irgendwie schließen auf Inneres, so. Keine Ahnung, also ich war mir irgendwie immer nicht so richtig sicher, ob der da irgendwie richtig ist. So, jetzt will ich ja auch nicht behaupten, ich hab schon mal so gewusst, Tatsache ist...
Ja, also sag mal so, hippie war er auf jeden Fall nicht.
Genau, und er war sicherlich ein streitbarer Charakter und es ist auch etwas sehr schwer zu urteilen, für was er nun wirklich verantwortlich war oder nicht. Jetzt können wir uns nur auf das beziehen.
Na der ist auf jeden Fall für die Stichennähte in hier... Ja klar, haben sie doch gesagt. Der ist für dieses Geo-Ding ganz verantwortlich da, der ist schuld. Und der ist jetzt raus, das heißt demnächst... Alles......kommen dann die Apps raus, weil ich hab auch mal verglichen hier, zum Beispiel bei FanFriends, diese Ledernaht da oben, die macht tatsächlich den Balken oben ein Stück breiter, das heißt, die haben wieder mal gegen ihre Guidelines verstoßen und sogar noch extra Platz genommen, damit diese scheiße Ledernaht da hinpasst, ja? Und das fällt dann mal weg. Alle feiern.
Also tasteless, ne?
Also weil, das geht gar nicht, dieses Lederzeug da und so...
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum die sich immer alle so an... Ehrlich gesagt, ich finde dieses Lederzeug, finde ich gar nicht so schlimm.
Doch, horrible, was findest du denn schlimm?
Schlimm finde ich dieses iCal. Diese Abrisskante.
Aber diesmal ist es nicht...
iCal, finde ich, geht noch ganz schlimm. Das ist das Adressbuch, was ein Buch ist, was man nicht blättern kann.
Sondern wo man...
Wir schweigen denn ordentlich Recize.
Wo man links was auswählt und rechts scrollt.
Aber ihr wisst schon, dass der Vorstel nur iOS gemacht hat, ja?
Nee, insofern, ich finde ja diesen Skeu-Morphismus, finde ich, nicht grundsätzlich falsch. Also ich finde es nicht grundsätzlich falsch, dass man sich im richtigen Moment an realen Objekten orientiert, um sofort klarzumachen, wie es sich bedient. Wenn das, was das reale Objekt macht, auch genau das ist, was man jetzt in dem Moment möchte. Wie zum Beispiel ein Taschenrechner. Der ist ja auch Skeu-Morph bis zum Anschlag.
Naja, nicht wirklich.
Doch. Ich meine, der ist ein Taschenrechner unter iOS.
Du hast halt Tasten, wo Zahlen draufstehen. Das ist ja was anderes, als ob da eine Ledernaht ist, die total keinen Sinn macht.
Moment, du kannst das anders machen. Du kannst auch DC auf der Kommando-Zeile starten. Da hast du auch einen Taschenrechner.
Aber nicht auf dem iPhone.
Man könnte es aber auch auf dem iPhone so machen. Du könntest auch einen ganz anderen Taschenrechner machen. Nur ist es natürlich Blödsinn, weil so viele Leute, weil das Konzept Taschenrechner so dermaßen auf genau diese Anwendungssituation passt, dass es geradezu fräfel wäre, sich da jetzt noch was komplett anderes einfallen zu lassen. Nur ist bei diesem Adressbuch, wie Roddy schon richtig sagt, sieht es ja nur so aus wie, aber hat weder irgendeine Eigenschaft in der Bedienung von einem Buch, noch ist Buch in dem Moment, ich meine kein Schwanz schreibt seine Adressen in ein Buch.
Und die ohne Schwanz schon oder?
Doch es gibt so Leute.
Ja, aber das gehört nun wirklich zu diesen Dingen, darauf wollte ich hinaus, die man einfach mittlerweile auf dem Computer einfach gerne anders machen möchte, weil nämlich die alte Art und Weise zu machen, einfach mit zu vielen Nachteilen. Genauso wie bei dem Kalender mit diesen abgerissenen Blättern.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn es so aussehen würde wie ein Rolodex, dann wäre es zwar geomorphisch auch wie so ein Objekt, was der Sache näherkommt, aber das wäre auch ganz fürchterlich.
Solche Anwendungen findest du im abstract?
Ja, ich weiß, dass man solche Anwendungen findet, aber ich fände es auch schlimm. Rolodex, du weißt nicht, was Rolodex ist?
Das ist so, wo die Karten, wo so mir das Karten mit einer Stanz...
Also so ein rundes Ding, was du am Arbeitsamt und so liest.
Ja, wo du so drehen kannst und dann hängen da so Karten drin, die du so umsortieren kannst.
Behörden.
Ja, gut, aber der ist jetzt weg und das heißt, demnächst hoffe ich, wird alles schicker und schöner. Genau, also ich hoffe.
Ich hoffe auch.
Also ein bisschen wieder weniger. Auch diese komische, diese Raufasertapeten-Hintergründe hier. Ja, hier auch gerade hier bei dieses Muster, was halt kommt auf OS X, wenn man hier den Notification Panel da sich holt.
Da hab ich schon 23 Monate bestimmt nicht rauf gekriegt.
Braucht auch niemand, glaube ich. Irgendwie nicht so wirklich.
Ach du meinst das Linen.
Das Resopal.
Ja, Linen, Linen.
Die Leinwand.
Ich finde es sieht aus wie ein Resopal.
Ich finde es ist einfach total unnötig.
Ich will mehr Future.
Ich will nicht, dass mein Computer nicht nach Computer aussieht.
Na ja nun.
Also an dem Lein störe ich mich noch am allerwenigsten, aber ich hätte es tatsächlich.
Ja, aber das sind alle Zusammenhalt.
Ich hätte gerne wieder so ein bisschen mehr, es sollte sich ein bisschen mehr wieder nach Zukunft anfühlen. So ein moderner, so ein Schritt vorwärts und nicht ein Schritt rückwärts halten.
Ja, das stört mich auch enorm.
Sollen wir mal ein Beispiel bei Microsoft nehmen?
Woran konkret?
Also man kann das.
Die sind doch voll technisch geworden. Da sieht doch nichts aus wie früher.
Bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei diesem Reh-Org. Es kann ja auch sein, dass irgendjemand in den letzten drei Wochen sein Internet noch nicht eingeschaltet hat und überhaupt nicht weiß, worum es geht. Fassen wir nochmal kurz zusammen, was passiert ist. Also Tim Cook hat irgendwie zwei Leute rausgeschmissen. Nämlich diesen Braut, den Chef von Retail, der ist geflogen.
Der war aber noch nicht so lange da, oder?
Nö, der war nur ein paar Monate da und der hat gleich irgendwie alles verkackt. Der hat irgendwie Leute rausgeschmissen an den Apple Store und wollte da irgendwie billig, billig, billig.
Wahrscheinlich war der für den Apple Store im Kuhdamm zuständig.
Genau, da war ja Tim Cook selber da und hat das Desaster gesehen. Na, war's das? Ja, ich weiß. Und dann... Ah? Ja, er war da.
Wirklich?
Tim Cook himself war...
Warum hat er nicht mal bei uns reingeschaut?
Er war halt gerade nicht da.
Macht er nächste Sendung.
Muss man halt alleine gehen.
Ich schreib ihm mal eine Mail nachher.
So, was ist passiert?
Also...
Also der Retail-Typ, den können wir auch gleich vergessen. Forstel ist aber auch entbunden worden. Sein direkter Job wurde jetzt an den Verpincher, an Herrn Craig Federighi, der immer so zittert. Ferengi? Ferengi, der immer so zittert, genau. Ja, der ein bisschen angestrengt war, aber der wohl an sich ein ganz ausgewogener, ruhiger Typ ist. Und ich hab so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass sie sich jetzt so auf ausgewogene, ruhige Typen irgendwie einschießen. Weil der Phil Schiller ist halt so drauf und dieser Eddy Cue scheint auch so drauf zu sein. Ja, es sind alles so entspannte...
Die müssen ja auch miteinander klarkommen. Was noch interessant war, ist ja der Grund, was sie sagten, warum der Forster halt raus ist. Weil die ersten Gründe, die sie spekuliert haben, ist, dass er angeblich die Meldungen nicht unterschreiben wollte, wo sich Tim Cook über Maps irgendwie entschuldigt hat, dass ja alles so grauenhaft ist. Und wenn der Forster da ja irgendwie, der ist ja iOS-Software-Oberchief gewesen, das wäre sozusagen seine Baustelle und seiner Dame hinten. Nee, da entschuldige ich mich nicht, weil ich auch so ein bisschen verstehen kann, weil Programm an sich ist ja eigentlich schon, okay, da ging ja mehr um die Daten eigentlich, oder?
Die App, naja gut, die App war ja in dem Sinne noch nicht mal richtig neu, also außerhalb des 3D-Modus haben sie ja im Wesentlichen die App einfach selber weiterentwickelt. Aber es ging halt um die Daten und es ging halt um das Gesamtwerk und die Art und Weise, wie man damit umgeht.
Also ich könnte mir schon auch wirklich vorstellen, dass er vielleicht Dickkopf war und wirklich sagte, nö, mach ich nicht. Weil es ja dann schließlich auch sein Ruf, das bleibt ja ein Leben lang an dem hängen. Okay, es bleibt dann immer hängen, dass so ein Blödes so draus gebogen ist.
Also ich denke auch, das war sicherlich jetzt nicht nur eine Sache, weil das zeigt sich ja auch daran, wie sie jetzt seine Aufgaben umverteilt haben. Also erstmal ist halt jetzt Maps und noch was anderes. Nee, iCloud war schon vorher bei ediq. ediq war ja derjenige, der sozusagen das Mobile-Media-Desaster mit iCloud gekontert hat. Also ediq ist eigentlich derjenige, der gerade, man kann jetzt über iCloud denken, was man will. Das funktioniert auch alles nicht so, wie sich das viele wünschen. Aber es ist zumindest jetzt nicht so ein totales Desaster gewesen wie der Start von Movami. Und iTunes läuft ohnehin schon immer relativ geräuscharm. Also es ist mal wirklich eklatante Probleme mit iTunes gab, kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern in den letzten 10 Jahren, seitdem es diesen ganzen Store gab.
Also die ganze Server-Technologie dahinter scheint robust zu sein, das Programm selber, aber da haben wir ja schon drüber geredet.
Ja, ich rede jetzt wirklich nur von der Cloud.
Die Cloud ja genauso.
Und Siri und Maps, was beides so seine Macken hatte. Also mit Siri wäre ich ja eh nicht so warm. Maps ist halt das Problem Abgut, Idee gut, Daten mangelhaft. Also Positionsdaten mangelhaft. Teilweise eben auch die Satelliten-Coverage mangelhaft. Ich war jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen in Fulda. Da ist so richtig wie so Google Maps ein Jahr nach dem Start. Also so der Bahnhof bestand aus drei Pixel. Also schon schlimmer an der Diaspora. So, das ist jetzt zur ADQ gegangen. Dann ist diese Entscheidung über Human Interface-Entscheidung, also zu sagen, wie sieht unsere Software aus, ist zu Johnny Ive gegangen.
Ich hoffe, das wird gut.
Und was ist nochmal, welcher Bereich ist nochmal entzogen worden, der in Richtung Phil Schiller ging? Ich glaube jetzt so direkt gar nichts, aber sie haben jetzt sozusagen eine komplett neue...
Na, der Typ, der eigentlich in Rente gehen wollte.
Den haben sie wieder zurückgeholt.
Den Mansfield.
Genau. Aber der hat doch nur gesagt, ja okay, er macht noch ein Jahr. Aber dann ist auch gut.
Na ja gut, aber immerhin kriegt er jetzt eine komplett eigene Division. Also ich meine, vorher war er sozusagen zuständig für Mac-Hardware. Und jetzt ist er sozusagen der Chef von der Technologies Division.
Du, keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist er gegangen, weil er von Scott Forstel angepisst war.
Ja, das kann gut sein. Irgendwie mit dem Penner mache ich jetzt nicht mehr zusammen hier.
Und nur dadurch, dass sie ihn rausgeworfen haben, haben sie ihn zurückgekriegt oder so, kann ja sein.
Kann schon sein. Na, da muss ja gar nicht so viel shoppen.
Sieht aber auch irgendwie merkwürdig aus.
Sieht irgendwie genauso aus wie vorher.
Gut, also stellen fest, wir sind eigentlich jetzt, es ist jetzt nicht wirklich schlimm, kann nur besser werden.
Also interessant fand ich da dran, dass jetzt hier Johnny Ive das Design sowohl, also jetzt von der gesamten Software bekommen hat. Also der macht jetzt eigentlich alles Design, was irgendwie zu machen ist.
Ja, und das finde ich auch absolut konsequent, weil diese Geräte ja ohnehin quasi als eins waren. Also gerade mit dem iPad und mit dem iPhone ist die Software die Oberfläche. Ich meine, der Großteil eines Gerätes, also Johnny Ive hat sich ja bisher eigentlich nur noch um die Umrahmung des eigentlichen User Interfaces gekümmert. Da bleibt ja nicht mehr so sehr viel übrig. Ich schaue dir die Bildschirme, die Laptops und so weiter an. Also da ist ja fast auch noch was zu sehen. Genau, so. Und das muss ich jetzt schon immer etwas umgetrieben haben, dass sozusagen ein Millimeter, nachdem so seine geile Alu-Kante endet, dann da so ein Desaster ausbricht.
Der geschmackloses Geomorphismus auch.
Ja mal ehrlich, Glas, Alu und dann kommt da ein Leonhart.
Ja glaub mal nicht, dass der Ive so unsgeomorphisch...
Er hat gesagt, er findet Geomorphismen Bad Taste. Das hat er so gesagt.
Wo? Im Internet.
Dass er das direkt so gesagt hat.
Es ist wirklich so, dass Scott Forster der einzige gewesen sein soll, der das toll findet.
Ich hab's auch gelesen. Das Einzige, was ich nur kenne, ist das Interview, wo er meinte, er habe damit nichts zu tun.
Hat er ja auch nicht gehabt.
Er ist darauf angesprochen worden, wie er das fände. Und er hat sich nicht direkt dazu geäußert, sondern er hat gesagt...
Der Mann ist Brite. Wenn der sagt, er hat damit nichts zu tun, dann bedeutet er, es finde es total scheiße.
Ja gut, aber es heißt nicht unbedingt, dass er das Prinzip scheiße findet, sondern dass er vielleicht die Umsetzung scheiße findet.
Nein, er sagt sehr deutlich, dass er sich dazu nicht äußern möchte.
Dieser Taschenrechner, das ist... Ich glaube nicht, dass der...
Der Taschenrechner ist doch voll okay.
Der Taschenrechner ist einfach braunesign...
Der Taschenrechner ist einfach bei braunesign geklaut.
Naja, und die neue... Und die Uhr klauen sie bei den Schweizer.
Lizenzieren.
20 Millionen.
Wer hat's erfunden? Wer hat's erfunden?
Das geht aber auch noch. Das geht alles auch noch, finde ich. Das ist alles nicht wirklich schlimm. Ledernähte sind schlimm. Ledernähte und hier Rauffaser-Papeten.
Also ich finde es voll super, dass sie das bei den Schweizer dann doch lizenziert haben.
Oder hier diese Tonwandmaschine beim Podcast im Hintergrund. Das sieht schick aus, klar. Aber ich meine, das können irgendwelche Schnuffi-Apps machen, die meinen, die wollen cool aussehen. Aber Apple doch nicht. Das sieht so ein bisschen nach Kindergarten aus. Wir haben unseren Developern mal ein Teil freigegeben. Und die können mal machen, was sie wollen. Aber angeblich war Forster irgendwie so ein Ziehsohn von Steve Jobs. Weil der fand das wohl auch toll. Oder zumindest hat er sich bequatschen lassen. Und dessen Backing er jetzt nicht mehr hat. Stand da anscheinend ein bisschen alleine da. Und dann haben sie ihn gekantet. Also was heißt gekantet? Vielleicht ist er auch freiwillig gegangen irgendwann.
Ich freu mich, was er jetzt macht. Ich mein, er ist jetzt offiziell ein Jahr noch Berater.
Er könnte sich ja mit diesen Microsoft-Typen zusammen tun.
Mit dem Zinowski.
Der hat bestimmt in seinem Vertrag, die haben ja alle so eine Klausel, dass die erstmal ein Jahr lang nichts machen dürfen.
Golden Parachute heißt es.
Dennis, ich gebe dir erstmal eine Rolls-Ball-Taste hier. Das macht gerade den Eindruck, als könntest du das gebrauchen.
Meine Vader-Maske ist ein bisschen verrutscht gerade.
Das hat nicht mehr ordentlich geredet.
Weißt du, was ein Golden Parachute ist? Das ist der, wo du nochmal richtig viel Kohle kriegst, damit du sanft landest, wenn irgendwo rausgekantet wirst.
Aber ein Golden Parachute ist wahrscheinlich unglaublich schwer und knallt dir tierisch auf die Birne.
Ich hoffe ja, dass Johnny Iphats als erstes diese Podcast-Abrauch schmeißt.
Rausschweißen nicht, sondern ändern.
Naja, halt mal ordentlich machen.
Technisch wird er jetzt da irgendwie nichts machen. Der wird halt nur das Gold ein bisschen ändern.
Ob sie iTunes jetzt auch delayed haben gleich, weil Johnny Iphats jetzt irgendwie...
Das war auch mein erster Gedanke.
Habt ihr schon gesehen, da gibt es ja schon Leute, die sagen, bei iOS 6.1 ist ja hier das Passbook, oder wie das Ding heißt, auch schon ein bisschen aufgeräumt. Da ist schon auch das Geo, alles weg. Kann man das überhaupt starten, wenn man nichts hat?
Kann man schon, aber es sieht halt irgendwie...
Ja, und hier diesen Fails bei Game Center. Also man hat sich natürlich dran gewöhnt, aber eigentlich sieht es auch scheiße aus.
Game Center ist der Augenkrebs schlechthin. Also da muss ich immer wieder nur Mapp-Recht geben, der bei jeder Gelegenheit schimpft.
Was, haben wir irgendwas? Ich hab kein Passbook-Ticket, nicht ein einziges.
Ja, man kann dann so Apps kaufen oder Laden.
Die das unterstützen, wie von der Lufthansa zum Beispiel.
Ja, welch Buch, doch kein Lufthansa-Pflug.
Da müssen wir auch nochmal so ein Special machen, hier irgendwie solche Buch- und Wurst-Off. Also die Lufthansa-App ist echt ganz vorne.
Ich schmeiß noch die DriveNow-App dazu.
Also ich hab noch keine einzige App wirklich benutzt.
Typisch so, die wieder meinen, die müssen alles selber machen. Entweder Developer, die keine Ahnung haben.
Nee, weißt du was das ist? Die haben garantiert irgendeinen.NET-Cross-Plattform-Scheiß gemacht und haben den gleichen Code für einmal nach iOS und einmal nach Android exporten. So sieht die DriveNow-App aus für mich. Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt, aber es gibt da so Development-Umgebungen, wo du dann in beide Richtungen quasi deinen Code schicken kannst. Ja, da sind wir jetzt gleich so in so ein Loch geraten durch diesen...
Dann kommen wir nicht mehr raus, ja.
Na ja gut, ich denke, man kann dem jetzt nicht mehr so sehr viel mehr hinzufügen. Der Reorg findet statt und wir müssen mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt. Ehrlich gesagt, das haben wir noch gar nicht besprochen. Die Frage ist vor allem, was bedeutet das jetzt für den OS X iOS Train?
Also meiner Meinung nach fände ich das gar nicht so schlimm, wenn sie jetzt nicht ein Jahr nach Mountain Lion schon wieder einen OS X rausbringen.
Was sie wahrscheinlich tun werden.
Wenn sich Johnny Ive da ein bisschen Zeit lässt, um den ganzen Lederkram wegzumachen und dann dauert das ein bisschen länger.
Lederkram gibt es doch nun gar nicht. Ich meine, wo ist denn da jetzt großes Leder?
Naja, im Kalender und im Adressbuch mal mindestens.
Im Kalender müssen sie nur den Code von vor zwei Versionen wieder nehmen.
Und dann in diesen komischen Erinnerungen heißt es auf Deutsch, dieses Reminder-Teil. Das ist doch eigentlich auch schwarzes Kunstleder.
Das habe ich glaube ich noch nie gestartet, das Programm.
Naja, und dann gibt es halt noch Game Center.
Also wenn sie es schon simulieren auf dem iPhone, es ist ja kein schwarzes Kunstleder, sondern simulieren sie ja wohl eher echtes Leder. Das wird ja simulieren ein bisschen übertrieben.
Aus imitierten Leder imitat.
Also von mir aus können sie sich Zeit lassen und ein bisschen an den unterliegenden Technologien schrauben.
Ja, unterliegende Technologien.
Ich wollte es nicht sagen, aber Fusion Drive!
Wir erinnern uns ja an die Sendung, wo wir hier diesen MAP da hatten und wir unsere advanceden Verhörmethoden angewendet haben, um ihn Insider-Informationen zu entlocken über ein neues Fallsystem. Und er meinte, neues ja, aber nicht modern. Also bei modernem Fallsystem, da ist er dann ausgestiegen.
Ja, da wird der Fusion-Drive gemeint haben.
Wer meinte das? Ah.
Kannst du nicht erinnern, wo ich meinte, wir machen es hier wie bei All the Presidents Men. Er soll einfach nichts sagen, wenn es stimmt.
Das gab es auch bei den Insider.
Stimmt.
Echt? Ja, alter Trick. All the Presidents Men hier.
Hast du noch nicht gesehen? Dann berichten wir doch mal, was es damit auf sich hat. Roddy, dein Einsatz.
Mein Einsatz. Also Fusion Drive ist eigentlich ein logical Volumen-Manager. Muss man das jetzt erklären?
Wir müssen überhaupt das mal erklären. Fusion Drive sind neue Geräte angekündigt worden. Man hat jetzt bei manchen der Geräte die Option, eine eingebaute SSD und eine Festplatte zu haben, die aber dann nicht als separate Volumes wahrgenommen werden, sondern eben, wie der Name Fusion schon so schön naheliegt, quasi so ein Konglomerat aus beidem. Und es gab ja ähnliche Devices auf dem Markt, wo so SSD-Cache in Festplatten reingetan wurde. Diesen Weg ist Apple nie gegangen und auch jetzt nicht, sondern es handelt sich wirklich um SSD-Speicher, im Sinne von dem man selber so als Platte benutzen könnte und nicht nur als Cache.
Also diese Cache-Festplatten, die konnte man ja einfach kaufen und einbauen, habe ich ja auch gemacht. Da hat man halt irgendwie 4 GB Flash, Cache und dann bootet der halt eine Sekunde schneller oder so. Also das ist dann irgendwo am Rand der Einbildung, ob es nun wirklich schneller ist oder nicht. Also das ist so, genau, Fusion Drive, aber halt wie gesagt eine richtige SSD irgendwie in ihrer vollen Größe. Sie versprechen irgendwie 128 GB plus die dazugehörige Festplatte dann. Bei dem iMac war das eine Gigabyte Festplatte oder eine Terabyte Festplatte oder eine 3-Tera Festplatte plus diese 128 GB SSD.
So, beim Mac Mini auch.
Bei Mac Mini war es doch auch eine Terra? Ja, kann sein.
Ja, darunter bauen sie gar nicht mehr ein, glaube ich.
Ja, kann sein. Die sind also angekündigt und dann wurden viele Leute hektisch, unter anderem ich. Was es denn damit auf sich habe? Was es damit auf sich habe, weil ich hatte mir nämlich irgendwie kurz vorher eine SSD und ein Umsrissatz fürs MacBook Pro gekauft und wollte dann mal die SSD in das MacBook einbauen und das optische Laufwerk ausbauen und die Festplatte und die SSD halt beides zusammen einbauen. Und dann hieß es Fusion Drive und dann wurde ich natürlich ganz nervös. Und dann dauerte es noch ein paar Tage und dann hat jemand herausgefunden, dass es eigentlich alles ganz einfach ist, zumindest zum selber machen, weil man muss einfach nur ein Core Storage Volume anlegen. Beziehungsweise ein Logical Volume Group.
Und dann hat er halt herausgefunden, dass es mit 10.8.2 schon geht. Also dass es auch jeder jetzt schon kann und nicht erst warten muss, bis neue Software kommt.
Genau, also habe ich dann das einfach gemacht.
Du hast da einen SSD und eine Platte in deinem Rechner?
Genau, und habe die zu einem Fusion Drive zusammenfusioniert.
Du hast keinen CD-ROM mehr, sondern so ein OptiBay da drin?
Ja, genau.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Genau, habe das zu einem Fusion Drive zusammengefusioniert und das ist super.
Kurze Frage, und man hat jetzt angenommen, wie sind die Daten, die Größen von deinen beiden physikalischen Volumes?
240 Gig SSD, 500 Gig Festplatte.
Und man hat dann am Ende wie viel? Die 500 oder wirklich beide addiert?
Beide addiert.
Also du hast jetzt 750 Gig an Storage.
Genau.
Okay, okay, also wird auch nichts gespiegelt oder sonstiges oder so? Sondern wären wirklich beide gestriped sozusagen, könnte man sagen. Also eigentlich sind die gestriped mit Priorität auf die SSD.
Genau. Und wenn die SSD, also wenn du halt viel Zeug benutzt, was auf der Platte liegt, dann fängt er an umzuschichten.
Ja, den habe ich schon gelesen. Und zwar so, dass nicht auf Pfeilebene umgeschichtet wird, sondern der macht es tatsächlich auf Block-Ebene.
Er macht es auf Block-Ebene, ja.
Es gibt bei Ars Technica, glaube ich, einen Artikel und von diesem Jolly Jinks, wie auch immer der Typ richtig hieß.
Patrick Stein.
Genau, gibt es auch einen Artikel. Jolly Jinks.
Der auch Jolly's VNC macht.
Ist das nicht das Pferd von Lucky Luke?
Jolly Jumper.
Den muss ich noch mal hier zu Jolly VNC-Dings-Pomps mal was husten.
Hat mich überhaupt nicht gewundert, dass er der Erste war, weil er ja vor einiger Zeit schon mit diesem SSD-Testing-Tool da rumgespielt hat. Da hat man hier auch mal aufgerufen und nach Beta-Testern für seine Software, die bis heute nicht rausgekommen ist. Ich glaube, er hat den Plan wieder eingestampft, aber er war sozusagen mit der Ebene schon wohl vertraut.
Ah, das ist der, der die SSD-Testsoftware geschrieben hat? Ja. Ach so, da habe ich doch mal gebetert testet. Ich kann mich mal kennenlernen.
Genau, der hat in drei schnell aufeinander folgenden Blog-Posts das alles auseinanderklamüsert und alles im Versuch mal rausgefunden. Hat also mal eben so einen Fusion-Drive zusammengebaut.
Also der hat ja die wahre Pioniersarbeit gemacht, nachdem dann im Internet das große Tara irgendwie losging und sich alle mal drum gekümmert haben.
Genau. Ja und was da sozusagen dahinter steckt ist, du musst eben, also dieser ganze neu mit 10.7, mit Line, das ist doch seit Line, diese ganze Logic-Verfolgung-Geschichte. Jetzt haben sie quasi, also ihr Fallsystem, also es ist nicht so, dass Apple nichts macht an ihrem Fallsystem. Sie machen nur nichts mit dem On-Disc-Fallsystem. Ihre Fallsystem-Architektur im OS, da sind sie sehr wohl dabei und bauen halt jetzt die ganzen Sachen ein, die so Laris irgendwie schon seit gefühltem Jahrhunderten hat.
Was denn? Der Begriff Fallsystem ist an der Stelle schwierig, weil es sich bei Core Storage eben um einen Logical Volume Manager handelt. Das heißt, alles das, was neu ist, passiert unterhalb von HFS Plus und ich würde auch sagen, HFS Plus hat keine Ahnung, was unter ihm passiert.
Oh ja, natürlich, so ist das. Das weiß auch nichts von dem Krypto und sonst.
Genau, und zwar ist es folgendermaßen, um so einen Fusion Drive zu bauen, man macht zuerst eine sogenannte Logical Volume Group. Da sind ein, zwei oder noch mehr tatsächliche physikalische Drives drin. Physical Volume heißt das, genau. Und nach oben hin werden die dann präsentiert als Logical Volume Family. Und diese Logical Volume Family kann Encription haben. Also sprich, die Logical Volume Group vereint nur die Laufwerke, die Logical Volume Family, also scheint so zu sein, macht die Encription. Und da oben drauf kann ich dann das File-System setzen. Sprich, also diese Logical Volume Family geht nach oben, sieht nach oben aus wie ein normales Device, was unter slash dev ist. Und dieser Patrick hieß er, ne? Der hat tatsächlich auf so einer Logical Volume Family, auf so einem Device, auch ein ZFS draufgesetzt. Weil er es mal wissen wollte, ob es geht.
Ja, hat mein Kumpel Krücks auch gemacht. Und er meinte, das mountet auch, aber, ne, wie war es? Ne, das mountet schon, glaube ich, aber der Feinde beschwert sich trotzdem immer mal, weil er meint, er kann da irgendwie die, irgendeine ID nicht erkennen. Also es ist noch nicht ganz perfekt, aber grundsätzlich so geht's.
Also grundsätzlich hast du nach oben ein neues Device, wo du halt was draufsetzen kannst. Und dann tut man üblicherweise natürlich ein HFS drauf. HFS Plus.
Interessant ist jetzt, was mich so ein bisschen gewundert hat, hier bei diesen, wenn man das so zusammenbaut, das sind ja nur so ein paar Kommando-Zeilen. Und nirgendswo sagt man jetzt explizit, oder sagt man das irgendwo, fällt das Wort Fusion da eigentlich auf Kommando-Zeilen?
Nee, du machst nur die Logical Volume Group. Und es scheint auch nur so zu sein, dass wenn du nur dann, wenn du zwei Laufwerke hast und eins davon ist eine SSD, dann funktioniert dieser Mechanismus.
Ja, das hat mich so ein bisschen gewundert, dass es da dich irgendein Setting gab, dass man sagt, das ist hier das Premiere, das ist das Schnelle, das ist das Langsame. Das scheint mir, sagen wir mal, auch ein bisschen hardcoded zu sein. Vor allem die große Frage ist ja, kann ich das auch mit zwei oder drei Platten machen?
Du kannst eine Logical Volume Group mit mehreren Platten machen. Ob dann der Fusion-Drive-Mechanismus, der dir die Geschwindigkeit bringt, auch tatsächlich zuschlägt, das weiß ich nicht, das kann ich beurteilen.
Ich hab ja hier in meinem Mac Pro auch drei Terabyte Festplatten drin. Die hatte ich halt noch so rumliegen und die passen da einfach so rein. Und hab die dann mit dieser Soft-Raid-Geschichte von Apple mit OS X zusammengeballert. Das ist allerdings keine Logical Volume Group. Also da greift jetzt nicht diese Core Storage-Geschichte. Ich meine, der ist ja auch von 2009. Da gab es das sozusagen gar nicht. Aber das hat sich dann sozusagen auch nicht geändert. Weil ich glaube, ich hab das mit 10.6 oder 10.7 in Betrieb genommen, das Gerät. Weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht. Ja, mit 10.6 stimmt, da gab es das ja auch noch gar nicht. Ich frage mich, ob das jetzt, wenn ich das sozusagen unter Mountain-Line neu machen würde, da irgendwas anderes bei rauskommt. Ich könnte wahrscheinlich jetzt diese drei Platten auch einfach als Logical Volume Group erzeugen.
Ja, dann hast du aber quasi einen Stripe. Das heißt, ich weiß es nicht genau. Hab ich ja jetzt auch. Ach so, du hast dich auch als Stripe.
Na, ich hab sozusagen die drei, wie heißt das so schön hier in der?
Rate 0.
Sprache hier in der Apple Sprache. Mal kurz nochmal schauen. Steht das hier eigentlich irgendwo?
Irgendwo sollte das stehen bei einem der...
Stripe Rate Set, ja, Apple Rate Version 2.0.
Stripe Rate Set, ja, ist das ein Rate 0. Ja, na du hast natürlich immer das Problem, dass du bei einem Stripe hast du halt keine Sicherheit der Daten und die Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit erhöht sich halt. Dadurch, dass es ausfällt, wenn nur eins von denen ausfällt, dann ist halt alles weg. Und so wird es dann wahrscheinlich bei einem Fusion Drive auch sein. Bis jetzt tut es aber ohne Probleme.
Ja gut, ich meine, die Sicherheit musst du dir dann eben durch Backup und so.
Und weil das war ja noch nicht genug, das... Schauen wir mal, was geht. Ich habe also tatsächlich dann mit Bootcamp von dem Fusion Drive wieder 100 Gig abgeknipst und auf diesen 100 Gig ein Windows installiert.
Und wie...
echt?
Von der HD.
Aber nur von der HD?
Nur von der HD.
Das heißt, du konntest das nachträglich shrinken oder was? Und das ist dann...
Mit Bootcamp, ja.
Aber du hast nicht explizit gesagt, dass er das nur von der HD machen soll, sondern er hat das einfach so gemacht und er kann und so?
Er hat das so gemacht, ja.
Okay, also das haben sie schon irgendwie vorgesehen.
Naja, es muss ja... Es muss ja auf den neu verkauften Macs mit Fusion Drive auch funktionieren.
Naja, stimmt.
Also das Installieren von Windows war dann richtig schwierig.
Warum?
Weil... also ein Mac, der ein eingebautes DVD-Laufwerk hat, kann von einem USB-Port nur ein macOS booten. Aus Gründen, die mir nicht so ganz...
Nochmal langsam für Podcasts.
Ein Mac, der ein eingebautes DVD-Laufwerk hat, kann von einem USB-Port nur ein macOS booten. Weil er nicht in der Lage ist, einen EFI-Bootloader von einem USB-Device zu laden.
Und wenn das DVD-Drive nicht da ist?
Dann hat man ein Problem.
Das ist nicht so, dass es dann auf einmal geht, okay?
Nein, es geht. Also wenn du aus einem Mac, wo ein DVD-Laufwerk drin ist, das DVD-Laufwerk ausbaust, kannst du nicht mehr von einer DVD booten.
Also auch nicht von einer über USB angeschlossenen DVD, das meinst du?
Ja genau, wenn du dieses Laufwerk in eine DVD-Gehäuse tust und es dann anschließt, kannst du nicht davon booten, weil das kann so ein Mac nicht. Die Macs, die kein DVD-Laufwerk haben, die können einen EFI-Bootblock von USB booten, sei es jetzt auf einem Stick oder auf einem externen DVD-Laufwerk. Aber Macs, die einen DVD-Laufwerk eingebaut haben, können das nicht. Es ist nicht vorgesehen im... na BIOS ist es ja nicht, EFI, keine Ahnung, Firmware.
Also du kannst jetzt dein Windows nicht mehr von der DVD booten und deswegen war es nicht so einfach, das zu installieren.
Aber ist das auch so bei den latest and greatest Revisionen der DVD-bestückten Geräte so? Die haben bestimmt auch eine neue EFI.
Das weiß ich nicht. Dieses Gerät ist von Ende 2011. Also es ist jetzt nicht wirklich alt. Also das ist so... Also... Keine Ahnung, kann ich jetzt nicht so viel zu sagen.
Also hier wird auch gerade widersprochen im Chat.
Aber er hat einen 2SZ-SZ4 MacBook Pro. Und wahrscheinlich hatte das noch nicht mal EFI, oder? Doch.
Was ist denn ein 2SZ?
Also wie gesagt, es geht nicht darum, einen Mac OS zu booten. Mac OS booten geht immer aus Gründen, die ich nicht nachvollziehen kann. Sondern es geht darum, irgendwas anderes zu booten. Also eine normale Linux-CD oder eine Windows-CD kriegst du nicht von einem externen USB-betriebenen DVD-Laufwerk gebootet. Ich hab wirklich alles probiert.
Auch nicht von dem originalen Apple-DVD-Laufwerk.
Ja genau, das hab ich ja benutzt.
Aber warte, warte, da gibt's doch dieses Refit-Tool.
Damit geht's auch nicht. Hab ich auch probiert. Ich hab extra noch eine weitere USB-Platte angeschlossen, um da noch ein Mac OS und ein Refit und alles zu installieren. Ich krieg das Refit. Refit ist ein EFI-Bootloader.
Refit, also das EFI sozusagen im Namen mit drin. Und das ist so ein...
EFI-Bootloader. Genau, das ist so ein gepimter. Von? Das heißt übrigens inzwischen Refined, weil der Typ, der Refit gemacht hat, nicht mehr weiter macht. Und es gibt aber einen anderen, der macht weiter, macht dieses Refined und dieses Refined, das funktioniert jetzt auch auf normalen Boards, wo jetzt kein Apple drauf ist.
Damit kannst du dann halt auch 23 Ubuntu-Versionen auf deinem Rechner haben. Die haben alle über so ein schönes Boot-Menü.
Genau, das sieht aus wie das andere Boot-Menü, nur ein bisschen hässlicher. Also, und kann angeblich mehr. Damit hab ich es aber auch nicht hingekriegt. Der Trick ist, man benutzt Virtual Box um die Partition, die man erzeugt hat, in Virtual Box als Laufwerk einzubinden und installiert darauf dann das Windows. Und wenn das Windows einmal installiert ist auf der internen SATA-Platte, dann kann das auch booten.
Lass mich raten, du hast immer noch keinen Job.
Schlafen die Kinder schön durch.
Wenn sie schlafen, hat man Zeit.
Zurück zu den Logical Volumes und Fusion Drives. Im Prinzip ist es so, dass wenn man sich jetzt, ich hab ja zum Beispiel grad nicht so viel benutzt, so mein 2009er iMac mit eingebauter Festplatte, den ich ja sowieso schon mit externer SSD betrieben hatte, wie ich so hinten, ihr erinnert euch, mit Firewire, Rangevelcro und so weiter, da war das immer so ein bisschen doof, dass man eigentlich so diese Terabyte-Platte nicht so richtig gut benutzen konnte, weil immer diese alte Entscheidung, wo hast du die Tore, blablabla. So, und das heißt, verlass dann immer so das falsche File irgendwo. Und genau, das könnte man sich jetzt eben mit diesem Fusion Drive Kram, auch bei so einem alten Rechner vermutlich, wenn man eben mindestens, ja, weiß nicht, ab welchem, 10.8.2. Wahrscheinlich 10.8.2.
Also in dem Help-Dokument von Apple steht drin, man kann ein Fusion Drive Mac, den man da gekauft hat, per Target Disk Mode an einen anderen Mac hängen, der 10.8.2 hat und dann kann man auch das Fusion Drive sehen. Was für mich die Aussage ist, man braucht mindestens 10.8.2, damit es funktioniert.
Okay, also 10.8.2 ist erforderlich, so ist es. Was ich noch geil finde, ist, dass man die Platten so effizient nutzt.
Es gibt noch eine Kleinigkeit zu beachten, nämlich die Rescue-Partition. Wenn man die startet, kann man keine Shell aufmachen. Das heißt, um diese zwei Befehle abzusetzen im Terminal und einen Fusion-Drive zu erzeugen, muss man ein ganzes macOS auf einer externen Festplatte haben, das man puten kann, sonst geht es nicht.
Das ist keine Shell bei der Rescue-Dings?
Nein, soweit ich weiß nicht.
Zu sicher?
Ziemlich, aber vielleicht habe ich nicht genau hingeguckt.
Also wenn man von DVD installiert hat, da kann man auf jeden Fall oben im Menü ein Terminal öffnen.
Ja, DVD, aber es geht hier um die Rescue-Partition.
Ist das das gleiche, die Rescue-Partition und so eine Install-DVD? Was sagt denn der Chat dazu?
Der Chat ist wahrscheinlich schon am Testen. Wir werden es gleich herausbekommen. Gut, ich finde das ganz gut. Ich meine, das ist mal echt ein innovatives Feature.
Auf jeden Fall.
Könnte echt was bringen.
Na ein bisschen scary, weil es ist halt wie bei Rate 0, wenn eins von beiden im Arsch ist, ist beides im Arsch. Und die Daten weg.
So wie vorher, wenn du deine Daten nur auf einer Platte hast und die Platte ist im Arsch, ist die Platte im Arsch.
Jetzt können schon zwei Sachen, also die Chance ist jetzt doppelt so wie vorher.
Du brauchst so oder so einfach ein Backup. Also ich meine, da muss ich eigentlich...
Die Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit steigt schon.
Dennis heißt er.
Hi, wir haben uns gerade die Hand gegeben. Freundschaftlich.
Also es heißt aber, wenn dir eine SSD ausfällt, dann sind da wohl hoffentlich noch alle Daten auf deine... Der packt tatsächlich manche Datendaten an.
In der Präsentation.
Also es ist wirklich...
Interessant ist, dass wenn du mit der Alt-Taste bootest, dann kommen auch zwei Laufwerke hoch. Die heißen beide Fusion eben, oder wie du es genannt hast. Und du kannst von beiden booten. Also er macht auf jeden Fall mal zwei Boot-Blöcke oder wie auch immer auf die beiden Drives.
Und die sind sozusagen gegenseitig verlinkt, dass jede Platte sagt zu der anderen hier, ich brauch aber die auch noch.
Wahrscheinlich, genau.
Dann lass doch mal deine kurz hier ausbauen, deine Festplatte und lass mal booten.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn deine SSD kaputt geht und du brauchst eine neue SSD ein, dann musst du alles fresh installen und so.
Ja klar. Du kannst einen Fusion-Drive nicht erzeugen und die Daten bleiben irgendwie noch auf der Platte drauf, sondern du musst wirklich beide Platten, aus denen du das zusammenbaust, halt platt machen. Oder die werden platt gemacht bei dem Prozess. Das ist so die nächste Entwicklungsstufe vielleicht.
Da hat man aber auch die Summe von beiden Plattengrößen als Platz zur Verfügung, ist doch schonmal cool.
Aber ich hab ja letztens schon zu Dennis gesagt, also mich reizt das ja überhaupt nicht, wa?
Na, mich hat's erst schon gereizt, bis mir eingefallen ist, dass ich dann wieder drehenden Rost in meinem Laptop hätte und dadurch keinen Bock. Ansonsten ist das total cool, aber nicht für meinen Laptop.
Also ich bin ja immer so ein Geschwindigkeitsfreund und wenn ich dann irgendwie doch mal wieder das Ding öffne, wo es dann von der Platte kommt und es fängt dann wieder so an, 10 Sekunden zu bouncing, dann werde ich schon unruhig, wenn mich ein Rechner an die Wand feuert.
Na gut, aber dafür hättest du 3 oder 4 Mal so viel Platz auf deinem Rechner. Bevor du machst eine Terabyte 2,5 Zoll Platte rein, hast du die gebacked durch deine 250 GB SSD. Weil die ganzen Apple Fusion Drives haben ja auch nur 128. Die haben ja relativ wenig beschleunigt. Du hättest ja sozusagen doppelt so viel beschleunigt.
Aber ich brauche ja ja nicht so viel Platz sogar.
Ja, dann ist Fusion doch für dich sowieso unwichtig.
Ja, also das Einzige, was mich wirklich stört, ich habe ja die Festplatte jetzt in diesen Adapter reingemacht. Und seitdem ist die Festplatte viel lauter. Die ist nicht so gut schwemungsisoliert.
Du hast es gerade erst vor kurzem umgebaut, wie auf dieses Optical Bay, OptiBay oder wie ist das Ding? OptiBay. Na ja, ich habe ja letztes Jahr schon überlegt, aber nachdem ich den drehenden Rost raus hatte aus meinem Laptop, habe ich gemerkt, ich merke nichts mehr.
Ich merke nichts mehr, außer die Lüfter vielleicht noch.
Da fühle ich das drehende Plastik raus.
Das drehende Plastik dreht sich nicht so lange, wenn man da nichts reinschiebt.
Da brauchst du auch nicht mithaben.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings, aber dann muss man sich halt einen Retina kaufen.
Ja, mal gucken.
Kurze Rückmeldung aus Twitter, also hier behauptet jemand, er hätte erfolgreich in dem Rescue-Disc auch eine Shell bekommen.
Dann war ich mir nur zu blöd.
Ich hab auch der Meinung, dass das geht, oben im Menü. Kann man irgendwie Disk Utility Terminal, dieses Internet-Tool irgendwie zum Pinks checken und so, die kann man da alle irgendwie einzeln öffnen. Nur nicht gleichzeitig komischerweise, sondern du musst erst schließen, damit du oben wieder ins Menü kommst.
Ja, siehst du, dann war ich zu blöd.
Und irgendjemand behauptet, dass die O2-iPhones richtig frei seien, ohne irgendwie mehr Lok-Scheiße?
Die Deutschen.
Ich habe jetzt den Plan von meinem Arbeitgeber vielleicht hoffentlich, mir noch mal so ein altes MacBook Pro aber rechts unten klicken zu lassen, bevor es die dann gar nicht mehr gibt, weil ich ja nach wie vor irgendwie nicht so diese Retina MacBook Pros geil finde.
Warum nicht?
Spiegel-Display, kein Ethernet. Es hat doch weniger Spiegel. Ich hab's schon gesehen, ich hab's ja vor mir gehabt, das spiegelt.
Dann sag doch mal dein Arbeitgeber soll mal ordentliche Beleuchtung machen bei euch.
Ich sitz am Fenster.
Da wo du Schalusin und was weiß ich nicht alles.
Ich will doch nicht den ganzen Tag auf so...
Ab in den Keller mit dir.
Ja, ich stehe einfach auf dieses Verspiegelte nicht. Und kein Ethernet finde ich tatsächlich auch scheiße.
Ethernet ist an einem Display.
Nee, ich habe meinen Rechner dauernd unterwegs auch dabei. Dann bist du halt in so einem Gegend, dann ist wieder das WLAN reudig. Diese kleinen Schnuffis. Also jetzt durch diesen Lightning heißt es hier, am iPhone 5, das ist ja die totale Kabelnotauschung. Man vergisst da einmal dein Kabel gleich Panik. Und bei uns in der Firma haben sie ja wenigstens so eine große Plastikkiste voll dieser alten Dock-Connector auf Lightning-Dings gekauft, weil die ganzen Kabel sind ja schon da und es wäre jetzt bescheuert quasi, dann tausende Kabel rumzulegen zu haben.
Die neuen Kabel sind billiger als die Adapter.
Wir haben jetzt noch einen Kisser Adapter. Because we can. Jetzt schleppe ich noch einen Ethernet-Adapter darunter, dann schleppe ich noch 23 Display-Ports auf VGA, DVI, HDMI, was auch immer Adapter rum. Das ist alles scheiße. Und ich finde so die alten Macro-Pros, finde ich eigentlich, das ist, ich finde das gut. Also jetzt noch einmal rechts unten mit dicker CPU, mit voll RAM, also mit 16 GB RAM und noch einmal dicker SSD und...
Ja, dann aber schnell. Die gibt es gerade ja noch.
Genau, sie haben ja einmal noch ihre Serie auch noch mal geupdatet.
Aber am Retina-Bildschirm an sich hast du nichts auszusetzen.
Nee, wenn es den Non-Gloss hier geben würde, hätte ich den natürlich sehr gerne. Wobei, wobei, jetzt ist ja hier, habe ich ja gehört, das MacBook Pro 13 Zoll, das ist ja nicht so geil, ne? Also es gab doch jetzt irgendwie so Berichte, dass, das hat zwar Retina, aber die Grafikkarte ist zu schwachbrüstig, um da die Refresh-Rate hochzuhalten und dann wenn du irgendwie so da so Fenster hin und her bewegst, dann gibt es mal so ein Ruckelkante und so, weil die nicht genug Dampf hat.
Kann ich mir fast nicht so richtig vorstellen, aber das ist natürlich mit dieser HD 4000 oder wie viel haben die jetzt?
Und noch schlimmer, weil du ja nicht die Retina-Auflösung die ganze Zeit kriegst, sondern du kriegst ja dieses, das Interface ist ja eigentlich immer noch genauso groß. Du kannst ja einstellen, ob du jetzt wirklich Retina-Retina-Auflösung haben willst, das ist ja alles ganz klein. Und wenn du halt alles so auf diesem optimal für Retina-Display einstellst, dann hast du sozusagen effektiv eine geringere Auflösung als auf dem MacBook Air, also von den Größenverhältnissen und so weiter, was auf den Screen passt. Genau die Hälfte, ja.
Auf dem MacBook Air kannst du ja trotzdem voll klein machen, ohne dass es kriselig wird. Das ist ja dann nur das Menü und der Fensterrahmen, die dir dann ein bisschen zu groß vorkommen.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ich hab jetzt schon ein paar Leute gehört, die meinen, ein 13 Zoll MacBook Pro kaufen sie sich doch nicht, weil Grafik zu langsam ist.
Naja, da muss man vielleicht auch einfach noch eine Modellversion abwarten.
Kommt ja auch drauf an, was so viele Leute sind. Wenn du natürlich dein 15 Zoll Power in 13 Zoll haben willst, dann ist das nicht das richtige Gerät. Dann bist du halt dann auch ein bisschen falsch.
Aber das allererste R war doch auch eher nur so Mittel, ne?
Ja, aber das allererste R ist ja nicht als MacBook Pro angetreten, sondern ist ja als R angetreten. Da hat man auch nicht so viel Performance erwartet. Aber wenn ich jetzt lese, dass da die Grafikkarte zu schwach ist, um irgendwie hohe Refresh-Rate auf diesem Retina-Display zu supporten, dann denke ich mir, ist das...
Ja, die haben das verglichen, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Die haben das Retina 13 Zoll mit dem alten 13 Zoll verglichen. Und beim alten 13 Zoll war da halt noch hier Discrete-Grafics, irgendwie AMD oder Nvidia drin, richtig? Und damit kann natürlich diese HD 4000 von diesen Ivy-Bridge irgendwie nicht mithalten. Das kann schon sein, aber so richtig voll schlecht wird es jetzt auch nicht sein. Aber klar, Diablo kannst du wahrscheinlich vergessen.
Ja, und dann ist es aber auch irgendwie kein Pro für mich halt. Dann ist das halt so ein anderes R, oder ein R mit Retina-Auflösung, aber mit effektiv geringerem Screenspace.
Naja, es ist halt für Leute wahrscheinlich eher so ein bisschen, das Ding ein bisschen weniger benutzen.
Ich glaube, es ist für Leute, für die vor allem der Bildschirm entscheidend ist.
Ja, Buckel ist aber auch der Bildschirm entscheidend, sonst würde er ja nicht so rumzicken wie ein Blossi.
Ja, nicht nur. Also, ich glaube, es ist vor allem erst mal für Developer.
Das 13 Zoll.
Ja, auch das 15 Zoll.
Die Developer, die dann die Retina-Anwendungen machen.
Nö, die aber, sagen wir mal jetzt, ich meine, was hat ein Developer auf dem Screen? Viel Kleintext.
Xcode.
Genau. Dann sagst du irgendwie, ja, hier, viele Pixel, lalala.
Ja, schon, aber dann willst du eigentlich wie man 27 Zöller haben.
Als richtiger Developer hat man einen großen Bildschirm und dann ist man auch eh nicht auf dem Laptop. Also ich jedenfalls nicht. Also ich hab da irgendwie meinen 23 Zoll und ja.
Nee, nicht den 27er Retina. Das hast du mich jetzt verstanden.
Ja, natürlich ist das toller. Nur rumtragen, überall arbeiten können, lalala. Trotzdem viel Platz haben, etc. Da macht das einfach Sinn. Hab gesehen, davon der Retina-Trend wird uns ohnehin einholen, weil es ist schon erstaunlich. Ich hab mir das mal so eine Weile angeguckt auf diesem Retina MacBook Pro und man muss halt wieder mal feststellen, es ist erstaunlich, was diese Verdopplung der Auflösung macht mit Text. Also diese Wahrnehmung von Text, da merkt man überhaupt erst mal, wie sehr man sich an diese Abstraktion von Schrift gewöhnt hat.
Na, das Gehirn rechnet das halt wieder rund und...
Ja klar, aber es muss halt auch die ganze Zeit dabei rechnen und wenn man dann erst mal diesen Rechenanteil nicht mehr leisten muss, weil sich einfach die Trendschärfe von einem einfach so weit angestiegen ist, dann wird es gleich wieder anstrengend. Das ist halt genauso jetzt mit dem iPad Mini. Wenn man sich das Ding irgendwie anschaut im Vergleich zum iPad 3, denkt man sich halt auch so. Rückschritt, deutlich. Aber ich meine, das Mini ist natürlich ein Fortschritt.
Besser als das iPad 2 von der DP-Zahl.
Wollen wir mal über das Mini reden? Haben wir jetzt irgendwie hier die MacBook-Abteilung irgendwie durch? Also habt ihr es schon gesehen? Habt ihr es schon in der Hand gehabt?
Das Mini? Hatte ich schon in der Hand, ja.
Ich hatte es im Apple Store kurz in der Hand. Du hast es so in the wild in der Hand gehabt?
Ja. Haben ja schon unsere Spiele angepasst.
Zu kleine Touch-Targets irgendwie raus operieren.
Irgendwie haben sie da schon was dran geschraubt. Zumindest zum Testen oder was auch immer. Sie hatten auf jeden Fall schon unsere Spiele drauf. Ja, also Formfaktor ist auf jeden Fall ganz schnuffig. Also so kann ich mir schon echt auch so ganz gut vorstellen in Sofa- und Bett-Situationen und so weiter. Also eher eben als dieses doch zu schwere und zu klobige und immer irgendwie doch nicht richtige iPad. Aber Auflösung war halt, also ich war doch so ein bisschen überrascht, wie deutlich man so diese Textbrückelei und diesen Matsch dann wieder sieht. Und dann hatte ich halt so mal verschiedene Webseiten aufgemacht und mal geguckt, wie so im Default-Rendering so der Text aussieht. Spiegel total furchtbar, Zeit total furchtbar. Also es war alles so richtig wieder wie früher. Wie früher iPad 1 und 2, Matschepampe. Und gerade so zum Lesen voll der Rückschritt. Also da ist wirklich so iPad 2, das aktuelle iPad oder hier eben alles, was Retina hat, ist da wirklich so eine ganze Größenordnung einfach von Lesbarkeit entfernt. Und das war dann für mich eigentlich auch schon gleich so das Stop-Kriterium, weil letztendlich ist mir das iPad ja, also das große, halt zu clunky zum Lesen irgendwie, weil es halt immer, mit einer Hand geht immer nicht so richtig gut, nur das Kleine, das kann man ja schon relativ gut jetzt in der Hand halten, aber dann ist der Textrendering, da kriegst du die Krise.
Es ist ganz interessant, ich meine, du siehst es wahrscheinlich genauso wie ich, du siehst den Wert des iPads im Wesentlichen eigentlich in der Möglichkeit zu lesen und jetzt, wo der Bild schon okay ist, ist das Gerät eigentlich immer noch zu groß und schwer und das iPad Mini hätte jetzt eigentlich die richtige kindelartige Größe.
Auch so Gewicht und so, das fliegt echt gut in die Hand.
Es braucht halt jetzt definitiv eine höhere Auflösung, aber es ist halt mal wieder so, dass sich das einfach entweder von der Batterie her oder von dem Gewicht her oder beiden derzeit noch nicht machen lässt.
Also das richtig coole Gerät wird dann erst mit dem iPad Mini 2 kommen.
Vielleicht.
Ja, also in der Zukunft.
Genau.
Weil irgendwann wird es auch passieren.
Was heißt das richtig coole Gerät? Ich meine, es gibt auch eine Menge Leute, für die jetzt Lesen nicht ganz so wichtig ist oder die das bisschen, was sie dann lesen, auch in 1024 x 768 noch wahrgenommen bekommen. Ich meine, so haben wir Computer über viele, viele Jahre auch benutzt, ohne dass sich nennenswert einer beklagt hat. Das war mal high resolution, ne? Und für Video und Spiele wiederum ist das dem geil.
Da merkt man, das ist ja nicht so dieses Problem. Genau.
Und ich meine, das ist einfach irgendwie wirklich so, ich meine, ich hab ja dieses Nexus 7.
Das ist auf jeden Fall klobiger gegen das iPad mini, ne?
Ja, gar kein Vergleich.
Also das ist da so richtig schon wieder so ein Stullenbrett. Und das andere ist eher so, weiß man gar nicht, wie man das beschreiben soll, das iPad mini ist auf jeden Fall sehr, der liegt echt sehr schön in der Hand. Ja, ich meine, wie gesagt, wenn ich spiele ja auch viel oder wenn ich das iPad benutze, das große, dann ist es bestimmt so 40 Prozent zum Spielen und der andere Teil zum Rumbrausen und vielleicht mal was lesen oder so. Zum Spielen ist das iPad mini dann auf jeden Fall auch sehr gut geeignet. Also ich hätte ja, letzte Sendung haben wir ja so groß orakelt und wir waren uns ja dann doch irgendwie einig, dass jetzt Apple nicht nochmal ein Gerät ohne Retina ein neues rausbringen und dann machen sie es doch einen Tag später, dann sei ich davor, äääh.
Ja, die Gerüchteküche war sich ja relativ einig. Wir haben es nur nicht geglaubt.
Ich wollte es einfach nicht wahrhaben.
Ich wollte es auch nicht wahrhaben.
Weil ich habe noch so eine Erinnerung, wie scheiße das war vorher mit dem Text-Retro-Regel, ich konnte wieder... Also als ich das halt in die Hand genommen hab, dachte ich, okay, das wird jetzt besser sein als vorher und das ist vielleicht akzeptabel. Und dann guck ich so rauf, ne. Das ist wirklich ganz schlecht. Wasserlaube Apple.
Mein Nexus 7 hat gerade ein Update für mich.
Tim ist erstmal ausgenockt für eine Stunde. Aber was hab ich gelesen? Asus oder wer hat gerade ein Gerät rausgebracht mit 440 DPI? Das macht krass, oder?
HD-Bildschirm auf so einem komischen Android. Klassisch, also so ein Flunder-Device halt.
Da müsste man echt mal etablieren, den Begriff. Für alles größer, also breiter als 4 oder 4,5 Zoll oder breiter sowieso. Aber die Breite ist ja da.
Diese 5 Zoll für Phones halt.
Ja, wer's mag.
Aber 440 schon ganz schön krass.
Das ist doch dann auch so ein bisschen übers Ziel hinausgeschossen, oder?
Naja, komm, würde es jetzt bei Apple rauskommen, würden wir sagen, ja, boah, noch geiler. Aber ich glaube auch ein bisschen, dass Apple schon recht hat, weil sie haben ja wahrscheinlich irgendwann eingesehen, dass man diesen DPI-Krieg gar nicht führen muss, weil es macht irgendwie keinen Sinn mehr, wenn es mehr irgendwie DPI hat, als das Auge irgendwie kann. Und bei den 440 ist es wahrscheinlich schon wirklich weit drüber hinausgeschossen.
China war wahrscheinlich die geilste Produktbezeichnung seit Jahren, die wir geführt haben, also Technologiebezeichnung. Weil das jedem gleich klar macht so, ah ja, jetzt hat es die richtige Auflösung. Niemand braucht mehr als das.
Ja, aber mal ganz ehrlich, das iPhone, das hat jetzt irgendwie, was war das, 328 oder so? 326 DPI und ich sehe da keine Pixel, selbst wenn ich mich anstreue.
Nein, siehst du noch nicht.
Und 440, ich meine, das ist jetzt irgendwie...
Das ist halt, damit du draufschreiben kannst, dass es Full HD hat. Das ist so spec-driven.
Das macht schon auch Sinn, man braucht seine Movies nicht mehr umrechnen.
Ach, die haben die Pixel so klein gemacht, bis sie Full HD hatten.
Ja, bis sie da 1920 mal 1080 drauf hatten. Dann haben sie es so lange zusammengestaucht. Ich meine, das ist so fernberuhigend, dass man jetzt weiß, dass es sogar möglich ist, die Pixel noch kleiner zu kriegen. Ob der Bildschirm dann aber auch wirklich dieselbe Qualität hat, wie jetzt zum Beispiel das Teil vom iPhone 5, das war stark zu bezweifeln.
Ja, das ist wie bei diesen kompakten Kameras.
Ja, aber selbst wenn es so ist, ich meine, kostet es wahrscheinlich auch eine Menge Geld. Die Fehlerrate, ich weiß nicht, wie es in der Produktion so geht. Wobei am Ende auch ist es bei der Technik so, because we can. Also, die machen es halt, weil es geht und weil es auch nicht teurer ist als jetzt bei 330 dB.
Das wird wahrscheinlich auch alles mit der Zeit jetzt, mit den Fehlerquoten und dem Ausschuss wahrscheinlich auch einfach immer besser. So, die Prozesse optimieren sie ja dann auch immer die ganze Zeit. Wenn sie es einmal geschafft haben, das so überhaupt in selten zu produzieren, dann geht es ja meistens.
Wenn eine Pixel klein genug ist, siehst du ja dann auch den Fehlpixel nicht mehr.
Ich glaube auch, wohin der Weg dann geht. Weil eigentlich müsste der Weg dann dahin gehen, dass irgendwann ist einem die riesen Mega-Auflösung dieser Geräte egal. Dann hast du halt irgendwie 10.000 x 5.000 Pixel auf dein Minigerät und dann wird dein OS oder dein GUI, was der Designer auch macht, wird einfach reinskaliert. Weil skalieren ist ja eigentlich blöd, wegen diesen krummen Zahlen. Du kannst halt nicht von ein Pixel auf 1,8 Pixel oder so skalieren, weißt schon. Weil dann hast du immer so komische Umrechnungsfehler. Wenn du aber auf 10.000 Pixel skalieren kannst, dann ist es egal. Dann ist dieser Umrechnungsfehler so klein, dass du den auch nicht mehr siehst. Und dann hast du die vollen Freiheiten. Dann kannst du halt, egal welches Display, die da gerade bauen, machen, welche Größe auch immer, ist alles total wurscht und da wird es wohl hingehen.
Na, bei den MacBook Pros mit Retina ist es ja jetzt schon so, dass sie ja auch skalieren. Wenn man nicht die optimale Auflösung ist.
Ja, aber da geht es ja immer noch, dass sie halt, sie skalieren entweder, also das normale Retina ist ja, dass sie genau doppelt skalieren. Also alles, was nicht angepasst hat, wird ja einfach mal zwei genommen.
Genau.
Das ist halt gerade, da hast du keine Umrechnungsfehler, weil es einfach mal zwei. Und diese komischen Zwischenstufen, die Apple da anbietet, ist glaube ich genau 1,5 und irgendwie auch noch so eine Geradezahl, die du auch wieder 1A sauber umskalieren kannst. Aber irgendwann in der Zukunft musst du halt vielleicht mal 3,45 Tralala umskalieren. Das würde scheiße aussehen, aber bei 10.000 Pixeln ist es egal.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die DPI-Zahl groß noch ansteigen wird. Ja, weil es nichts bringt. Du hast einen unglaublichen technischen Aufwand für einen Effekt, der nicht bahnnehmbar ist. Der, den du nicht verkaufen kannst. Ich meine, gut, in der Android-Welt mag das immer noch so sein, dass Geräte nach Megahertz-Zahlen verkauft werden. Aber ansonsten ist es halt auch so. Weißt du jetzt aus dem Kopf, wie viel Gigahertz dein MacBook hat? Also ich nicht. Das ist auch nicht mehr interessant. Weißt du, diese Zahl, es ist halt genug inzwischen. Und wenn du einmal Retina erreicht hast, dann hast du genug Pixel. Dann hast du genug Auflösung. Und alles, was drüber ist, ist vergebliche Liebesmühe.
Ja, vor allem, es kostet halt auch mehr Speicher. Sowohl Grafikkarten-Power, SSD, als auch Lohndamm.
Stimmt, und es wird auch wieder dunkler. Wir haben ja dieses, wie mit dem Fensterkreuz habe ich ja mal erklärt, die Stelle, wo halt zwischen den Pixel muss halt dunkel sein, weil muss ja irgendwas sein und dann wird es halt dunkler.
Transistoren musst du da auch noch runter drängen.
Das ist doch da, wo der Fnord ist.
Na ja, kann sein. Man muss halt abwarten, vielleicht ist es ja auch nur so ein Marketing-Gag und sie wollen mal hier, wie sagt man, das Wasser testen.
Würdest du dir ein iPad Mini kaufen?
Ich werde mir jetzt erstmal kein iPad Mini kaufen, weil ich auch beim iPad Mini das selbe Problem habe, wie mit den anderen iPads, dass ich einfach keine Anwendung habe dafür. Ich habe zwar eine im Sinn und da sind die iPad Minis in gewisser Hinsicht noch besser geeignet als die iPads. Hier so als Studio-Steuerung, weil dann nehmen sie nicht ganz so viel Platz weg. Das iPad Mini ist, glaube ich, auch ein echter Kandidat, was jetzt so diese ganzen Integrationen betrifft, die es ja jetzt schon gibt. Wenn du hier so über die Musikmesse latschst und so weiter, tonnenweise so Mixer, Controls, Tra-la-la. Da mag manchmal auch das iPad die bessere Wahl sein, weil es einfach mehr Fläche, mehr Platz bietet. Aber das iPad Mini ist dann eben für kleinere Konstellationen besser.
Kurze Zwischenfrage, Chef. Erstens, deine App, die du dir dann da machen lassen willst oder die es schon gibt, die dann auf dem iPad Mini wäre, warum machst du die nicht einfacher und gibst die uns hier auf unseren Laptops? Weil das Ding läuft sowieso die ganze Zeit, das ist auch nicht gescreen-lockt, sondern dann hätte ich da das, was ich auch immer auf dem iPad Mini machen würde, oder halt das gleiche auf unserem iPhone, wobei ich da aber anlocken würde, deswegen wäre auf dem Rechner eigentlich noch viel cooler. Dann brauchen wir keine Geräte, keinen extra Platz, weil ist alles schon da.
Na, du würdest halt nicht auf deinem Rechner rumtatschen, weil der hat keinen Touch?
Ich muss nicht touchen, ich hab ein Trackpad und so. Aber so muss ich erst mal ein Gerät suchen, eventuell muss ich es anlocken, weil sonst die Batterie leer ist.
Ja, dann musst du aber erstmal deine Fenster beiseite räumen, das hast du nicht immer im Blick, da bist du nicht mal eben schnell auf einer Reuspertasse. Wenn du erst mal 30 Fenster aus dem Weg räumen musst und durch Apple-Tab, durch deine Tastelleiste durchgehen musst, bis du dann deinen User-Interface gefunden hast, dann ist einfach mal der Sinn von so etwas weg.
Das iPad Mini wäre aber nur schneller, weil es die ganze Zeit an ist und die ganze Zeit so genau da liegt, dass ich genau sofort klicken kann. Dann weiß ich aber jetzt schon, dass man andauernd hier irgendwie, dass bei den Dingern auch immer grundsätzlich das Stromkabel mit drin hängen muss.
Na klar, das hätte so ein eigenes Gehäuse. Also ideal wären ja diese Glas-Präsentations-Teile, die in den Apple Stores sind, die uns Apple ja nicht verkaufen will. Die haben ja auch die iPad so umgebaut, dass sie ihren Zugang unten in der Mitte haben. Die leisten sich ja gar nicht diesen Stecker von der Seite, sondern haben den irgendwie in der Mitte, damit das halt schick aussieht. Das hätte ich ja mal gerne als Kit oder als Option. Aber an sowas dachte ich halt, einfach so eine Einfassung, so ähnlich wie eben dieses Cover. Also das Cover wäre sozusagen die einfache Variante. Dieses Case, dieses iPad-Case. Was es leider wiederum fürs Mini nicht gibt, da gibt es jetzt wieder nur dieses bekloppte magnetische Smart-Cover.
Was ja wohl auch recht schlecht sein soll.
Das habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Max tweetete sowas.
iPad als Irrweg.
Naja, so schlimm ist es nun auch nicht.
Ich würde mir auch irgendwas bauen aus Holz, keine Ahnung, ist egal. Ich will das hier sozusagen fest auf dem Tisch haben, weil nur fest auf dem Tisch funktioniert immer. Das schließt ja nicht aus, dass du das dann auch mit irgendeiner bekloppten Software machen kannst. Ich will das sowieso mit OSC lösen. Das Problem ist, erstmal brauche ich die Software dahinter. Das ist leider immer noch Zukunftsmusik, aber man kommt ja jetzt zu nichts. Wie auch immer, das iPad Mini schließt einfach eine interessante Lücke, weil manchmal ist einfach so ein Touch oder ein iPhone zu klein und ein iPad zu groß. Ob das jetzt meine Anwendung oder jemand anderes Anwendung ist, das ist einfach die Wende universal.
Ich habe ja auch kein iPad, aber ich benutze den ab und zu bei so einem Kumpel immer, wenn ich zu faul bin, wenn ich meinen Rechner rausdrehe, ist ja auch der Moment, wo man halt Bock hat auf so ein iPad, wenn man gerade zu faul für irgendwas ist und einfach nur mal klicken will. Aber da ist es mir zu schwer. Und wenn ich am Tisch sitze, dann ist mir mein Laptop ja doch lieber, dann kann ich auch meinen Laptop da hinstellen.
Da brauchst du nicht so einen extra Ständer für, weil dein Laptop, das ist halt auch im Bett. Wenn ich zum Beispiel irgendwelche Videos gucke, gerade hier so Gitarren und da mach ich meistens noch irgendwie zum Einschlafen, wenn du das iPad dann so versuchst, in irgendeinen Kissen zu drapieren, damit es nicht umfällt und so weiter, das ist total nervig. Nimmst du den Rechner, stellst dir das Display ein, Peng, fertig. Das lüftet dann dafür so ein bisschen dann, aber mit dem iPad, ich finde immer nicht die richtige Situation, wo ich das so, wie ich das halten oder positionieren soll. Also wenn du es auf dem Tisch legst, dann guckst du immer so von oben drauf und machst so den. Die ganze Zeit festhalten willst du es auch nicht.
Also das, was du da hast, ist halt auch irgendwie doof, weil es ist halt so, wie es von Anfang an präsentiert wurde, das Teil fürs Sofa. Das ist einfach was für Couch-Potatoes. Ich sitze so selten auf dem Sofa. Du weißt ja, dass viele Leute viel Zeit auf Sofas rum sitzen. Und sitzen vor allem vor dem Fernseher. Eigentlich ist das iPad geradezu die Fernseher-Konkurrenz schlechthin, weil du einfach, während du vom Fernsehen gelangweilt bist, aber trotzdem hypnotisiert und nicht weichen könnt, dann da so rum sitzt und dann so ein bisschen im Netz surfst. Irgendwann wahrscheinlich auch anfängst du dir die Filme direkt auf dem iPad anzuschauen. Zumindest wenn sie sie von dort dann eben zum Bildschirm zu streamen. Das ist schon ganz klug, wie sie das machen.
Also es gibt so ein Vergleichsbild von einem Retina-iPhone und diesem 440 dBi-Gerät. Aber da die natürlich da auch wieder hier so ein lossy JPEG-Tralala genommen haben, finde ich, kann man es gar nicht so gut vergleichen. Ich finde, die sehen beide unscharf aus.
Du kannst das auch nicht vergleichen auf einem anderen Bildschirm. Du kannst es nicht vergleichen. Du musst es sehen.
Wir haben Fotos gemacht.
Du siehst das hier auf einem anderen Raster. Ja, ja, ja. Irgendetwas wollte ich doch gerade noch aufgreifen. Ach ja, genau. Die Sache mit dem, sind wir durch mit dem Max? Die neuen iMacs sind ja noch nicht draußen. Wann kommen die? Dezember?
iMac hat mich noch nie interessiert irgendwie.
Not my computer.
Ich verstehe das irgendwie nicht, was Sie da so eine Obsession haben, das Ding irgendwie so dünn zu machen.
Das verstehe ich auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Guck mal, jetzt passt noch weniger rein. Auch das Laufwerk nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist nämlich Johnny-RF, der ist schuld. Vielleicht ist auch alles gar nicht so gut.
Ja, hinterher ist die Auflösung, ist die ganze UI total dünn.
Hast du auch das neue Gehäuse gesehen? Das ist jetzt in so einem schrägen Gehäuse, also in der Verpackung.
Ja, vor allem ist es so eine Augenwischerei, wenn du dir mal die Promo-Fotos anschaust auf der Webseite, und zwar alle, alle IMAC-Fotos, die da auf der Webseite zu sehen sind, alle sind aus einem Winkel gemacht, wo man die Wölbung nicht sieht. Wo du die Wölbung...
Na, ist ja wohl klar, oder?
Nicht siehst, aber ich hab das, ich hab, das hab ich sozusagen als erstes gesehen. Und ich dachte mir nur so, fuck, die Scheiße haben das jetzt irgendwie echt so dünn gemacht.
Optische Trick-Zeit, aber es doch...
SSD only und so weiter, das schoss mir irgendwie gleich...
Aber die haben die Fotos doch schon immer so geschossen.
Vorher konnten sie die breite Kante nicht ignorieren.
Aber die breite Kante, da war es ja vorher auch schon ein Stück breiter als die breite Kante oder nicht. Hatte ja trotzdem noch eine Wölbung, oder?
Guck mal hinter dich da. Aber die Kante war breit. Wölbung war da schon auch noch.
Na, da sieht aus dem Fernseher das Ding. Da ist schon noch eine Wölbung. Das ist schon noch mal breiter als die Kante. Und das haben die natürlich nie so fotografiert, dass man diese Fernseher-Boiler da hinten noch sehen kann.
Ja, aber ich meine, es gibt nicht ein Foto, wo man das sehen kann.
Ja, das ist schon...
Das ist halt Marketing pur.
Das finde ich wirklich mega frech. Vor allem, früher gab es ja noch so 360-Grad-Views. Die gibt es auch nicht mehr, oder? Früher? Früher, ihr wisst schon noch.
Da, du bist von der Seite.
Ah, hier haben sie einen irgendwie, in dieser Evolutionsliste haben sie so ein Ding.
Da gab es so ein Foto, ich habe das jetzt nicht wiedergefunden.
Man muss sagen, ok, du hast natürlich recht. Sie waren schon immer hinten gewölbt.
Na, der erste, der ist anscheinend, wenn überhaupt, dann ganz wenig hier, 2004. Der ist wirklich einfach nur so ein Brick.
Genau, und dann haben sie angefangen, immer mehr da so ein Mond-Sichel-Style.
Genau, dann haben sie es schwarz gemacht, damit man sich so sieht.
Ist auch gar nicht so dick.
Aber da gibt es so ein Bild irgendwie, dass das mich fett macht oder so ähnlich. Da hat irgendjemand den iMac genau so fotografiert, dass man die Wölbung schön sehen kann. Das ist halt dann so ein Kontrast irgendwie zu den Marketing-Fotos, wo sie es immer genau aus dem Winkel machen, wo man die Wölbung hinten eben nicht sieht.
Hier haben sie mal zumindest so eine Zeichnung von oben. Also ich bin gespannt, ich finde auch, dass mit dem Fusion-Draft, der iMac ist nach wie vor ein echt interessanter Computer. Also den werden wirklich viele Leute sich klicken.
Ich wäre ein Retina Cinema Display.
Also ich finde nach wie vor so dieses Display, das ja doch irgendwie zwei oder drei Computer lang durchhält, zusammen zu bauen mit einem Computer, der eben nicht zwei oder drei Computer lang durchhält, finde ich nach wie vor irgendwie nicht so richtig toll.
Hast du das mit deinem Laptop auch?
Ja, mit dem Laptop hast du es auch, aber den nimmst du halt auch mit. Also das ist irgendwie ein anderes Gerät.
Oh, der iMac ist jetzt so dünn.
Ja, den kann man auch im Zug benutzen.
Ich habe das Foto auch gesehen.
Ja, er ist ja auch wirklich viel leichter geworden. Das macht natürlich auch was aus, weil so den iMac der letzten Generation...
Ich dachte mal direkt die Zahlen, weil ich meine, ich kann den alten jetzt hier anheben, aber den neuen kann ich nicht anheben.
Tech-Specs.
Ja, der wiegt schon ein bisschen was.
Aber eh in der Fresse, ich kann den nicht mit einer Hand hochheben.
Na ja, der hat eine dicke große Glasscheibe vorne dran, also natürlich wiegt der ein bisschen was.
Ist schon ein ganz schöner Klopper.
Was wiegt der denn jetzt eigentlich? Hier, neuneinhalb Kilo wiegt der neue 27 Zoller. Wieder neue!
Der aktuelle.
Zehn Milchkartons.
Ich guck mal kurz in den McTracker, ob da auch das Gewicht drin ist.
Ich glaube, da standen auch die...
Ja gut, aber ich meine, das ist ein Rechner, den packst du einmal aus und stellst ihn auf den Schreibtisch und gut isst. Ist jetzt nicht interessant, ob einmal ein Kilo mehr oder weniger hat.
Mein Schreibtisch ist eine riesengroße Glasscheibe, das ist schon interessant.
Ob es Pling macht oder nicht. Ja, weil wenn du drunter sitzt, du sitzt öfter unter deinem Schreibtisch.
Also 20... Meine Knie sind natürlich unter der Scheibe.
Der 27 Zoll iMac, der wiegt 30 Pfund.
13,8 Kilo hat der.
Also 15 Kilo.
Nein, 13,8 Kilogramm.
Hat der, der jetzt in der Ecke steht.
Hat der, der in der Ecke liegt. Das heißt, sie haben das Teil um 4 Kilo leichter gemacht. Das ist schon was.
Das ist schon was, ja.
Das merkste.
Das ist dann schon was anderes. So ein Rechner, der leicht durch die Gegend zu tragen ist, wird dann auch so ein flexibel... Ich meine, du hast da in der Regel auch keine Kabel groß dran. Heutzutage. Alles ist irgendwie wireless. Nur noch Strom. Trägst du irgendwo anders hin, arbeitest du damit irgendwie weiter.
Nein, gut.
Das ist jetzt wirklich nicht der wichtigste Aspekt.
Also damals, als der Gungeon, als ich so frisch noch im Club war, da kam einmal der Gungeon rein und hatte ja...
Wegen, dass ich dir die Hängematte mit seinem...
Nee, der kam ja an und hatte irgendwie den Röhrenmonitor vorne an den Körper geschnallt und hinten den fetten Desktop-Rechner so schön mit spannenden Gurt, da hatte er sich das um den Leib geschnallt und ist damit durch die S-Bahn gestiefelt und hat seinen Rechner in den Club geschleift, um da ein bisschen zu hacken. Das ist dann auf jeden Fall schon...
Da brauch man sich ja nur früher vor den Kongressen angucken, wie seine Warteschlangen standen mit ihren Desktops.
Ja, wie man mit diesen großen Wagen irgendwie auf den Camp...
Genau, wie der Papa mit dem Auto vorfährt und dann hinten die Klappe aufmachen und dann erstmal 10 Leute schleppen müssen.
Die Zeiten sind echt vorbei, ey. Heute war in der Hosentasche irgendwie das 50-fache an Rechnergeschwindigkeit an Bord. Ja, wo wir noch über neue Geräte reden, habt ihr schon mal so eine Surface in der Hand gehabt? Nee, ich hab das mal berührt. Also ich hatte jetzt nicht viel Zeit damit verbracht. Ich hab's mir so ein bisschen angeschaut, so ein bisschen bewegt, ein bisschen hochgehoben und so weiter. Ja, ist irgendwie kompakt, ist ordentlich verarbeitet, pipapo, was man so gelesen hat, stimmt im Wesentlichen auch.
Also Hardware ist erstmal ganz okay.
Hardware ist erstmal so ganz okay, nur dass ich halt dieses Prinzip sehr zweifelhaft finde. Ich meine, du hast da so ein Teil, das ist so wie ein Tablet, was irgendwie nach einer Tastatur schreit. Da gab es auch diese lustige Zeichnung, so Laptop irgendwie so unten breit, Bildschirm dünn und Surface ist irgendwie oben breit und Tastatur dünn. Also das Ding ist irgendwie auf dem Kopf. Und vor allem, du kannst ja dann sozusagen nur diesen einen Stand da rausklappen.
Was war das, 27,5 Grad? Was war das?
Hab ich mir nicht gemerkt, aber es gibt sozusagen nur exakt einen Winkel, in dem du dieses Ding hinstellen kannst mit den eingebauten Maßnahmen. Und dann hast du die Tastatur da wie so ein Waschlappen davor. Wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, du kannst dieses Teil nur auf dem Tisch benutzen. Und dann frage ich mich, warum ist das dann überhaupt ein Tablet? Okay, ich kann es dann zuklappen, nehmen und theoretisch auch in der Hand halten und es als Tablet benutzen.
Und woanders auf einen anderen Tisch stellen.
Aber dann ist es halt trotzdem irgendwie noch so ein 16 zu 9-Bildschirm und das merke ich halt auch bei diesem Nexus 7 wieder so. Also 16 zu 9 ist da einfach nicht das richtige Format für Portrait-Anwendung. Alles in dieser Android-Windows-Landschaft hat sich irgendwie voll auf Landscape eingeschossen. Die kommen da irgendwie nicht weg. Während es beim iPad ist Portrait irgendwie Default. Du kannst auch Landscape machen, aber du fängst irgendwie, die meisten Sachen sind irgendwie Portrait. Also besonders stark ist es halt auf dem iPhone.
Ja, Booten.
Ja, aber die Anwendungen haben auf jeden Fall auch eine klare Vorstellung davon, wie sie in Portrait arbeiten und wie sie in Landscape arbeiten. Und beide sind irgendwie gleichberechtigt. Also vielleicht ist Bevorzugung ein bisschen zu weit gesagt, aber beide Modi sind ausgeprägt.
Das ist zumindest beim iPad.
Ja, das meine ich.
Beim iPhone ist wahrscheinlich Landscape eher noch ein bisschen bevorzugt.
Richtig, aber bei den Android Tablets oder auch bei diesem Surface ist halt irgendwie alles Landscape.
Portrait findet nicht statt.
Portrait findet nicht statt. So, naja, und so die Software, also ich weiß nicht, warum alle diese kache Geschichte jetzt so in den Himmel loben. Ich habe noch nicht so ganz verstanden, warum das jetzt unbedingt der große Wurf sein soll. Okay, die können mir da irgendwas kommunizieren, aber du blickst eigentlich die ganze Zeit auf so ein Puzzle-Blinkwald. Ja, der versucht dir die ganze Zeit, irgendwas zu kommunizieren, was auch irgendwie anstrengend sein kann, kann ich mir zumindest vorstellen.
Naja, also eins muss man ihnen lassen, es ist die einzige runde Sache, die nicht direkt nach Apple aussieht.
Apple hat sich ja auch runde Ecken passieren lassen.
Nein, rund im Sinne von, im Design her ist es, vom Designkonzept her ist es...
Schlüssig.
Schlüssig, genau. Schlüssig ist ein guter Ausdruck. Ist es aber nicht. Während alles, was von Android kommt, also von Schlüssig kann man da wirklich nirgendwo reden. Aber dieses Microsoft, jetzt mal abgesehen von diesen zwei Benutzungsmodien mit Desktop und Kacheln. Das hat jetzt überhaupt nichts mehr mit Schlüssig zu tun. Aber wenn man jetzt allein den Kachel-Ansicht ansieht von dem, also gut, ich kenn's halt jetzt nur vom Desktop, weil ich mal die Probe Windows 8 da geladen hab, dann muss ich sagen, ja, das kann ich halbwegs verstehen. Also das ist nicht komplett Unsinn, würd ich sagen.
Es ist nicht völlig scheiße.
Es ist nicht völlig scheiße. Nein, es ist, ich würde da jetzt nicht in Begeisterungsstürme ausbrechen, aber es ist doch zumindest was, wo ich sagen würde, es ist schlicht, es ist schön designt, zumindest halbwegs. Jetzt hängt wahrscheinlich davon ab, was man da so für Kacheln hat. Aber prinzipiell hat das mal ein Designer gesehen. Bei den meisten Android-Geräten hat man das Gefühl, Designer kennen die gar nicht. Also, ja, aber ich hab's halt, wie gesagt, auch nur auf dem Desktop bzw. in der Virtual Box versucht.
Ja, man wird's abwarten müssen, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht mega rasant. Also, es spricht halt relativ wenig dafür, dass man auch eins kauft. Man ist ganz okay darüber zu philosophieren, wenn es vor einem steht. Und dann, naja, mit diesem Windows 8.
Was ich das geilste fand, Moment, muss ich kurz sagen, zum Thema kaufen. Windows RT, dieses, was auf der ARM-Version von einem Surface ist, hat in der Grundinstallation 18 Gigabyte. Das heißt, von dem 32 Gigabyte Tablett, was man da kauft, was einem ja als so unglaublich günstig verkauft wird, weil es hat ja 32 Gigabyte Flash, gehen 18 für das Betriebssystem drauf.
18, 14?
18 sind übrig, ja, irgendwie so was. Also auf jeden Fall kommt man letzten Endes bei auch nicht mehr raus, als wenn man ein iPad mit 16 Gigabyte hat.
Was soll das jetzt eigentlich für eine Meldung mit Werbung in Windows 8?
Es gibt da irgendwelche Apps, die auch bei Windows 8 dabei sind, die tatsächlich halt Werbung anzeigen. Ich kann dir das gerade mal nicht benennen.
Achso, aber es macht nicht das OS immer hin.
Nee, aber es hat jetzt auch nicht bundelt Apps, sondern schon Apps des OS, aber ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht genau welche, falls da jemand noch mal einen Link hat, dann...
Habt ihr auch das Video gesehen, wo sie die besoffenen Windows 8 testen lassen haben?
Hast du nicht gesehen?
Ja, das ist großartig.
Ich muss mal gucken, ich tue mal raus.
Nee, soll mal der Chat machen, ich bin zu faul. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall voll witzig.
Ja, was wollte ich dir noch sagen?
Windows 8.
Vielleicht der Desktop-Mode. Als ich gerade in Kolumbien, in Bogota war, was eine merkwürdige Stadt ist, weil das ist so eine von diesen Städten, wo so alles, also wenn du irgendwie irgendwas aus Kategorie, also irgendein Produkt in der Kategorie X kaufen willst, dann gibt es da nicht einen Laden dafür, sondern einen Stadtteil. Also wenn du Schuhe kaufen willst, gibt es dafür den passenden Stadtteil. Oder wenn du Elektronik kaufen willst, gibt es dafür auch den passenden Stadtteil. Und so war ich in so einer Mall, und diese gesamte Mall bestand aus 100 kleinen Läden, die dir alle im Prinzip denselben Scheiß verkauft haben. Also du kannst sozusagen in jedem Laden den gleichen Dreckbunch von USB-Scheiß kaufen und sonstigen PC-Gelrotz, wo es sozusagen vollkommen egal ist, ob du da jetzt eine halbe Stunde durchläufst oder nicht. Du siehst sowieso immer wieder nur dasselbe. Das heißt, da standen dann auch überall PCs in allen Formen und Farben rum und offensichtlich hat Microsoft selbst in Kolumbien da irgendwie so viel Geld ins Marketing reingeschossen, dass einfach überall alles voll war mit Aufklebern auf dem Boden, jetzt Windows 8 kacheln auf dem Boden, so haha und dann natürlich irgendwie tonnenweise so komische neue PCs, die so komische Touch-Hybriden sind, also wo der Bildschirm dann nochmal so ein Touch-Bildschirm hat, obwohl es irgendwie eigentlich ein normaler PC ist und dann natürlich Windows 8 drauf. So und dann hab ich so ein bisschen versucht, das zu bedienen und da hab ich wieder gemerkt, wie wichtig das ist, dass Hardware und Software aus einem Guss sind. Weil du hast ja zum Beispiel in Windows 8 verschiedene Gesten, die davon ausgehen, dass du so von der Seite in den Bildschirm reinwischst. Und nun war halt Windows 8 auf so komischen PCs installiert, die zwar einen Touch-Bildschirm hatten, wo aber der Rand nochmal übersteht über den eigentlichen Bildschirm. Ja, wo du diese Geste einfach nicht generieren konntest, weil du musstest sozusagen mit deinem Finger dann am Rand da so reinprokeln, um dann wirklich so die Kante zu treffen, damit das Windows 8 das auch wirklich als Geste vom Rand... Weil du musst ja sozusagen das erste Touch-Pixel schon berühren, sonst ist es ja nicht an der Seite. Und das war einfach physikalisch unmöglich. Also es ging, wenn du sozusagen ganz bewusst gesteuert hast, aber eben mal so undenkbar. Das heißt, das funktioniert wahrscheinlich auch alles überhaupt nicht. Abgesehen bezweifle ich ohnehin, dass so Touch auf vertikalen Bildschirmen, die so stehen, das funktioniert nicht.
Ja, in der Virtual Box hat es ja auch nicht richtig funktioniert, aber das liegt halt auch daran, dass du halt dieses Fenster hast. Wenn du über den Rand von dem Fenster hinausgehst, mir Mauszeige, dann bist du halt aus dem Fenster raus. Das heißt, du kannst auch nicht von draußen reinwischen.
Ja, stimmt. Na gut, ich mein, das iPad hat das ja auch, das iPhone auch. Aber da ist halt die Hardware so, dass es eben einen Rand gibt, wo du... Naja, das ist mir nur so aufgefallen. Das ist ein bisschen albern. Also Surface, meinetwegen. Aber das Teil ist jetzt irgendwie, ich weiß nicht...
Hast du den Desktop-Mode mal gewechselt?
Ja, meinst du, das rechtfertigt jetzt den Rausschmiss von dem Zinowski?
Keine Ahnung, was da gerade läuft.
Oder wie er heißt?
Scheint gerade das große Aufräumen in der IT-Branche zu sein, oder?
Weil ich meine, es ist ein bold move. Aber der bold move ist halt irgendwie auf dünnem Eis, habe ich das Gefühl.
Ist der jetzt eigentlich rausgeschmissen worden oder ist der gegangen? Das habe ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden.
Na ja, wenn jemand in der Position plötzlich meint, er müsse gehen, dann ist das meistens nicht so.
Das ist ein und dasselbe, schmissen und gehen.
Ja, würde ich sagen, ab einer bestimmten Hierarchiestufe ist das das gleiche, glaube ich.
Also du gehst, weil sie dich dann schmeißen würden, oder was?
Der hängt ja auch verdrinnen in der Firma, oder?
Ich meine, wenn der Typ, derjenige war, auf dessen Mist Windows 8 und Surface tatsächlich entstanden ist.
Und 7.
7 auch?
Der ist seit 13 Jahren da.
Ja gut, aber halt auch 8 und Surface und ja, Windows Phone 7 wahrscheinlich auch, weiß ich nicht.
Und auch einer, der auf der Bühne sich nicht komplett zum Hampelmann macht, wenn er Sachen präsentiert.
Ich meine, Microsoft hat da ohnehin irgendwie einen Drain. Ich meine, die sind ja nur ein laufendes Drain. Da ist ja nicht der erste, der gegangen ist.
Der Elop ist ja gegangen.
Der Elop ist zu Nokia gegangen. Da sind auch zwei andere Vögel irgendwie auch gegangen.
Ja, aber mal ganz ehrlich, ab einer bestimmten Stufe bei Microsoft stehst du halt direkt unter Bauma und da kann man doch nicht arbeiten, oder?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich kann mir das eh nicht vorstellen.
Also die alte Cokes Nase, das würde ich nicht aushalten. Developers, Developers, Developers.
Ja, der Schwitzer, das ist einfach...
Mit dem willst du auf jeden Fall nicht auf einer einsamen Insel stranden. Das kann man schon mal ganz deutlich festhalten.
Ja, ich... Tja, wir brauchen charismatische Führer.
Der ist ja bei diesem Pirates in the Silicon Valley, dieser Steve Jobs Movie, da ist schon ein bisschen älter. Da wird der Bauma ja auch von so einem Typen gespielt, das ist eigentlich auch ganz cool, da kommt der ganz gut rüber.
Was?
Müsste mal gucken, das ist ganz witzig. Ist jetzt nicht so der Überfilm, aber ist ganz nett.
War ja auch glaube ich erst nur ein Fernsehfilm, ne?
Ja, ist so ein ganz El-Gipo-Ding, ist jetzt kein Film.
Aber den kann man schon mal gucken.
Aber ist trotzdem witzig, also so. Was ich noch letztens geguckt habe, es gibt ja dieses Steve Jobs The Lost Interview, angeblich wurde der auch in Kinos gespielt oder so, da wollten sie es jetzt nicht so lange her, als sie das gemacht haben. Den habe ich mir mal nicht im Kino angeguckt. Und ja, ist auch ganz witzig, kann man auch mal gesehen haben. Also ich habe dieses Steve Jobs Buch immer noch nicht gelesen, habe ich mir irgendwie gespart. Aber das Interview ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Kann ich nur empfehlen, kann man mal geguckt haben.
Wenn es mal irgendwo rausfällt, meinst du?
Ja, wenn man es mal, genau.
The Lost Interview.
Wenn es einmal auf den Rechner fällt, kann man es mal gucken.
Das werde ich mal tun.
So, ich wollte noch mal im Nachgang zu unserer, der ganzen Geschichte hier, wir und unsere Datalsysteme. Das wollte ich vorhin eigentlich schon ansprechen, aber es ist gut gekommen. Ja, naja, wir haben ja schon darauf hingewiesen, Backup ist eine gute Idee. Vor kurzem bin ich dann auch endlich mal auf deinen Ratschlag eingegangen und habe mal dem Programm ARK, die Gelegenheit gegeben, zu zeigen, was es so drauf hat. Ich würde jetzt noch nicht von intensiven Testing sprechen, aber ich habe zumindest mal beschlossen, jetzt mal Geld auszugeben für Backups. Und ich fühle mich auch schon ein bisschen besser. Und dann gab es aber, vielleicht noch mal kurze Erinnerung, ARK ist halt so ein kleines Tool, was sich so ein bisschen im Toolbar da versteckt, aber auch ein ordentliches Macintosh-Programm ist. Nicht hier so eine komische Java-Schlampe, die dann irgendwie mit so hässlichen Buttons und so weiter, wir kennen das ja alle.
Java-Schlampe.
Ist doch wirklich.
Ist doch wahr.
Schlimm. Und jetzt kriege ich bestimmt wieder einen Shofi-Preis. Egal, aber ich verscheinbar auch verdient. ARK, sehr einfach zu konfigurieren. Man schmeißt da seine Amazon S3 Keys rein, die man da vorgeneriert bekommen, wenn man sich da einen Account aufmacht und da eine Kreditkarte am Start hat, wo man abgebucht werden darf. So, ja, und dann sagst du einfach dieser Ordner und dieser Ordner und dieser Ordner, bitte back up und dann geht das halt Schwupps hoch auf S3.
Schwupps ja schonmal nicht, oder?
Schwupps mal nicht. Also da musst du schon eine Schwupps-Leitung haben für, oder?
Dann sag mal, wie lange Schwupps gedauert hat.
Und für wieviel natürlich, also es dauert halt schon so sein Moment, es ist nicht so...
Ja, es kann mir aber auch egal sein. Also ich meine, abgesehen jetzt von den klassischen Problematiken, die man eben so hat mit HFS Plus und Backups, die so während das Dateisystem sich darunter ändert, irgendwie ein Backup machen, das ist natürlich so der Klassiker. Aber ich hab jetzt vor allem mal auch, also vorher hab ich bei solchen Backup-Lösungen, wenn es jetzt nicht lokal war, sondern irgendwie remote, wo es immer ein Problem war mit dem Platz und dem Preis, hab ich eigentlich immer nur so meine heißesten Daten, die ich auf gar keinen Fall verliere, weil ich mit denen immer arbeite. Und dann legt man immer alles andere, was immer so schwer und groß war, das legt man dann doch mal auf irgendwelche Platten, die legen dann in irgendwelchen Regalen und da vergisst man sie dann und dann findet man sie nicht wieder.
Angenommen hier, die Straße, in der du wohnst, hier brennt ab? Ja, ok, oder nur deine Bude und deine ganzen Rechner sind weg. Jetzt nur noch die Keys, um da wieder ranzukommen. Ausgedruckt? Digital aber nur woanders nochmal.
Digital auf so USB-Sticks und...
Die liegen ja dann eventuell auch zu Hause rum, sind ja auch im Arsch dann.
Ja, halt auch welche, die nicht zu Hause rumliegen.
Aber die Keys, also du brauchst ja eigentlich nur deine Passphrase quasi wissen, oder? War das nicht so?
Die Arc Passphrase, du musst dann deinen Amazon-Account natürlich irgendwie noch rankommen.
Ja gut, das ist beides, glaube ich, sehr einfach möglich.
Ja, im Wesentlichen, ich hab halt einfach ein Master-Passwort für eine Keychain und diese Keychain hab ich halt gebackupt. Und da ist alle meine Passwörter drin. Breaking News, vor ein paar Wochen kam Amazon, ich weiß nicht, ob wir da überhaupt schonmal drüber gesprochen haben.
Wir hatten drüber geredet, glaube ich, ja.
Und kam ja raus hier mit diesem neuen Backup-System Glacier, Glacier, Gletscher Fu und das versprach ja deutlich niedrigere Preise, die ungefähr bei 10% liegen von dem, was man bei S3 zahlt. Das ist dann sowas wie ein US-Cent pro Gigabyte pro Monat, den du da ablegst, also für 10 Euro kannst du einen Terabyte, für 10 Euro im Monat kannst du einen Terabyte ablegen. Das ist so die Größenordnung, wo ich sagen will, was interessant ist.
Und man zahlt nochmal Geld, wenn man es wieder haben will, so war es doch irgendwie, oder?
Nur, also ich hab jetzt...
Nur, wenn man es wieder haben will.
Nur, wenn du es wieder haben willst. Nein, also du musst...
Nur, wenn du eine bestimmte Menge davon wieder haben willst.
Es gibt verschiedene Einschränkungen, womit sie sicherstellen wollen, dass du das nicht so als Online-Storage benutzt, weil der Punkt ist, dass sie wahrscheinlich dahinter das mit irgendwelchen Tape-Robotern organisieren und so, deswegen ist der Zugriff auch nicht immediate. Wenn du eben auf die Daten zugreifen möchtest, musst du das erstmal anstoßen und dann wird dir in einem Zeitfenster von bis zu vier Stunden dann irgendwann der synchronen Zugriff gewährt und dann hast du die Daten für 24 Stunden im Zugriff, bis du diesen Zugriff wieder neu anstoßen müsstest und du darfst auch innerhalb eines Monats nur auf fünf Prozent deiner Daten, die du überhaupt abgelegt hast, zugreifen und das auch noch auf die Tage verteilt. Das heißt, du darfst quasi pro Tag circa ein Dreißigstel der Daten, die dann eben insgesamt fünf Prozent ausmachen, zugreifen, wenn du nichts zusätzlich zahlen möchtest. Wenn du aber jetzt wirklich diesen Fall hast, Haus brennt ab, alles ganz schlimm, ich brauche meine Daten wieder, dann zahlst du irgendeine Strafgebühr, dass du da voll Zugriff drauf kriegst und dann kannst du auch natürlich auch alles runterlutschen, aber kostet halt irgendwie extra. Aber ich meine, das ist dann wirklich noch das geringste Problem. Aber es geht nicht darum, einen abzukassieren, wenn man an die Daten ran will, sondern es geht darum, dass sie sich eben sicherstellen wollen, dass es sich wirklich um selten bewegtes Datenmaterial handelt, damit es eben für sie auch wirklich so billig ist, damit sie sich diesen Preis auch leisten können bei der hohen Zuverlässigkeit.
Aber die werden ja auch irgendwelche Tapes wegschreiben, wo sie halt nicht so schnell rankommen.
Genau, so. Und das ist quasi das Ding und das heißt, für mich ist das ja sozusagen auch so, ich lege die Daten dahin, in der Hoffnung, nie wieder ranzumüssen. Eigentlich will ich sie immer im Zugriff haben, aber mir geht es einfach darum, mal wirklich ruhig schlafen zu können, was die Daten betrifft, um zu wissen, selbst wenn mir hier die ganze Bude ausgeräumt wird, kann ja sein, hier ist hier wie ein Einbruch und sie finden auch noch die letzte gut versteckte Festplatte, etc. oder machen es kaputt oder was auch immer. Oder halt... Ja und vor allem, wenn du halt mal an irgendeinen Pfeil ran musst, so aus dieser, ich schreibe jetzt hier ungefähr gefühlt so vielleicht eine 1,5 Terabyte Daten dahin, gerade alles noch am Laufen.
Seit wann?
Das ist zwar auch nicht durchgehend, ich hab das hier irgendwie unterbrochen und Updates und Pieper. Aber irgendwann wird es dann halt weg sein, das geht an sich ganz gut voran, ist mir auch Wurst, Hauptsache es wird irgendwann mal fertig. So, und angenommen, ich muss halt jetzt mal an 10 GB ran, dann geht das halt auch. Und mal ehrlich, 10 GB mal eben aus dem Backup holen, das macht man schon wirklich sehr selten. Sehr selten. Also das wird wahrscheinlich einfach vollkommen ausreichen.
Ja, also bisher hatte ich ja keinen Festplatten-Crash mehr, seitdem ich da auch bin.
Ah, das ist so wie mit dem Regenschirm.
Doch, nee, Quatsch, hatte ich schon mal, stimmt gar nicht, aber da hatte ich noch einen Time-Machine-Backup und hab nur Teile aus dem Ding. Und bisher war es halt immer so irgendwie, ich hatte letztens mal so zum Beispiel mit meinen Keychains rum experimentiert, dann hab ich die eine aus Versehen doch… Ne, das war kürzlich, erst hab ich meine Keychains zerschossen und dann irgendwie halt mal so schnell mal eben wieder die Keychain halt aus dem Arc-Backup rauskratzen und so ne Sachen. Das war noch ein anderer Fall, genau. Also ich hole auch tatsächlich aus dem Arc-Backup bisher immer so, ah, irgendwas ist hier kaputt und ich weiß noch so, in etwa vor zwei Monaten war es aber noch ok, dann klick ich da mal kurz und hol mir die Version da raus. Und dafür funktioniert das echt gut. Und ich hatte ja einmal mir auch die Festplatte zerschossen oder die war zerschossen und dann musste ich größere Brocken da aus, ich glaube meinen ganzen Library-Folder und mein ganzes, ja doch den ganzen User-Library-Folder hatte ich da drin und das waren auch so ein paar Gigabyte und das hat dann halt so sein Moment gedauert, aber es ging halt einmal, die abinstalliert, eingeloggt mit Passphrase und Amazon-Account und dann kam es halt alles runter wieder und war auch alles ok.
Na ich mache immer noch Time Machine und inzwischen kann man ja sogar zwei Festplatten als Ziel auswählen, könnte man theoretisch, wenn man irgendwie auf Arbeit ist und zu Hause oder noch ein eigenes Büro hat, an beiden Lokalitäten irgendwie Backup machen.
Ja ich mache auch Time Machine, aber in letzter Zeit ist er immer relativ oft dabei und will wieder ein komplett neues Backup anlegen.
Das nervt dermaßen.
Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist. Ist das irgendwie…
Das nervt mich auch.
Ist das ein Update-Problem? Auf dem FreeBSD-Server mit Netatalk.
Welche Version? Netatalk? Die haben einen Bucket-Fix. Seitdem ist es nicht mehr.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wo 2, 3, 3 brauchst du?
Oder 2, 2, 3? Aber ich hab das auch häufig mit der Time-Capsule.
Echt?
Das Ding…
Also bei dem Netatalk haben sie da irgendwann so einen Bucket-Fix und dann war das wohl weg. Seitdem hatte ich das auch wirklich nicht mehr.
Aber das nervt so dermaßen, weißt du? Dann kommt einfach dein Backup, wo du dich die Anzahl darauf verlassen hast, wo du jetzt irgendwie auch so Diffs gespeichert hast seit einem Jahr. Und dann kommt er einfach hoch und sagt, äh, äh, scheiße, ich muss mal alles löschen und mach noch mal neu. Das kann ja so schlimm nicht sein, oder? Das ist irgendwie nicht so die Art, die ich mir unter Backup vorstelle, oder? Ich meine, das geht nicht.
Also bei ARK gab es ja mal in einer Version, da hatte er auch irgendwie so ein Problem und dann musste da irgendwie alles nochmal rausgebackupt werden, aber das war bisher einmal und dann hat er auch den Bucket-Fix und dann war es auch wieder okay. Aber bei Time Machine hatte ich das auch schon ein paar Mal zu oft.
Wenn du zwischendurch deine Ports geupdatet hast, dann hat er das geupdatet, aber du hast die eventuell nicht installiert.
Das Ding, was ich auch bei Time Machine immer nervt, also bei mir ist es halt so, ich habe ja so diese ganzen vielen externen Festplatten immer rumliegen. Achso, mach mal ab.
Denis, chatet miteinander, wir machen hier gerade eine Live-Sendung.
Genau, die ganzen externen Festplatten rumliegen und dann ist halt immer so, okay auf welcher externen Platte war denn jetzt wohl dieses Backup, wo noch dieses Pfeil drin war und so. Und das jetzt, das wurde halt so schön dein, einmal alle Zeitstempel und dann klickst du einfach so durch und brauchst, dann hast du nicht diese ganzen physikalischen Dinge und dann ach, jetzt ist es, bei diesen externen Platten ist ja noch das Schlimme, wenn die in so einem Gehäuse sind, dann brauchst du da einen anderen Stromadapter als für das nächste Gehäuse. Ich hab so echt so ein Wild wuchsen und ich hab die mittlerweile alle ausgebaut und nehme dann so einen Universal SATA Adapter, das hat die Situation schon mal verbessert, aber es ist halt trotzdem so, ok, jetzt alle Platten nacheinander anstecken, dann geht die eine nicht.
Ich hab aber noch einen Nachtrag. Erstens, ARK macht ja sozusagen so ein eigenes Format. Weißt du eigentlich, was das ist, was er da schreibt? Also ich meine, du kannst das, was mit ARK weggeschrieben ist, auch nur mit ARK wieder zurücklesen. Das ist eigentlich so eine Sache, wo ich mir noch sage, ich hätte eigentlich mal lieber so ein Time Machine 2 S3 Interface.
Naja, der macht ja halt, also er macht ja diese Blöcke da erstmal von deinen Daten, dann dedupliziert er die Blöcke, also über diese Checksums und dann macht er noch eine Encryption drüber, das heißt, wahrscheinlich gibt's da, ich könnte mir jetzt vorstellen, wenn du ihn fragst, okay, wie kann ich mir denn jetzt aus den Daten das wieder zurückkonstruieren, vielleicht gibt's da sogar einen sane Weg, so wie irgendjemand halt den, so das File Vault, die File Vault Prozedur wieder auseinander gebröselt hat und ich vermute mal, wenn du den fragst, dann sagt er dir das auch.
Gut, ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht kritisieren, ich sag nur, so ist das und ich könnte mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass es jetzt Leute gibt, die sagen, abhängig von einer Software und Mac-Only und lalala, kann ich alles total verstehen. Jetzt ist ja so, für S3 gibt's ne Menge Tools wie Transmit und so weiter, die so FTP-Zugriff, also File Transfer machen, die mittlerweile auch S3 nativ unterstützen und dann stellt sich das einem ja so semi-heirarchisch dar. Man hat da so seinen Top-Level, wo man eben mit seinem Account aufschlägt und dann hast du da so Buckets, was im Prinzip so Directories sind, wo du dann eben Files reinschmeißen kannst, aber nicht nochmal Directories. Das heißt, du musst auf S3 eigentlich sowieso irgendwie ne Abstraktion finden, aber du könntest zum Beispiel jetzt so ganz einfach Log-Files da reinschmeißen oder tar, gz, bzip, gz... Es gibt ja auch noch Sachen, eine kleine Sekunde noch. Das kann man sozusagen auch machen, aber das kann man eben nur direkt mit S3 jetzt so ohne weiteres machen. Und heute kam noch ne Mail, ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon gesehen hast, es gibt jetzt von Amazon nochmal ein extra Feature on top auf S3, wo du, hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert, aber du kannst auf dieser Konsole konfigurieren, dass Buckets, die du dir jetzt anlegst, also diese Top-Level-Ordner, mit einem bestimmten Präfix, mit einer von dir eingestellten Zeit nach Creation-Date automatisch auf Glacier ausgelagert werden. Das heißt, du kannst sagen, ich mach jetzt hier mal wieder so ein Backup und dann sagst du, das fängt an mit lalala, Präfix tralala, so to be archived, und stellst ein, ok, wenn das jetzt 30 Tage alt ist, dann schiebst bitte automatisch zu Glacier. Das heißt, du hast quasi deine direkten, gerade eben Backups in teuer, aber eben auch in hoch verfügbar, so für die nächsten Endtage. Und danach werden sie aber von Amazon selbst automatisch weggegossen auf Glacier, sind nach wie vor verfügbar, kosten aber nur noch ein Zehntel, und der Zugriff ist halt beschränkt auf die Art und Weise, wie ich es vorhin beschrieben habe.
Und wie ist das bei Arc, also wie…
Na, wenn du das nicht konfigurierst jetzt, also der Arc greift direkt auf Glacier zu.
Das heißt, der macht das irgendwie automatisch, entscheidet der, was da…
Du sagst das, also man muss auch bei Arc, wenn man das Upgrade gemacht hat auf 3.0, kann man jetzt, also ich hab jetzt irgendwie keinen Weg gefunden, wie ich die alten Backup-Sets da hinschieben konnte, sondern die waren dann einfach weiter auf S3 und sobald das andere fertig ist, werde ich die dann da löschen, um Geld zu sparen. Ich musste nochmal diesen Setup-Prozess mit Eingabe der Amazon-Keys durchgehen und dann hatst du erst einen Zugang, der sowohl S3 als auch Glacier gleichzeitig hat. Also der alte Zugang, die alten Backup-Sets, konnte er nicht jetzt so, ich hab überall geguckt, wo da mal so die Option ist mit jetzt bitte schiebst du auf Glacier, bin irgendwie bekloppt geworden und hab dann auch nicht so ein Handbuch drinsteht und dann hab ich halt einfach das neu eingegeben und siehe da, dann war irgendwie alles so wie gedacht. Aber du kannst halt jetzt für jeden Ordner sagen, der soll zu S3 und der soll zu Google und zu Glacier und mit dieser Automatik kannst du sozusagen auch noch sagen, okay und alles, was bei S3 ist und so ein Bucket ist, was eben schon ein All ist, das wird dann eben auch automatisch weggeschmissen. Das ist mehr so für diese Logfile-Fraktion, also wenn du jetzt so deine Logfiles sicher dauerhaft speichern willst, schiebst du einfach auf S3 und sagst hier der Präfix nach einer Woche ab zu Glacier billig, passt schon.
Okay, es gibt ja noch dieses andere Tool, weil du gerade meintest, falls man jetzt mit so einer Mac-App nicht so glücklich ist, es gibt ja immer noch dieses Tar Snap, das wir auch immer wieder mal erwähnen.
Warte mal, guck mal hier, das ARC-Format ist wohl dokumentiert, wie es aussieht.
Ja, es ist doch ein guter.
Ja, passt schon, okay, alles klar, ist jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres, aber es ist auch nicht so dokumentiert.
Das ist ja doch in einem Nachmittag nach und...
Genau, also als kleine Erlang-Fingerübung. Genau, mit Erlang wahrscheinlich noch am einfachsten zu machen.
Ja, wie gesagt, dieses Tar Snap ist ja von so einem Fribisti-Typie und macht das alles so auf Tormannotzeile letztendlich, also backt auch ab nach Amazon S3 und es gibt es auch schon eine ganze Weile. Hast du das mal benutzt denn jetzt eigentlich?
Tar Snap oder Snip? Tar Snap.
Snap.
Ich mach Time Machine.
Ja, das erinnere ich mich jetzt wieder, aber es war irgendwie teurer oder so.
Geht auch für OS X.
Ich finde ja die Bezeichnung schön, Online-Backups for the truly paranoid.
Ja, da machst du halt wirklich auch alles so ein bisschen selber halt, ne? Also da machst du auch die Keys. Also ich meine, das kannst du ja mit ARK auch machen, deine Keys selber machen und so, aber da ist alles sehr manuell sozusagen und gibt dir dadurch auch ein bisschen mehr Kontrolle.
Na, ich bin ja nicht wirklich paranoid.
Nur so halb.
Ich tu nur so.
Die Kalenderprogrammierer sind hinter dir her.
Nee, ich bin hinter den Kalenderprogrammierern, das ist eine ganz andere Geschichte. So und was soll ich euch sagen?
Sag uns was.
Sag uns doch was.
Ich weiß nicht, wollen wir noch in diesem High, wollen wir in diesem totalen Nerd-Level bleiben? Das ist eigentlich ganz geil gerade, ne?
Ja, es ist gemütlich, da kann man sich nicht beschweren finden.
Bevor wir jetzt hier so auf die seichten Themen wie Abs und so weiter kommen, ne?
Nerd noch mal rum.
Ja, ich hab mich noch weiter mit meiner Fritz!Box angefreundet, hab ich ja schon mal erzählt, ne? Weil ich jetzt wirklich gut miteinander klarkommen mittlerweile, weil ich irgendwie, sagen wir mal, diese Feature-Ritschnisch von diesem Gerät durchaus zu schätzen weiß. Und jetzt hab ich irgendwie auch noch was anderes, das erste Mal ausprobiert. Ich hatte ja irgendwo noch so einen ollen USB-3G-Stick rumgammeln. So ein Teil, was man eigentlich gar nicht in Betrieb nehmen möchte, weil das immer bedeutet, dass du dir so vollkommen mega veraltete Prolo-Software aus Taiwan runterladen musst, die dann irgendwie vorkommen, absurde Dinge mit deinem Dateisystem anstellen und dann trotzdem nicht funktioniert und wenn sie läuft, dich mit so dermaßen übel riechenden User-Interfaces vergrault, dass du eigentlich nur noch schreiend irgendwie aufs Klo rennen möchtest.
Du meinst so Dinge, die sich unter 10 slash Windows slash Program Files installieren wollen?
Nicht ganz so schlimm, die tun schon so ein bisschen so, als wären sie so Macintosh Citizens, aber so Sachen, wo es dann auch keinerlei Updates gibt und die mittlerweile überhaupt nicht mehr laufen, weil sie halt 32 Betreiber installieren und unter 10.8 einfach versagen.
So etwas.
Und so war es ja eben auch bei diesem Stick. Aber, was auch schon seit einiger Zeit geht, dass es jetzt auch überhaupt nichts Neues ist, und das wissen wahrscheinlich auch schon alle, aber es ist ja immer wieder mal was anderes, wenn man es eigentlich mal ausprobiert hat, wie einfach es dann ist, du kannst halt zu jeder Fritz!Box mit halbwegs aktueller Firmware, kannst du diese ollen Gammel-Sticks, die eigentlich nirgendswo wirklich zu verwenden sind, steckst du da einfach rein, machst da eine SIM-Karte rein, so was weiß ich, von dir so eine Multi-SIM oder so, was halt auf demselben Datentarif läuft und nicht groß extra kostet, außer dass du da mal die Strafgebühr für die SIM-Karte hast entrichten müssen und kannst dann in der Fritz!Box relativ easy sagen, ja hier ist übrigens die PIN und wenn mein DSL ausfällt, dann mach doch darüber Internet. Krass. So, und das habe ich ausprobiert, es funktioniert. Also es ist einfach Backup. Das ist cool, ja, kannst du auch als Alternative zu solchen WLAN-Hotspots, kannst du auch einfach so eine olle Fritz!Box mit USB nehmen, falls du noch eine rumliegen hast mit so einem Stick, also wenn sich das gerade so anbietet, die Konfiguration, dann ist das auch so gutes Mobil-Internet für irgendwo, so für alle. Und ich glaube sogar die Fritz!Box hat auch die Option als Fallback auch, sich in ein anderes W-Laden einzubuchen, das habe ich jetzt nicht ausprobiert, das erinnere ich jetzt gerade so, aber ich glaube diese Funktionen gibt es auch, dass du quasi also auch, sprich du hast einfach ein Internetzugangsgerät, was sich mal echt um dein Internetzugang kümmert, weil wenn hier mal wieder Alice sich die Karten legt des Nachts und neulich hatte ich das hier auch wieder mit der Telekom, das ist einfach mal so Internet, nö, dann hast du zumindest, dann musst du halt nicht jetzt hier irgendwie zusehen, dass du alle deine Geräte so neu programmierst, damit sie jetzt dein iPhone benutzen, damit du überhaupt noch irgendwie was atmen kannst, sondern einfach dein Router routet. Das finde ich einfach mal wirklich cool.
Wo kommen wir da hin, wenn der Router routet?
Ja, das ist schon cool.
Ja, das ist wirklich geil. Also wer noch so ein Teil rumliegen hat und noch nie so richtig wusste, ob er das nicht vielleicht besser auf eBay verhökern sollte, obwohl das eh keiner mehr haben will, dann wäre das definitiv eine gute Methode, das da zu entsorgen. Das finde ich irgendwie richtig klasse, gerade so im Hinblick auf eben Notnetz und das scheint ja doch regelmäßig der Fall zu sein. Also ich hatte jetzt, vorgestern hatte ich auch wieder mit meinem Alice auch mal so nachts drei Stunden Netzausfall. Einfach so. Ja, das ist auch eher so 97% und was auch noch sehr hübsch ist mit der Fritz!Box, da bin ich jetzt gerade noch so ein bisschen dabei, das erst so richtig zu erkunden. Das Ding lässt sich ja auch wirklich prima als Telefonanlage missbrauchen und kann auch als VoIP-Station eingerichtet werden. Das heißt, du kannst da so richtig so einen SIP-Zugangsport konfigurieren, also quasi da, wo du sagst, hier steckt ein analoges Telefon und hier ist ein ISDN-Telefon dran, kannst du auch sagen, und hier mach einfach mal einen SIP-Account und dann kannst du halt so einen normalen SIP-Client nehmen und den auch an deine Fritz!Box ranstecken, der dann eben potenziell dein ISDN oder deinen dahinter konfigurierten SIP-Telefonnummer-Account durchreicht und das geht dann eben auch mit entsprechenden Clients auf Computer zum Beispiel. Da gibt es auf dem Mac...
Die eierlegende Wollmilch-Sau.
Jaja, das ist echt die eierlegende Wollmilch.
Das geht aber auch alles schon ewig, oder?
Das geht schon eine Weile, aber das muss auch einfach mal gesagt werden. Zumal eben dieser VoIP-Client-Bereich ist ja auch genauso creepy wie dieser Zugangssoftware für USB-Sticks mit 3G-Karte. Also ich weiß auch nicht, da gibt es auch so eine Verschwörung, dass ein SIP-Software generell hässlich zu sein hat.
Oder VoIP-Software.
Genau. VoIP-Software. Und da gibt es jetzt auch Ausnahmen, also auf dem Mac gab es ja schon immer dieses kostenlose und auch freie, also wo man sich auch die Software runterladen kann, dieses Telefon ab. Das habe ich jetzt allerdings mit der Fritz!Box noch nicht verbunden bekommen, aber das kann auch an mir liegen. Und dann gibt es noch so ein anderes kleines Tool, das heißt Jitsi, J-I-T-S-I, was auch so halbwegs gut funktioniert und vor allem, die Fritz!Box unterstützt halt auch andere Audio-Kollegs. Also du kannst auch G722 machen, das ist dann 15 Kilohertz Telefonie, also anstatt 8 Kilohertz hast du einfach deutlich bessere Voice-Qualität.
Du musst nur noch jemanden anderen auf der Welt finden, der das auch kann.
Ja gut, aber die modernen Decked-Handsets können das halt mittlerweile eigentlich alle. Da in dem Bereich gibt es halt dann durchaus noch ein bisschen Innovation, was so bei ISDN-Telefonen nie so richtig passieren wollte. Und ZIP-Clients halt in zunehmendem Maße. Also ich glaube, die Gesamtsituation wird sich da verbessern. Jetzt warte ich nur noch darauf, dass sie noch Opus einbauen in die Fritz!Box, dann wird es langsam echt interessant. Und ein Audio-Eingang und Ausgang wäre noch cool. Also das fände ich zum Beispiel noch geil, weil die große Box hat irgendwie zwei USB, Ports. Warum sollte man nicht einfach noch ein USB-Audio-Interface ranmachen können und sagen, da hätte ich jetzt gerne ein Telefon drauf. Genau, oder so. Aber auf jeden Fall wäre es halt interessant, sozusagen mal ein USB-Telefon zu haben, was einfach nur Audio in-out macht. Da muss man halt noch überlegen, wie man das mit dem Telefonieren macht. Aber um so Standleitungen übers Netz, so Audio-Standleitungen mal hinzubekommen, wäre das auch mal eine sehr schöne Variante. Mal gucken, was sich da noch alles einfallen lässt. Ja, das war es so von mir, von der Fritz-Front. Ich finde das gut.
Gut finde ich das. Ja, wir haben ja eine Fritz-Box zu Hause, allerdings steht ein großer Schrank davor.
Die sind dann an den Schrank gefallen?
Nee, die hing da an der Wand und als der Schrank kam, war ich nicht zu Hause und meine Frau ist nicht auf die Idee gekommen, die Fritz-Box erst abzumachen, bevor sie den Schrank davor stellt. Und deswegen steht da jetzt der Schrank davor und man kommt nicht mehr ran an die Fritz-Box. Und zum Auszug weiß ich dann mehr.
Aber sie läuft noch.
Ich war sogar so mutig, da schon die Firma ja drauf zu updaten, was ein bisschen blöd ist, wenn man nicht ans Gerät kommt.
Ich hab ja in der Uni, hatte ich das schon mal erzählt, wo ich irgendwie so einen Rechner mal irgendwo hinter das Rack stellen wollte, um den da mal zu parken. Und dann guck ich so hinter das Rack und dann steht da schon ein Rechner und der hat schon so eine Zentimeter-dicke Staubschicht und lief aber noch, das war der Mac-Hackers, iMac Tim. Der stand da noch und ich hab aufs Base gerückt und der hat so Ratter, Ratter, Ratter, Ratter, Ratter gemacht und dann kam da ein Lock-in-Screen. Der stand da in 207 hinterm Rack, wo ich gerade auch noch einen Rechner mal kurz hinstellte, weil ich so, what? Ich hab den nicht ausgemalt und ich hab kein Passwort gefunden und dann hab ich ihn, glaube ich, erstmal stehen lassen. War so ein Tangerine Blue iMac, also so, weißt schon, so ein...
So ein Gnubbel iMac?
So ein Gnubbel iMac.
Was lief da drauf?
Also, ich bilde mir einen, der stand im Lock-in-Screen, irgendwas von Mac-Hackers oder sowas, aber...
Ich meine, welches OS?
Es war schon ein OS X, aber wahrscheinlich sehr antik. Da ich mich nicht einloggen konnte, konnte ich nicht nachschauen.
Ja, die alte Spam-Schleuder, die haben wir jetzt mal abgeschaltet.
Na, das war ja woanders, das lief ja schon. Das Wiki hab ich ja schon längst woanders hingezogen. Ja, Media-Wiken werden gerne aufgemacht in letzter Zeit.
Oh ja, gerne. Nicht so viel mit rumgespielt in letzter Zeit.
Nee, ist irgendwie.
Das geht ja auch seiner Dinge.
Ist ja so ein bisschen irgendwie.
Ich benutze das halt einfach und gut ist.
Das passiert immer noch nicht so, wann da nicht so viel Infos strommäßig.
Bitte?
Für mich persönlich. Ich folge aber noch nicht so vielen Leuten.
Ach so, naja gut. Solange man das eben nur als Twitter sieht.
Ja, was machst denn du da sonst mit?
Na, ich benutze es natürlich auch mit einer Twitter-artigen Timeline, aber ich schau mir vor allem eben die generelle Entwicklung an und mach mir so meine Gedanken, was denn das alles so machen könnte. Es gab neulich einen schönen Podcast auf, wie heißt dieser Podcast, lasst mich kurz schauen, dann weiß ich es auch genau. Und zwar ein britischer Podcast, was auch mal ganz angenehm ist, wenn mal ordentliches Englisch gesprochen wird. Command plus Space heißt er.
Command plus Space?
Ja, Command plus Space, im Sinne von wir suchen oder so. Und Mike Hurley macht den und der interviewt auch immer interessante Leute. Und die letzte Ausgabe 70decibels.com. Und der interviewt halt den Deuten Caldwell, also diesen Founder und CEO von Abdotnet und da unterhalten sie sich irgendwie. Da ist mir nochmal ein bisschen klarer geworden, wohin das eigentlich führen könnte und finde das einfach jedes Mal, wo ich drüber nachdenke, noch interessanter. Also sie sehen sich halt selber als, also nicht nur, aber auch, also das meinte er halt so, das wäre eben für sie eigentlich eine interessante Zukunft. Im Wesentlichen so ein Identity- und Payment-Provider zu sein. Weil diese Messaging-Architektur, also man darf sich nicht so richtig davon blenden lassen, dass die Anwendungen, die man jetzt vor allem zur Kenntnis nimmt, eine Twitter-like Experience vermitteln. Weil Abdotnet ist halt mehr als das.
Sie wollen auch genauso PayPal machen, mehr oder weniger. Zum Beispiel könnte man.
Ja, aber das Ding ist halt so ein langes...
Also alles mit Zahlen und ID, also alles eigentlich.
Ja, mal erstmal ganz unabhängig von dem Bezahlen. Sie sind halt eine Plattform, sie bieten irgendwie Accounts und sie haben so ein Unified Messaging und demnächst auch mit privaten Nachrichten. Derzeit hast du ja nur die Public Timeline und jetzt arbeiten sie gerade an den privaten Messages und er hat dann auch schon so ein bisschen durchblicken lassen, was du da halt machen kannst. Also im Gegensatz zu Twitter, wo du ja immer nur eine Direct Message im Sinne von, also du hast ja eine Direct Message an eine Person, die dann privat ist und die private, also ich weiß nicht genau, wie sie es nennen werden, aber ich sag jetzt einfach mal die private Messages, die es bei app.net gibt, die können halt an einen oder eben auch an mehrere Personen gehen. Das heißt, und dann eben genauso effizient wie eben durch Followership ausgewählt hast du dann eben quasi deine Benutzergruppe, sagen wir mal so eine ähnliche Funktionalität wie dieses Glassboard zum Beispiel realisiert, könntest du dann eben bauen als app.net-Client, indem du dann eine geschlossene Benutzergruppe zusammenkehrst, das irgendwie definiert, wie auch immer das dann in der API aussehen mag und dann kannst du eben auch solche privaten oder teilprivaten Kommunikationswege dir dort erschließen. Und es gibt ja jetzt schon, das haben wir ja letztes Mal schon erwähnt, so Sachen wie dieses Petter zum Beispiel, die halt so Chat-Kanäle machen, die derzeit eben auch public sind, die dann eben auch in dem Sinne genauso wiederum auch privat sein können. Also kannst du eine Chat-Experience machen, so eine Messaging-Experience, du kannst sein wie E-Mail, du kannst sein wie Twitter, du kannst sein wie irgendwas, was wir vielleicht noch gar nicht sehen. Dann gibt es jetzt auch noch so eine Anwendung, ich glaube, das ist das einzige, was wir jetzt mal nicht genannt haben, oder haben wir das genannt, wo man so synchronisiert über das Netz irgendwie sich gemeinsam YouTube-Videos anschauen kann, wo dann sozusagen die Software dafür sorgt, dass eben alle zum gleichen Zeitpunkt sich dasselbe Video anschauen. So eine Geschichte. Wäre vielleicht auch mal als Interaktionskanal für Podcasting auch ganz interessant, diese Idee. Das müsste jetzt nicht zwangsläufig nur über app.net laufen, aber das sind eben auch solche Anwendungen, die dort entstehen. Aber gerade im Hinblick auf Identity und Payment, dass sie da quasi einen definierten Kanal haben, sprachen eben unter anderem auch von Micro-Payment, ohne jetzt konkrete Pläne oder Visionen da zu kennzeichnen. Und da kann ich so ein bisschen ins Grübeln, weil das natürlich durchaus auch etwas ist, was in so einem Modell ganz gut funktionieren kann, weil da eben alles in Ordnung ist. Also die wissen, wer wer ist und haben sozusagen die ganzen Distributionskanäle und sind natürlich auch wiederum der Herrscher da übers Payment.
Ja, wobei ich ja momentan so noch denke, es war alles ganz gut und schön, was sie so announce und was so geplant ist und was die API eigentlich kann, aber solange es nichts gibt, was mich da irgendwie gerade berührt, ist mir das auch einigermaßen wurscht. Was ich sehe ist halt der Twitter-Like-Ebene, die ist jetzt so okay, jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig spannend. Also jetzt haben wir kein Problem mit. Es ist jetzt aber auch noch nicht so viel Informationsgewinn im Vergleich zu der Twitter-Experience und alles andere, was so halt die ganze Zeit so für Luftschlösser gebaut sind, also oder gebaut werden. Wenn sie dann da sind, dann können wir noch mal drüber reden, aber ich finde gerade das, also es klingt immer so ein bisschen zu Vapor-Verben-mäßig, solange es halt noch nicht da ist, weißte ich meine.
Ich weiß auch, was du meinst, aber es ist ja mehr und mehr, vor allem auch extrem viel, jetzt schon populäre Anwendungen bauen ja ab dort net ein.
Das ist richtig.
Also es gibt definitiv so einen Trend dahin, ab dort net extrem ernst zu nehmen.
Ich würde mir das auch sehr wünschen, wenn das ernst genommen werden würde, aber wie gesagt so momentan...
Ja, die haben es auch nicht eilig, also das wird sicherlich alles noch ein halbes Jahr oder vielleicht auch ein Jahr dauern, trotzdem, ich sehe keinen anderen Ort, wo ähnlich viel Aktivität gerade entwickelt wird und ich finde nach wie vor diese Idee einer Plattform ganz interessant. Wenn sie es halt schaffen, vielleicht eben auch noch... Also MicroPayment fand ich insofern sehr interessant, als dass sie ja dieses Developer Incentive-Programm haben, wo sie sagen, okay, die Einnahmen, die wir jetzt hier haben, der User, geben wir auch wieder mit an die Developer, was wiederum die Developer motiviert, mehr Anwendungen zu machen, die auch wirklich benutzt werden und nicht nur einmal verkauft werden. Die also so einen permanenten Benefit haben, ist einfach so, wie der Name schon so schön sagt, so ein Incentive halt. Und wenn man das eben dann auch noch auf die User so Flatter-mäßig verteilt und da eben auch das Payment quasi auch als Micro-Payment implementieren kann, dann wird's spannend.
Du meinst, die haben sich Flatter genauer angeguckt?
Das weiß ich nicht. Das weiß ich nicht. Aber ich meine, Micro-Payment steht für viele im Raum. Und ich meine, ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich mir so angucke, wie Apple gegen Flatter rumhackt, rumkackt. Also ich meine, die waren ja wirklich grundsätzlich so, das was so von dieser WWDC an Reaktionen da zu spüren war, war wir wissen ganz genau, was das ist und wir wollen das da nicht haben. Und wenn Apple da was nicht haben will, muss es nicht, aber kann es auch bedeuten, dass das einfach ein Feld ist, das sie gedenken selber zu bewirtschaften. Und mal ehrlich, Apple mit, was weiß ich, wie viele User-Accounts mit Kreditkarten haben die da? Die haben doch da mal irgendwelche dreistelligen Millionenzahlen. Was kommt als nächstes? Was wäre, wenn Apple eine Bank kauft? Was wäre, wenn Apple selber eine Bank gründet?
Na, die haben noch eine Bank. Die heißt, wie ist das letztens? Hatten wir doch. Scheiße, auch ein Apfelname auf jeden Fall. Deren Bank heißt auch wie eine Apfelsorte.
Ach, und die gehört Apple?
Die verwaltet das Geld von Apple, diese 100 Milliarden Dollar. Gab's letztens noch einen Artikel.
Pink Lady.
Golden Delicious wahrscheinlich.
Golden Delicious würde echt passen. Lecker Geld.
Apfelsorten gibt's wie Sand am Meer.
Überrascht mich jetzt auch nicht so. Ich meine, auch VW hat Banken und so. Wobei das sind alles so Banken, die eher eben zur Finanzierung von ihren Geräten sind. Bei Apple kann man ja auch auf Raten kaufen, oder? Sowas wird dann auch nicht selten mit eigenen Banken realisiert.
Ich glaube, wenn du einen gewissen Umsatz hast und auf einem gewissen Level mit Kreditkartenfirmen reden willst, dann musst du auch Bank sein.
Ja, aber ich wollte das eher in die andere Richtung denken. Was ist, wenn sozusagen Apple als nächstes denkt, also überall, wo wir Geld sparen können, versuchen wir mal, was Sache ist. Zulieferer, billiger, CPUs kann man auch selber bauen. Also Apple ist schon seit Längerem auf diesem Pfad, dass sie sich eigentlich alles einheimsen und überlegen, ob sie nicht diesen ganzen Business-Zweig einfach mal in ihrem Style komplett neu aufbauen, auf allen möglichen Ebenen. Läden, ja, und sie haben es dann auch wirklich an vielen Stellen geschafft, alles neu zu definieren. Warum sollten sie, wenn sie so viele Leute haben in ihrer Datenbank, nicht einfach auch die Funktionalität eines Payment-Providers sein?
Machen ja andere auch.
Ja, also wenn Kreditkartengeld annehmen, weiterleiten und dann an Apple schicken können, können sie den Spieß auch genauso gut umdrehen und sagen, ja, wir haben jetzt hier für jeden, der einen iTunes-Account hat, auch einen Account. Also ich meine, da kannst du ja eh schon Geld draufladen.
Ein Apple-Pal-Konto.
In gewisser Hälfte sind sie ja sozusagen schon eine Bank, weil du hast ein Konto, da kann Geld drauf sein. Wenn du da ein Gutscheincode drauf lädst, dann tust du ja eigentlich auch nichts anderes. Wenn sie also sozusagen sagen, dein iTunes-Account ist jetzt dein Bank-Account und du kannst damit auch deine Miete überweisen und dein, gerade in den USA, wo dieser ganze Banking-Transfer, ich meine, die stellen sich da noch Checks aus und so.
Ja, bei denen ist ja eine Kreditkarte auch wirklich eine Kreditkarte.
In Frankreich übrigens auch.
Also du kaufst ja immer Kredit auf deiner Kreditkarte und dann gibst du so lange aus, bis du den leer hast und dann kaufst du dir eine nächste, die sozusagen deine alte Kreditkarte abbezahlt und hast dadurch wieder den neuen Kredit und so rutscht die da von einer Kreditkarte zur nächsten. Bei uns ist ja Kreditkarte mehr wie zum Geldabheben da. Die haben Kreditkarte wirklich für den Kredit.
Ja, hier sind manche Kreditkarten auch so, dass sie erst nach einem Monat ausgleichen, aber bei manchen Banken ist es, dass die eigentlich genauso funktionieren wie die EC-Karte auch.
Diese Bank von Apple heißt Braeburn Capital und ist der größte Hedge Fund der Welt. Verwaltet 117 Milliarden Dollar. Ich glaube, das ist nicht der größte, aber hier steht der größte, was ich letztens gelesen habe, dass es einer der größten ist. Aber hier steht jetzt, dass es zum größten gerade aufgestiegen ist.
Ah, die haben sie 2006 gegründet. Na gucke mal, man weiß ja nie alles. Value 2005, 8 Billionen US-Dollar, mittlerweile 97.
Hier steht was von 117. 6. Oktober 2012.
Ja, okay, das ist jetzt die 2011-Zahl.
Als Bild ist ja auch gleich eine Heuschrecke, die sich durch einen Apfel frisst.
Kannst du das mal in Asset Management Company?
Da war letztens hier so ein richtig fetter Artikel, aber ich weiß leider nicht mehr, wo der war. Na ja, keine Steuern und so.
Okay, aber das ist ein Investment, das ist keine Bank.
Nee, nee, aber der... Was machen denn Banken? Also in Amerika oder überhaupt auch bei uns gibt es eine Menge Banken, die haben ja gar keine, wie sagt man, User-Content mehr für normale Leute, sondern die sind halt nur noch am Geld hin und her schieben und so. Eigentlich müsste man dafür mal ein neues Wort erfinden.
Created to better manage its assets and to avoid certain California state taxes. Und allein daraus machen sie irgendwie 45 Billionen im 2012. Ja, also das ist halt das Ding. Ich meine, die können sich irgendwie auch diese ganzen...
Royal Domination sag ich mal.
Allein von der Valualisierung. Also hier sowas wie Santander oder Mastercard oder so, das kaufen die doch zum Frühstück. Das schmieren sie sich mit auf eine Stulle.
Weiß nicht, ob man die überhaupt haben will.
Naja, deswegen wahrscheinlich nicht. Also sagen, euch müssen wir gar nicht kaufen. Wir fahren viel besser, wenn...
Wir fahren euch gegen die Wand und ihr seid weg.
Ja, ich meine, wenn das so weitergeht, dann wird Apple noch mal irgendwie so The Company Ink.
Ja, es gibt so ganz viele so eine Science-Fiction-Romane, die halt beschreiben, dass in der Zukunft halt irgendwie so starten, haben eigentlich nichts mehr zu sagen so. Sondern es gibt nur noch so ein paar so Megacorps und die regieren die Welt. Und ich meine, so sieht es auch schon aus, oder?
Ja, wie bei Blade Runner.
Ja, genau.
Wie hieß der Laden noch gleich?
Aber bei Alien hieß er Intex, oder? Nee, doch.
Und bei Resident Evil?
Umbrella Corporation. Und bei Terminators war es nicht Skynet oder so? Skynet war die Technik und die Firma hieß auch noch ein bisschen anders. Oder hieß es da Intex? Aber es war ja auch schon so eine riesen Corporation, die halt irgendwie zwei verschiedene Businesses nicht so gemixt hat, wie es sein sollte. Wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, einmal gucken.
Ja, und wir, wir kleinen Fanboys, wir sind schuld. Wir stacheln hier die Masse auf, die Leute zum Kaufen. Einzutreten in die Sekte, in diesen Schreiladen nach, wo sie da mit ihren komischen Plastikgebimmel an ihren hässlichen blauen T-Shirts irgendwie da diese Schreiorgien bei diesen furchtbaren Stores, die sie irgendwie den ganzen Tag über wachen, machen.
Da muss man wieder ein bisschen...
Du bist ja nur neidisch, dass du nicht so abgehen kannst.
Ich hab kein Problem mit abgehen.
Da muss mal wieder ein bisschen mehr Stil rein in die Firma.
Wenn sie dann noch mal den Spin kriegen, am Ende den Kapitalismus abzuschaffen, dann bin ich ja glücklich. Irgendwann ohnen sie irgendwie alles und dann können sie sagen, wir ändern jetzt mal das Wirtschaftssystem.
Das könnte man also theoretisch...
Dann kommen sie mit so riesigen Raumschiffen und fräsen so am Nordpol irgendwie alles.
So Stückchen raus.
Ja, also erst ändern sie das Klima, dass dann wieder mehr Eis ist am Nordpol und dann fräsen sie so ein Stückchen raus und stecken so eine dicke Antenne rein, bis die ganze Erde aussieht wie ein Apfel. Die Frage ist, wo kommt der Biss?
Angenommen, die haben so Ende nächsten Jahres 200 Milliarden Dollar. Können die nicht dann irgendwie so ein Land kaufen? Rumänien oder so? Also was heißt, was wollen sie damit? So schlecht ist es jetzt hier in Europa nicht. Ich meine, bei uns kommen keine Sandys, die hier mal kurz drüber braten und alles ist weg und so weiter. Also wir sind relativ krisenfest. Aha, genau.
So ein paar Erdbeben, genau.
Die kommen alle 50 Jahre und danach...
San Andreas-Fault, ein paar Erdbeben.
Also schlechter gibt es auch erstmal gar nicht.
Was sollen sie denn kaufen? Eigentlich würdest du ein Land kaufen, wenn du Apple wärst. Also wenn du die Kohle von Apple hättest. Ja, du bist jetzt hier irgendwie...
Ich würde ganz Europa kaufen.
Was willst du mit ganz Europa?
Das ist doch cool hier.
Griechenland, Spanien, das ist schon mal kein schlechter Anfang.
Italien. Die Alpen sind eigentlich auch ganz viel geschiefen, wenn man sie auch so ein bisschen... Wahrscheinlich könnte man hier alles kaufen, die Schweiz lässt man einfach da in der Mitte und macht eine dicke Mauer drumrum.
Ich weiß nicht, ich würde eher so ein Neufundland kaufen und dann irgendwie alle Nazis da drauf.
Damit die jetzt, ja klar, denen noch Urlaub zahlen, bist du bescheuert. Die kommen nach Sibirien.
Ja, oder gleich in die Antarktis, im Neuschwabenland.
Aber wo du UFO sagst, jetzt muss ich ihr neues Office schon so wie ein UFO bauen. Das hebt dann ab da.
Das hebt dann ab.
Sammelt alle ein.
Was ich ja nicht verstehe, ist, warum Pixar jetzt ihr Haupt-Building, das Steve Jobs-Building nennt und wie wird das UFO heißen? Steve Jobs-UFO oder was? Verstehe ich nicht so richtig. Also ich hätte dieses Gebäude, Steve Jobs-Building genannt und nicht das von Pixar, aber sowieso schon.
Vielleicht heißt es dann wieder Infinity Loop oder so.
Lass uns lieber über Apps reden.
Ja, also hier von dem, weil wir gerade bei Twitter waren, der Typ, der Tweety an Twitter verkauft hat, ist ja bei Twitter auch wieder ausgestiegen schon länger und hat ja eine neue App rausgebracht, die heißt Letterpress. Ging ja auch eine Weile ganz gut rum. Ich hab's auch mal gespielt, obwohl es jetzt nicht so mein Game ist. Die App ist umsonst. Man kann die also erstmal loszocken und man kann, wenn man die nur umsonst geladen hat, zwei Spiele gleichzeitig spielen. Man muss halt aus 5x5 Matrix mit Buchstaben drin, muss man Wörter zusammensetzen, kriegt man Punkte für. Der Gegner macht das auch. Da kriegt man Punkte wieder abgezogen, wenn einem die Buchstaben wieder geklaut werden und wenn alle Buchstaben einmal benutzt wurden, ist vorbei, oder wenn beiden Seiten nichts mehr einfällt. Also es ist relativ simpel. Was es halt irgendwie nicht gibt, ist irgendwie so Highscores oder überhaupt sonst so ein Scoring-System, sondern entweder du verlierst gegen deinen Gegner aus Game Center oder nicht, aber mehr gibt's da nicht. Find ich ein bisschen lame. Man kann sich irgendwie nicht so richtig messen. Man kann aber irgendwie upgraden für irgendwie 90 Cent. Die Preise sind ja gestiegen, haben wir auch noch nicht drüber geredet. Und dann kann man mehrere Spiele gleichzeitig laufen lassen, weil man muss ja erst turn-based, man muss ja mal warten, bis der gegnerische Spieler irgendwie seinen Zug gemacht hat. Und das ist schick gemacht, aber es ist irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wenn ich mich nicht messen kann und das ist so alles verschwindet und ist so vergänglich, dann hab ich nicht so richtig Spaß dran. Ich will schon irgendwie sehen, wie gut ich war oder schlecht oder wie mein Progress ist. Ich finde das ist irgendwie wichtig. Ansonsten, wie gesagt, ist es eigentlich schick gemacht. Also für Leute, die so auch Scrabble oder irgendwie so eine Spiele spielen und so, ist das irgendwie ganz nett.
Also was muss man da machen, wenn man sucht?
Du kriegst halt eine Matrix aus fünf mal fünf Buchstaben. Und du musst halt da ein Wort zusammensetzen und du kriegst für jeden Buchstaben, den dein Wort hat, kriegst... Also der Buchstabe färbt sich dann in deiner Farbe ein und du kriegst irgendwie einen Punkt. Und der Gegner macht dann das Gleiche und eventuell nimmt er dir deine Buchstaben auch wieder weg. Dann kriegst du den Punkt halt sozusagen auch wieder abgezogen. Also die Punktezahl ist immer wie viel...
Das ist ja dein Buchstabennetz oder was?
Nee, du musst halt aus den Buchstaben Wörter zusammensetzen.
Das ist so wie bei... Was für Wörter kennt der?
Das sind einfach Buchstaben. Du musst die kennen. Du musst die rausfinden.
Dann krieg ich da irgendwas eintippen.
Wenn die Buchstaben da sind, schon.
Dann krieg ich da alle eintippen, dann mach ich...
Nee, die Wörter muss ja existieren. Wo? Na, in diesem Spiel. Das Spiel sagt dann, das Wort gibt's nicht.
Also er hat ein Wörterbuch und sagt, das gibt's nicht.
Ist auch ein bisschen blöd, finde ich, beim Englischen, weil die Engländer haben irgendwie nicht so coole zusammengesetzte Wörter, so wie wir Deutschen. Wir können so deutsche, geile Spaghettiwörter machen.
Das Beste ist sozusagen, wenn ich die Buchstaben von dem anderen wegnehme.
Genau, und der von dir. Und dann gibt's noch eine Sache, wenn du deine eigenen Buchstaben, also wenn du sozusagen so vier Stück hast und das eine ist davon so ganz in der Ecke und da ist kein anderer mehr so drumrum, dann ist der gesperrt für den anderen, dann kann er den zwar benutzen, aber er kriegt keinen Punkt mehr dafür. Also du kannst sozusagen so eine Art sichere Bastion an Buchstaben dir so machen, aber bei 5x5 ist mir noch, also ich habe nur ein paar Mal gespielt, ist mir jetzt nicht wirklich passiert. Und ja, das war's.
In welcher Sprache?
Ja, erstmal schon.
Es müsste eigentlich auch mal, dass man einfach andere Dictionaries reinlädt oder so. Oder dass man auch sagt, ok, du kennst jetzt dieses Wort nicht, aber ich will es eigentlich trotzdem nehmen und der Gegner muss dann zu sagen. Wenn er dann cool genug ist, dann sagt er... Wenn alle Buchstaben benutzt wurden, von egal welcher Seite. Oder wenn beide Seiten kein Wort mehr einfällt.
Man kann das Dictionary hacken und eigene Wörter reinschreiben. Ich hab auch noch ein Spiel. Das ist aber keine App. Das ist schon eine App. Das ist eine Application. Das ist ein richtiges Spiel.
Also für den Desktop jetzt?
Eher so für den Desktop, aber auf allen möglichen Plattformen. Nee, gibt's auch sogar auf Konsole. Ich glaube, das war auch mal an diesem Humble-Bundle, an diesem Indie-Game-Bundle. Und das ist eins, der also Machinarium oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht, das fand ich ja schon ein extrem schönes Spiel. Einfach ästhetisch wirklich sehr ansprechend und auch wirklich super toll gemacht. Und ein neues Spiel, was auch richtig cool gemacht ist, ist Pit. Jetzt auch die URL im Chat, pitgame.com. PID. Da sollte man sich mal das Video angucken, also es gibt Videos, die Images, die sagen irgendwie noch nicht so richtig viel aus. Also es ist richtig schön atmosphärisch. Es ist halt so ein, wie sagt man, Jump, nicht Jump'n'Run, also so richtig, also, ja, oder Plattformspiel oder wie auch immer. Man läuft halt so schon durch irgendwelche Welten durch und hat auch so ein bisschen hier und da mal ein paar Extra-Powers und es ist einfach extrem wunderschön gemacht. Und es ist auch echt mit ein paar cool, coolen Spielmechaniken ausgestattet. Und das kostet 10 Dollar, wenn man es da direkt von denen auf der Webseite kauft. Und die Demo, also man kann sich auch eine Demo runterladen, ich glaube die erste Stage oder so komplett mal durchspielen. Das ist ein schönes Spiel. Schönes Indie-Spiel. Eine Augenfreude sozusagen und auch also wie gesagt, die Spielmechaniken, die machen schon auch Spaß. Kann man sich mal reinfahren. Naja, ist halt so, wie man halt so durch diese Levels kommt und wie man so Gegner ausschaltet, das ist nicht so mit so direkt irgendwie Gegner abschießen oder so, man hat halt so manchmal so ein paar Extras, mit dem man sich so durch Levels bewegen kann und ganz kreativ irgendwelche Hindernisse überwinden kann oder Gegner halt irgendwie in eine Falle locken kann, damit sie dann doch irgendwie verschwinden und so. Also, ist sehr kreativ gelöst.
Auch wieder mit Schlüssel holen und da öffnen und dann wieder zurück und da und kreuz und quer und all so was.
Ja, so viel hin und her war bisher nicht. Also ich habe jetzt noch nicht so viel gespielt, aber es ist auch bei jedem Screen oder bei jeder Zwischenstage, die du erreichst, wird auch immer gespeichert. Selbst wenn du dann halt scheiterst, musst du nicht irgendwie ganz von vorne wieder anfangen, sondern wirklich nur in dem einen Raum jetzt nochmal von vorne.
Also es ist nicht so frustrierend, wie es auch mal manchmal bei so einem Spiel ist, wo du dann irgendwie drei Ebenen weiter wieder zurück erst anfangen musst und wieder von vorne. Ja, checkt das mal aus. Sieht also wirklich schon alleine so die...
Trosslante Optik so.
Genau, und schon alleine so die Intro-Screens, wenn das Spiel so lädt. Das sieht so hübsch aus. Also da hat wirklich einer mal genau den Ton getroffen. Und wie gesagt, in der Demo kann man das schon sehr gut oder in den Videos schon sehr gut sehen. Und ich glaube, das gibt es irgendwie für alle möglichen Plattformen auch. Ich hab das vorhin gesehen, Xbox gibt es das, Steam gibt es das, also es gibt es für Windows, Mac, Xbox. Echt?
Und dann ist es immer noch ein Indie-Game?
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Ja, gerade wenn es Steam ist, also...
Ja, aber Xbox und so eine Plattform...
Oder Xbox Live, also ich weiß ja nicht, wie das mit der Xbox da funktioniert in diesem Xbox Live und so, aber...
Ist das auch alles von diesem Game, was ich hier sehe?
Das Video, das hab ich da angemacht. Die Hörer sehen jetzt nichts, aber die können sich ja trotzdem das Video angucken.
Mir fällt auch gerade noch ein, was ich letztens gesehen hab, und zwar... Der Originalmacher wohl, der auf dem C64 Karateka gemacht hat. Der hatte ich jetzt noch mal rangesetzt und hat jetzt noch mal Karateka gemacht in modern. Und da gibt's auch ein cooles...
Alter, du hast ja gar keine Ahnung.
Heißt es eigentlich Karateka oder ist es nicht Karateka? Karateka ist sozusagen jemand, der Karate macht, ne?
Kann sein. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hab damals nur gespielt, hab nicht weiter nachgedacht. Wie gefällt es als Kind, ne?
Ja, da gibt's so ein total super cheesy Video jetzt.
Genau.
Stimmt, das war dieses... Oh Gott, ja, ich erinnere mich. Oh mein Gott.
Stimmt, der sagt auch immer so Karateka, ne?
Ich glaube, ich weiß es noch.
Ich find jetzt dieses scheiß Video nicht. Der Chat muss aushelfen. Ah ja, das war... Und war ganz, ganz witzig. Also ich hab das sonst noch, das Spiel an sich nicht gesehen. Ich glaub, es wär auch nicht mehr meins. Aber damals fand ich dieses Karateka eigentlich irgendwie ganz cool. Waren ganz coole Moves und cooler Sound und so.
Das war überhaupt so das eins der ganz allerersten Prügelspiele, ne? Damit fing das irgendwie an.
Ohne das würd's hier so einen Techenscheiß gar nicht geben.
Da wurde nur noch geprügelt.
Ja, immer drauf auf die Pixel.
Karateka!
Damals waren wir von Retina noch so weit entfernt.
Auf jeden.
C64 sagst du ja? Die sahen früher aus.
Also richtig scheiße. Aber damals eigentlich war er ganz cool.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
War einfach zwei Figuren, kannst du so steuern. Und so hat er seinen Sidekick und sonstige Kick gemacht. Da war Chuck Norris gar nichts gegen.
Na gut, aber wie das Spiel wird, das werden wir erst noch sehen.
Aber dieses Video, dieses Werbevideo, sollte man sich mal angucken. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt schon wer gefunden hat. Nee, noch nicht. Warum gibt es das hier nirgends? Scheiße.
Das ist immer so mit so Wörtern, die im realen Leben auch eine Bedeutung haben.
Wer soll zu C64 Zeiten schon eine Ahnung haben, dass man irgendwann später mal googelbar sein muss?
Hier, Karateka Official Trailer.
Ja, hier, genau, 2012. Extended Director's Cut, hier, ich hab was. Ich poste den mal.
Du kannst, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp. Wollen wir es mal ganz modern machen?
Ja, ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen lang, aber du kannst ja den Anfang kurz machen.
Du kannst jetzt, wenn du deinen Audio-Output auf Mischpult legst, du musst aber dazu im internen Netz sein, mein Freund.
Ich bin WLAN.
Ja, aber in welchem WLAN? Im Public. Public ist draußen.
Aber das sieht ja total billig aus.
Das ist das Alte oder das Neue?
Die Figuren da. Das ist ja nichts gegen Tecken.
Hier, da. Die Zuhörer müssen jetzt eine Weile das aushalten.
Jetzt probieren wir das einfach mal aus. Ich wollte das mal...
Du wolltest es eh immer mal auswählen.
Jetzt habe ich mal ein paar neue Features.
Das heißt, ich nutze jetzt hier Mountain Lion Feature Airplay Midspult, weil Tim hat hier einen Midspult am Start. Dann muss ich meinen Safari neu starten. Ich hoffe nicht. Ich mache mal lauter und leiser Ton. Kommt da schon was bei dir? Bei mir nämlich nicht. Man müsste jetzt bei dir irgendwie Sound kommen über das Midspult.
Ja, ich sehe es schon.
Nur noch durch die drei Subgruppen durchruten und dann...
Doch, irgendwo höre ich was.
Ganz leise höre ich.
Du bist noch zu leise.
Ich bin bei maximaler Lautstärke.
Du bist bei maximaler Lautstärke.
Steckt der Stecker richtig?
Ja, zwischen Max und ein bisschen weniger schalte ich hier hin und her.
Der Stecker, naja, der Stecker kann jetzt nicht groß falsch sein.
Und es ist alles nur ein paar Sekunden verzögert, was ja bei so einem Video oder bei Sound ja sowieso nur egal ist. Dann kannst du bei dir nicht mehr höher drehen? Oder warte mal, habe ich hier eventuell...
Ich bin nicht so mega leise, dass ich...
Ich bin hier wirklich auf voller Pulle, hier geht es nicht mehr.
Aber hier kommt... Es müsste eigentlich mehr zu hören sein. Ich habe hier noch ein anderes... Es ist halt alles nicht so einfach. Deswegen wollte ich das jetzt auch gerade mal ausprobieren. Bin ich ein weiteres Mal verwundert. Das hat man ja auch selten, ne?
Dass du verwundert bist, hm?
Ja, warte mal, ich glaube der Hauptkund ist, dass ich gerade hier...
Falschen Regler drehe.
Ich kriege hier tatsächlich das Signal rein.
Das ist doch auf Bus 5, 6, verdammt.
Wollen wir noch bei 7 und 8?
Warte mal, ich mach mal einen Hack.
Der ist aber eigentlich nicht erlaubt. Aha, wieso hören wir das dann und dann da nicht?
Da war gerade schon einer im Chat. Mittlerweile haben alle im Chat das Video schon fertig geguckt.
Ja, ich glaub auch.
Selbst die Hörer, die später nicht live zugeladen haben, haben es jetzt schon gehört. Und, wie machen wir es nun oder machen wir es nicht?
Ja, können sich die Hörer noch sehr weiter.
Irgendwie hören wir es, ne?
So ein bisschen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum es leise ist. Vielleicht der gleiche Effekt, den ich vorher mit Dings hatte. Ja, hier muss noch einiges debackt werden.
Jetzt nicht das Mischpult neu starten.
Und starten sie gleich schon alleine neu.
das ist strange.
Aber ich sehe hier den Pegel.
Ich weiß nicht, ist doch im richtigen...
Christoph, du hörst das wahrscheinlich gerade. Wir müssen da nochmal die packen. Das ist wirklich zum Mäusemelken, verdammte Fickscheiße.
Tja, knapp daneben ist auch vorbei.
Ja, ich hab heute bei so einem unserer Spiele...
Mach jetzt noch mal kurz.
Noch mal, einmal.
Schon ein bisschen mehr.
Ja, aber das nehme ich jetzt gerade nicht auf. Das ist das Dramatische. Deswegen darf ich das eigentlich gar nicht abspielen.
Na, da hab ich heute in einem unserer tollen Facebook-Spiele, was jetzt demnächst rauskommt, einen Satz gefunden. Da ist so ein Character, der immer so ein bisschen grumpy ist und der meinte, there's a fine line between fishing and just standing on the shore like an idiot. Weil du meintest gerade, knapp daneben ist auch vorbei.
Eben, das ist logisch. Jetzt halten sich ja schon alle die Bäuche. Aber es ist ja wahrscheinlich nur irgendein kleines... Aber solche digitalen Mischpulte sind aber auch echt Biester.
Lieber meditieren als rumsitzen und nichts tun.
Ja, wir könnten ja...
Ja, so ein paar Abtipps.
Na, was denn so?
Was soll ich euch sagen, Leute? Meinen...
Sag uns was.
Sag was, solange du noch kannst. So wie du dann den Milchpulver umruhst, ist ja alles gleich vorbei.
Ich bin mutig.
Nein, Tollkühen nennt man das.
Nee, ich weiß genau, was ich tue. Es gibt einen Outliner, der auf dem Mac und auf dem iPhone und auf dem iPad läuft.
Nein, ihr müsstet jetzt Tim sehen, er hat jetzt die Hände ungefähr so, wie man es von einem guten Jesus-Standbild sieht. Er segnet uns gerade so, mit leicht angewickeltem, zur metergebenen Weit.
Gute Lupe, sag ich nur. Das Ding heißt Cloud-Outliner, kostet irgendwie 5 Taken pro Plattform.
Nicht Cloudliner?
Nee, auch nicht Atlas. Cloud-Outliner ist definitiv noch so eine 1.0. Also da geht noch was. Aber liefert, also ganz einfaches Interface, ein Fenster, links in vertikaler Anordnung untereinander, einfach die Outlines mit Titel und rechts die Outline mit Dreiecken und bedient sich im Wesentlichen so, wie man einen Outliner eben bedienen möchte. Also mit einklappen, ausklappen und du kannst ganze Strukturen hin und her drängen und so. Warum heißt das eigentlich Outliner?
Weil das ist doch eher so eine Baumstruktur, oder?
Na ja, das ist ja eine Outline.
Ach echt?
Ja, deswegen heißt das.
Die Baumstruktur ist eine Outline?
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass jede Baumstruktur zwangsläufig eine Outline ist, aber jede Outline ist eine Baumstruktur. Also eine Outline ist quasi eine hierarchische Liste von Dingen.
Mir ist noch nicht klar, warum die Outline heißt.
Weil du damit halt... You outline what you're talking about. Also wenn du sozusagen versuchst, eine Struktur zu beschreiben, dann machst du das, indem du eine Outline erzeugst. Im Englischen heißt halt... Ich könnte jetzt meinen...
Eine Gliederung quasi.
Ja, ein Outlining mein... Sehr schön. Gliederung trifft es sehr gut. Gliederung ist ein guter Bezirk.
Outlining ist ein Umriss oder ein Schattenriss?
Ja, also im Sinne von... Also Outlining, der Wortsinn ist... Der Ursprünge ist sozusagen... Ich zeichne dir meinen Plan. Ich skizziere dir, was ich meine. Und um das zu tun, definiert man eine hierarchische Struktur. Das heißt, das ist das Große und Ganze.
Wikipedia sagt, die Gliederung eines umfangreichen Textes in einem Computerprogramm, Gliederungs-Editor oder halt eben Outliner. Ja, war mir irgendwie nie so klar. Ich habe konnte damit den Wort...
Schreib mal lieber in der englischen Wikipedia nach.
In Englisch steht ja wieder Outliner da. Nützt mir erstmal nicht. Ich wollte grundsätzlich mal wissen, was das Wort so heißt.
Die Texte werden vielleicht in einen Nod verbreitet oder ausgebildet. Das ist auch das, was ein Outliner ausmacht. Dass du eben nicht nur eine Hierarchie hinmalen kannst, sondern dass du eben diese Collapse-Expand-Sachen hast. Also kannst du halt alles ausklappen, einklappen. Typisch sind für Outliner auch noch so Funktionen wie heust, anhäust. Was ist das? Naja, du kannst jetzt in irgendeinen beliebigen Unterpunkt gehen mit dem Cursor. Du bist so zwei, drei Ebenen drunter und hast da sozusagen deinen Subtree. Und wenn du dann heustest, dann heißt es, dass du den aktuellen Note quasi wie Root darstellen lässt. Das heißt, du siehst die darüber liegende Struktur und darunter liegenden Notes nicht mehr, sondern nur noch diesen Subtree. Und bearbeitest nur diesen Subtree. Also der Outliner erlaubt dir quasi, deinen Fokus nur auf diesen Subtree zu machen, dass du den Rest einfach gar nicht siehst. Und wenn du dann wieder anheust, machst, dann siehst du wieder alles.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Links erlaubt? Ja, das ist ja wie im Pfeilsystem, das ist ja auch eine Baumstruktur. Da gibt es ja Links so, ja, Soft Links.
Das mag Outliner geben, die sowas tun, aber das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, nicht Teil der Definition von Outliner. Outliner sagt einfach nur, du hast eine hierarchische Struktur und die ist relativ einfach. Und jetzt gab es ja schon immer Omni-Outliner, was bis zur Version 3 wirklich ein ganz hervorragender Outliner war, und dann haben sie in Version 4 den Blodbären und sich nach Hause geholt. Genau, sich den Blodbären aufgebunden.
Eingefangen und gezündet, könnte man schon sagen.
Also wirklich schlimm. Was ich in der allermeisten Nacht trage, ist, dass sie einfach den unformatted Text abgeschafft haben. Das heißt, Text ist jetzt immer styled. Und du kannst nicht forcieren, dass er unstyled ist. Mit diesen klassischen Problematiken, wenn du irgendwie Copy in der Webseite pastest, dann ist er irgendwie so kursiv, 6-Punkt, irgendwie...
Das heißt, du müsstest in den ersten Textedit reinschreiben, Make Plane Text machen und dann weiterpasten, ja?
Du kennst aber nicht die Tastenkombination.
Doch, ich kenne die scheiß Tastenkombination.
Shift, Alt, Command, V. Einsetzen und Stil anpassen.
Du weißt aber auch, wie geil das funktioniert auf Mac. Dann hast du so... Du hast dann immer noch irgendwelche formatierten Spaces, die dann übrig bleiben bei deinen Hin und Her Aktionen und da pastest du da was rein und dann übernehmen die von diesem unsichtbaren Text dann wieder die Formatierung als Default und das ist einfach nur Ärger. Ich will einfach sagen, plain Text. Ich will nie, ever, niemals in meinen Notizen Rich Texts haben, nie. Und die bauen es einfach ein, dass es immer da ist, zum Kotzen.
Und kein Syncing.
Ja, und gut, ich meine, sie haben da viele Sachen drin, die ich manchmal benutze, aber die ich eigentlich nicht so dringend brauche, wie Spalten und so was. Und sie sind total beseelt bei Omni-Outliner, dass du das alles irgendwie formatieren kannst, und dann sieht es schick aus und pipapo. Und eigentlich ist es Quatsch. Und Outliner ist lustig, weil ganz viele Leute benutzen das am laufenden Meter. Wenn du Keynote benutzt, hast du links einen Outliner. Das ist die Outline deines Vortrags, wie die einzelnen Slides zueinander geschachtelt sind. Du kannst ja sozusagen Unterteile deines Vortrags auch dann wieder ausklappen, etc. Und tatsächlich war auch eins der allerersten Outliner-Programme, da wo nämlich dieser Begriff überhaupt herkommt, war nämlich die Software More auf dem Mac. Und ich gucke gerade mal, ob die in der englischen Wikipedia ist hier natürlich auch drin. More großgeschrieben. Und die ist von Dave Weiner.
Nein.
Und wer ist Dave Weiner?
Wer war das nochmal?
Alle Leute wissen, wer das Web erfunden hat, aber keiner weiß, wer Dave Weiner ist.
Wer Goffa erfunden hat.
Also Dave Weiner ist im Prinzip der Typ, der irgendwie Blogging, RSS, Syndication, all das erfunden hat, der irgendwie den ersten Outliner gemacht hat, der Userland, Frontier, scripting.com, all diese ganzen Sachen, der einfach extrem influential ist und der auch so ein Freigeist ist, weil der ist einfach ein sehr strittiger Typ. Ist einfach auch ein cooler Typ. Ich kann euch auch durchaus empfehlen, den mal auf Twitter zu folgen. Er hat immer irgendwie spaßige Anmerkungen und ist einfach ein kritischer Geist. Manche meinen auch, er sei schwierig. So und er hat im Prinzip dieses Modell, dieses Konzept des Outliners gemacht. Und ich hab halt, Moor ist von 1986. Und ich hab damals meine ersten Präsentationen auf dem Mac mit Moor gemacht und es ist wieder so ein bisschen wie mit Framemaker. Irgendwann war dann diese Software weg. Und du hast das Gefühl, 20 Jahre lang passiert einfach nichts auf diesem Planeten. Ja, mit Framemaker. Weißt du, du hast das Licht gesehen, und auf einmal kommt einer rein und sagt, Licht aus. Klack. Und dann tappst du die ganze Zeit im Dunkeln und suchst den Lichtschalter und findest ihn nicht. Und dann kommen die Leute rein mit Kerzen. Hier, ist doch auch hell. Ist nicht ganz das, was ich schon mal hatte. Weißt du, dann drückst du auf den Schalter und so und dann war es da. Und dann kommen sie irgendwie und halten irgendwelche Blätter vor die Fackel. Hier ist doch auch fast das gleiche.
Nee, wollte Licht nicht feuern.
Und dann kommen welche mit RGB-LED-Glübe, die du mit deinem iPhone per WLAN steuern kannst und das beschissenste Licht machen, was die Menschheit je gesehen hat. Aber du kannst es ja von deinem iPhone steuern.
Wie man das so schön schnell lässt und du nichts falsch machen kannst. Ja, More war geil. Ich meine, ich hab dieses Software jetzt auch schon seit ewigen Zeiten nicht mehr in der Hand gehabt, aber das ist doch auch eine dieser Programme, wo du wahrscheinlich relativ schnell fündig werden dürftest, wenn du auf dem Netz nach Disc-Images suchst. Die gammelt bestimmt noch irgendwo rum. Ja, und es ist dann halt irgendwann, wie das so ist, wurde dann irgendwann für einen Symantec gekauft und dann war es dann halt irgendwann weg. Ach so, Winer hat sogar die Software for free download. Ah, alles klar. Ja, und er hat im Prinzip diesen Begriff von Outlinern definiert. Er hat auch dann dieses OPML-Format spezifiziert, also in XML, wie man quasi den Inhalt eines Outliners in eine einfache XML-Datei macht. Und OPML ist ja heutzutage auch immer noch so das Austauschformat, wenn du zum Beispiel einen Podcast-Client nimmst und der hat so eine Exportfunktion, wo du deine Subscriptions mit exportierst, dann ist das in 99% der Fälle OPML. Weil auch das eben wiederum eine Outline ist, bzw. als solche dargestellt werden kann. Sehr populär für Feeds und so generell. Gut, kommen wir zu Cloud-Outliner. Der macht das halt by default über iCloud. Und ist da eigentlich auch recht fix. Und vor allem, du schaltest das irgendwie an, oder es ist einfach angeschaltet, also einfach Sync by default über iCloud. Das heißt, du hast zumindest auf all deinen Büchsen immer gesynkte Outlines. Und du kannst aber so als extra Sugar für einzelne Outlines auch noch ein Syncing über Evernote machen. Womit du dann diese Outlines auch tatsächlich noch in Evernote siehst, was ja eigentlich eher textorientiert ist. Da simulieren die das irgendwie mit so komischen Outline-Bullet-Point-Listen und so. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob das unter allen Bedingungen zusammenpasst. Aber so habe ich mir das immer vorgestellt. Jetzt können sie dann das Haufen noch ein bisschen drehen.
Aber passt.
Kann ich euch sehr empfehlen. Damit könnt ihr mal so ein bisschen arbeiten. Und ich sage euch, das auf jedem Rechner aufhaben, zum Notieren von Ideen, so quasi als Notizbuch benutzen, das hilft. Bisher benutze ich ja Simple Note bzw. auf Mac ganz konkret die Applikation Just Notes, wo ich zuletzt noch geklagt hatte, dass sie so Syncing-Probleme hat. Das Problem ist wohl mittlerweile behoben. Ich benutze da die aktuelle Beta bzw. es ist gar keine Beta mehr, sondern es ist eigentlich schon längst im Upstore, hängt aber irgendwie seit zwei Wochen mal wieder bei Apple fest, weil wir wissen schon, da muss dann irgendwie erst mal noch das Karma gemessen werden und die Messgeräte sind gerade nicht da.
Was messen die Synch-Synthologen nochmal? Wie heißt das mit ihren E-Metern? Also sie messen eigentlich den Widerstand, aber was denken Sie, was sie messen?
Die heißen diese komischen Messgeräte.
Stress? Ja, die heißen E-Meter, oder?
Ja, die heißen E-Meter.
Tetanen?
Tetanen sind doch diese Ordnungsgrade, die man da erreichen kann, wenn man da in der Hierarchie aufsteigt, oder?
Aber ich dachte, die messen noch was anderes außer Stress, irgendwelche komischen Wellen oder sowas, was sie sich da ausgedacht haben. Aber gut, vielleicht messen sie auch einfach nur die Stresswellen. Ja, gut, aber sowas in der Art machen die auf jeden Fall beim Apple-Review-Prozess offensichtlich auch.
Genau, und das wird aber wohl demnächst draußen sein. Also wer JustNotes benutzt, der sollte sich schon mal freuen auf die 1-2-1, die scheint mir dann recht stabil zu sein. Hat aber leider keine Outlines. Und diese Cloud-Outliner hat im Prinzip genau dieselbe Optik wie JustNotes, bloß macht Outlines. So, wenn man jetzt sozusagen diese beiden Programme noch irgendwie mergen könnte, dass man sagen kann, jetzt will ich mal Fleece-Text haben und jetzt will ich irgendwie Outline haben.
Und da noch Rich-Text hinzufügt.
Ich nehme ja Plain-Text. Das ist so ein Programm, mit dem kann man dann einfach in der Dropbox Texte, einfach nur ASCII-Texte schreiben und die synchronisiert da dann über die Dropbox zu.
Ja, aber da ist halt nicht so ein Live-Syncing?
Nö, es ist relativ flott mit dem Syncing. Also tippst und nach 2-3 Sekunden ist es woanders.
Du hast halt noch Konflikt-Copies und bla.
Nö, hast du eigentlich nicht. Der ist da relativ...
Du hast generell bei der Dropbox Konflikt-Copies. Das ist einfach bei Design.
Ja, das ist bei Design, aber es ist, wenn du jetzt nicht auf drei Geräten gleichzeitig tippst, das ist nicht schlimm.
Ja, du kannst es nicht verhindern als Applikations-Entwickler, dass du sowas hast.
Ja, weiß ich, weiß ich. Aber es ist bei iCloud nicht viel besser. Ganz im Gegenteil, da ist es viel schlechter.
Weil?
Äh, Apple das irgendwie nicht richtig macht, keine Ahnung. Also ich hatte neulich irgendwie von einem Numbers-Dokument plötzlich drei, von denen eins nicht mal aufging. Und immer wenn ich versucht hab, das aufzumachen, dann hat er mir noch ne Konflikt-Copy erzeugt. Da musst du erst mal rausfinden, wie man in der iCloud überhaupt ein Dokument löscht.
Es gibt Konflikt-Copies in der iCloud? Ich dachte, die machen da immer so The Truth is in the Cloud und sie entscheiden dann für dich, was irgendwie das Aktuelle ist. Truth ist doch nicht in der Cloud. Wo ist denn dann die Wahrheit, wenn sie nicht in der Wolke ist? Es gibt keine Wahrheit.
Es gibt nur Versionen.
Das war's.
Mir fällt nichts mehr ein.
Über 06, äh, Quatsch, 061, 601 brauchen wir nicht reden. iPhone Update, ne? Da gab's jetzt nicht so viel. Das iTunes ist immer noch nicht draußen.
Ich hab da noch so ein nettes Spiel, was eigentlich so ein Clicky-Spiel ist, wo man halt irgendwann irgendwelche Inner-Purchases machen muss, damit man weiterkommt oder zumindest damit man schneller weiterkommt. Das ist aber sehr niedlich, es heißt My Singing Monsters. Und da züchtet man Monster, die singen. Und je mehr man von diesen Monstern züchtet, desto komplexer wird auch der Song, den die da zu Besten geben. Ich fand das super.
Und wie finden es deine Kinder?
Die können damit noch nichts anfangen.
Die sind noch zu klein, wa?
Außerdem ist Angry Birds Star Wars erschienen.
Wollt grad sagen, genau.
Und?
Ja, ist kurz niedlich.
Was ist jetzt der Unterschied? Man muss jetzt Darth Vader durch die Gegend schmeißen?
Nee, aber du hast jetzt ein Laserschwert. Und wenn du dann fliegst, kannst du dann im richtigen Moment das Laserschwert zünden und dann säbelt er einmal durch die Blöcke durch, auf die er drauffliegt. Oder wenn du mit dem Yoda-Vogel schießt, dann macht er sofort Wellen und dann fliegen die ganzen Bauteile weg.
Das ist ja der Grund, warum George Lucas dann verkauft hat.
Da hat er keinen Bock mehr gehabt.
Das Marsch war.
Wahrscheinlich hat er noch schnell an Rovio lizenziert und dann verkauft. Aber es ist recht nett, wenn man ein Level nicht geschafft hat, dann kommt das Darth Vader-Schwein.
Das ist jetzt aus dem Laserschwert ab.
Dann kommt das Darth Vader-Schwein und lacht blöd.
Für das Sounddesign der heutigen Sendung ist zuständig die Stimme der Jugend.
Fertig geleserschwert dort.
Das muss ich hier mal kurz.
Ich habe auch noch einen Android-Tipp.
Ich gehe mal kurz auf Klo. Da müssen wir hier gebühren sein, wenn du so etwas machst.
Das kannst du dich bringen.
Jetzt, wo Pixar oder Disney in Charge ist.
Bis gleich. Ich meine es ja nicht so, dass ich jetzt besonders viel Zeit mit Android verbringen würde, aber ich habe zumindest hier mal ein wenig geschaut, wie es denn so mit den Podcast-Lines aussieht. Und was vielleicht jetzt nicht jeder, der Android benutzt, kennt, ist, neben den etwas bekannteren, also Beyond Pod ist glaube ich ein relativ bekannter Podcast-Line. Dann gibt es ja noch diesen Podkicker Pro, der auch im Gegensatz zu Beyond Pod mit Flutter ausgestattet ist. Und dann gibt es noch Antennapod. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das User-Interface mich nicht verwirrt, aber es ist zumindest nicht schlecht. Und auch da ist Flutter mit eingebaut und ja, also kann man benutzen, ist so ein Podcast-Line eben.
Du redest jetzt von Beyond Pod?
Ne, von Antennapod. Antennapod. Antennapod. Und der ist auch komischerweise kostenlos.
Obwohl er was taugt.
Obwohl er was taugt, ist er kostenlos. Verstehe ich irgendwie nicht so richtig, aber so ist es nun mal. Ja, sieht ganz aufgeräumt aus. Hat auch OP im LX Porto. Und man kann die App selber flattern sozusagen. Habe ich jetzt gerade erfolgreich getan. Ja, das war's von mir. Du hast meinen ersten Android-Tip verpasst.
Ich kann es ja glücklicherweise nachhören, wenn es diesmal mit dem Recording geklappt hat. Alles noch da.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das eben nicht mit aufgenommen hat. Sag mal, Tim, ich sehe, du hast hier eine iPhone 5-Holle.
Und warum hast du zwei davon? Hast du die mitgebracht?
Nicht so explizit, aber die gibt es sozusagen nur im Doppelpack. Also du kaufst das Ding und dann hast du eine weiße und eine schwarze.
Die weiße würde ich ja nehmen.
Würdest du das?
Dann weiß ich jetzt auch gar nicht mehr, was ich dafür bezahlt habe.
Dann findest du es mal raus.
Denke ich mir was aus. Hab ich bei Saturn gekauft, kostete glaube ich so 17, 18 Euro. Und war damit deutlich billiger als alles das, was beim Apple Store war. Wobei das Angebot beim Apple Store war einfach mal schlecht.
Gibt es ja inzwischen schon, weil ich habe immer mal wieder geguckt.
Ja, die haben jetzt so, zumindest in Oberhausen.
Also direkt im Store.
Ich wollte ja noch was über diesen Store sagen.
Also gut, dann gibt es wirklich gar keine News.
Na, außer dass es Frühjahr ist, ist auch übrigens bezahlter Urlaub.
Also dieses Jahr wird es definitiv nichts. Bitte?
Sie kriegen wohl bezahlten Urlaub. Oder wenn du weiter zugehörst, Switcher.
Ja, das will man ja wohl hoffen, dass irgendwie die gesetzlichen Vorgaben eingehalten werden. Ja, aber manchmal gibt es ja noch so Urlaubsgeld oder sowas. Über dein normales Gehalt hinaus sozusagen nochmal eine Zuwendung im Sommer bekommst oder Weihnachten oder so, weißt du, so 13. Monatsgehalt, was in Österreich so gang und gäbe ist. Das gibt es wohl nicht. Das gibt es sicherlich auch in anderen Branchen nicht, aber es gab da wohl überhaupt relativ wenig, was Freude macht, außer von einer Menge Arbeit.
Trinken sie Kaffee umsonst?
Ja, aber sie haben keine Zeit, sie zu trinken, oder?
Also ich bin mir sicher, dass dieser Spiegel-Artikel an manchen Stellen auch ein bisschen übertrieben hat. Aber ich habe mich schon mal länger mit jemandem unterhalten, der schon ein bisschen länger her am Apple Store gearbeitet hat und zumindest diese ganze Überwachungsgeschichte und so. Das hat sich ziemlich genau mit dem gedeckt, was er da erzählt hat. Und so richtig geil ist es nicht.
Das heißt, man ist als Kunde eigentlich auch überwacht, wenn man da reinläuft?
Ich meine, die sind da auch echt im Stress. Wenn ihr da in Oberhausen, da merkt man mal echt, wie populär Apple ist. Dieser Laden, ich habe ja versucht, da noch irgendwie einen Termin zu klicken und ich dachte mal, die Apple-Webseite wäre kaputt. Weil die haben mir da nur einen einzigen Tag angezeigt. Normalerweise, wenn du jetzt bei so einem Apple Store in Dresden oder so dir da einen Termin klickst, na okay, dann ist vielleicht mal der Vormittag und der Mittag weg, aber dann hast du noch am Abend was oder zumindest noch vier, fünf andere Tage. Aber die meinten dann auch so, der Run auf dem Laden sei irgendwie so dermaßen extrem, weil das halt mitten im Ruhrgebiet, mit einem Einzugsgebiet größer als Berlin. Und es ist so ein kleiner Mall-Store. Also es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass die sich da über drei Etagen ausgebreitet haben. Es ist halt ein Zentro, und es ist halt einfach so ein normaler Mall-Store. Es ist diese kleinste denkbare Instanz eines Apple Stores.
Die kleinste Scheibe.
Und dann hast du da hinten so einen Genius Bar mit drei, vier, fünf Leuten, die da vielleicht parallel rumstehen, und die müssen dann irgendwie diesen Run machen. Und vorne ist halt so die übliche hektische Aktivität, die man so kennt, und hinten ist irgendwie alles rappelvoll. Und dann auf Nachfrage, ich meine so, naja, ich bin mal so auf gut Glück vorbeigekommen, weil da war halt gar kein Termin frei im Web. Ich mir dachte irgendwie, seid ihr vielleicht einer, wo man keine kriegt, und man muss da nur hingehen oder so? Ich dachte, ich probier's zumindest mal, ich würde mir den Laden mal angucken. Und dann meinten sie so, ne, die werden irgendwie überrannt. Also sie würden jeden Tag 500 neue Termine raushauen, und die werden halt innerhalb von einer halben Stunde weg.
So viele Probleme haben sie mit ihren Produkten.
Naja, also was ich damit sagen will, ist, die könnten wahrscheinlich in diesem Gebiet mal locker noch zwei, drei Stores aufmachen. Im Prinzip, die Nachfrage ist definitiv schon da. Nur weil sie halt so mega picky sind, und so lange brauchen, ihr Personal auszubilden. Und keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist die Fluktuation auch so hoch, dass sie die, die sie ausbilden, wesentlichen brauchen, um die Lücken zu stopfen. Keine Ahnung, das ist jetzt nur eine reine Vermutung.
Naja, ich meine, wenn sie die so scheiße behandeln, dann ist natürlich klar, dass sie nur durchlauferhetzt werden.
Ja, aber irgendwie bleiben die halt dann trotzdem da. Wir hatten ja schon mal diese Schilderung da von dem anderen Laden, dass du dieser ganze Ausbildungsprozess, dass du da halt auch einfach so hin gewaschen wirst und dann so auf diesen alles ist toll, Apple ist super, wir sind glücklich und liebe deinen Kunden und jetzt wird aber mal ordentlich geklatscht hier. Ich meine, ich bin ja auch gerne mal Fan von einem Unternehmen, wenn sie ordentliche Sachen machen. Das gilt auch ein Stück weit für Apple. Ich habe das ja nun schon häufig zur Kenntnis gegeben und ich tue das hier gerne nochmal. Bei diesen Apple Stores und vor allem bei diesen Eröffnungen oder Produkten, da hört es bei mir auf. Das ist einfach der metallische Anschlag. Täglicher Zuneigung.
Und klang!
Da kann ich keinen Millimeter weiter. Da ist einfach Ende.
Was war das in Dänemark, dieser Store, wo bei der Eröffnung sich dann keiner reingegangen getraut hat?
Was war das, Oslo? Nee, Schweden, in Stockholm. Genau, und ich sag dir, wenn dieser scheiß Apple Store hier in Berlin aufmacht, dann wünsche ich mir, dass wir hier wirklich diese Idee mit dem Flashmob, dass einfach jeder, der an dem Tag, wo das scheiß Teil aufmacht, gelangweilt ist und schlechte Laune hat, soll da hinkommen. Das wäre so geil, wenn dieser ganze Apple Store einfach umrundet ist von Leuten, die einfach mit dem Leben abgeschlossen haben, die sich sowieso über nichts mehr freuen können. Am besten, man ordert einen Bus und fährt denen irgendwie so eine Psychiatrie und dann...
Und dann stellt sich raus, die fangen alle wieder an zu grinsen, wenn sie so ein Apple-Gerät da sind.
Oder wenn man verteilt so Sad-Face-Masken. Oder hier so der Schrei, weißt du so.
Oder man sprüht Buttersäure auf den Bürgersteig und dann haben alle keine gute Laune.
Buttersäure?
Stinkt.
Ach, das ist dieser faulige Eier...
Nein, Eier nicht.
Aber schon so einfach richtig, dass man eigentlich schlecht kotzen will. Also das war ja meine Idee, Buttersäuren-Superstore-Kanal in diesen Scientology-Ständen mal kurz so vorbeisliden mit so einem Fahrrad oder so und mal kurz so eine Spur Buttersäure voran über die Bücher geben und dann...
Ja, aber das ist schon... Das finde ich irgendwie, das ist schon so...
Terrorismus.
Terrorismus. Nee, es muss einfach nur Langeweile da sein. Einfach nur so keine Begeisterung. Dann stehen da so diese ganzen Horten, das ist wahrscheinlich auch total unfair gegenüber diesen Leuten, dann wieder so... Aber ich meine mal ehrlich, das geht nicht. Und gerade in Berlin.
Das geht überhaupt nicht. Kannst du dir das überhaupt vorstellen?
Dass in Berlin da so eine Klatsch und Jubel und Schreiorgie abgeht?
Wollen wir nicht!
Das wollen wir doch nicht! Das passt hier nicht hin.
Wir Berliner wollen das nicht.
Deswegen gehen die wahrscheinlich auch in den Westen. Da kannst du das noch machen.
Hier wird nicht geklatscht, hier wird gekauft!
Aber einer nach dem anderen. So, watten die ja? Sie haben doch schon ihr Produkt. Gehen sie mal raus. Da wollen noch andere Leute rennieren. Das ist der Berlin-Star. Und so läuft das hier.
Willst du noch einen Kaffee oder bist du fertig?
Jetzt drängeln sie mal nicht hier. Die anderen wollen ja auch mal touchen, wa? Meine Fresse!
Echt?
Also Apple, Koch! Bleib mir mit deinen Grinsekatzen fern hier. Von unserer Wahlheimat sollen wir einfach den Laden dicht lassen.
Ja oder einfach so mal...
Kein Scheiß drauf. Man kommt auch gut rum, verstehst du? Ich fahr auch gerne mal nach Dresden mit meinem iMac unter Barm.
Ist ja jetzt leichter, den du hast.
Vier Kilo gespart, da wird so eine Reise noch ganz erträglich irgendwie.
Voll ungeil, oder? Ich meine schon dieser Graves Store, der irgendwie so... Ich meine gut, die tun nicht so affektiert, das muss man ja echt noch zugute halten.
Die sind schön gravesmäßig geblieben von ihrer Grundeinstellung.
Ich meine, wenn du hier irgendwie einen guten Apple Laden machen willst, dann machst du ja irgendwie so eine hippe, coole Bude, wo irgendwie alle in gebrauchten Klamotten rumlaufen und nicht mit diesem ekligen California Blue.
Wo gibt es denn gebrauchte Klamotten? Die Löcher in den Hosen, da wird so gekauft, das ist nicht im Raucht.
Hat jetzt noch keiner gesagt.
War das in dem Artikel oder in diesem Video, was Spiegel noch dazu gebracht hat, meinten sie ja sogar, hier ist glaube ich in dem Artikel drin, dass es die Anweisung gibt, das ist halt so absurd, dass wenn diese Apple-Shirts durchgetragen sind, also die kriegen wohl ihre eigenen, und wenn sie die dann wegschmeißen, die dürfen die zwar wegschmeißen und kriegen dann neue, aber die dürfen die halt nicht wegschmeißen, ohne vorher nicht den Apfel herauszuschneiden.
Also zu zerstören da...
Also den Apfel müssten sie abgeben, um ein neues Shirt zu kriegen, oder wie?
Die wollen nicht, dass irgendwer mit so einem Shirt in der Öffentlichkeit rumrennt. Also nicht raus schneiden, aber die müssen es wahrscheinlich kaputt machen oder so. Na klar wollen die nicht, dass irgendwer auf der Straße mit so einem Apple Genius T-Shirt rumrennt, wobei es dir nicht so schwer ist, so ein T-Shirt nachzumachen, oder?
Nee, das nicht. Aber ich würde mir wünschen, dass diese amerikanische Gleichmacherei hier spätestens in Berlin an ihr Ende gerät und wahrscheinlich ist das einfach vergebliche Liebe.
Perlen voll die Säue.
Ja, aber dann halt Apple doch wieder ein CEO, den Deutschland nicht mag. Na ja, Steve Jobs mochte doch Deutschland nicht.
Was?
Jetzt kommt's raus.
Es gibt so eine nette Geschichte, dass er irgendwann noch zu Next-Zeiten mal in Deutschland war und dann dachte der der Next-Chef von Deutschland, es wäre doch eine super Idee, irgendwie mit Steve, mit Olle Steve ins Hofbrauhaus zu gehen und er wird doch dann sicherlich auch ein Schweinebraten essen und ein Bier trinken und so weiter und Steve saß dann wohl da den ganzen Abend in einem Glas Wasser und am nächsten Tag gab es einen neuen Apple-Deutschland-Chef.
Das ist bestätigt? Das ist bestätigt?
Keine Ahnung. Also er war nicht in Deutschland, er war in Bayern. Wenn du so willst, er war in Bayern, in München. München ist Deutschland näher als Bayern.
Und wie wir wissen, steht in München auch ein Hofbräuhaus.
Also Kacke kann er in Deutschland gar nicht gefunden haben. Da würde er sich nicht jedes Jahr einen neuen SL irgendwie da von seinem Händler geben lassen, weil der kommt schon nämlich auch von hier.
Ich glaube, dann wäre er schon mehr …Es wäre schon geil, wenn man irgendwie so diese Apple-Store-Shirts dann halt auch wirklich mal selber druckt. Nee, dann verteilst du das ja einfach an die Hobos irgendwie. Obdachlosen.
Ja, hier sind Hobos?
Nein, muss A.
Das ist natürlich auch eine Trollmaßnahme.
Ja, an Apple a day keeps the trouble away. Also meine Vorschläge greifen nur so begrenzt. Aber es zeigt auch nur meine Verzweiflung.
Ja, aber du hast Recht, da müssen wir was machen.
Irgendwas müssen wir uns da einfallen lassen.
Die hedonistische internationale Malinrufe.
Ich glaube, das stimmt, das ist glaube ich der richtige Ansatz.
Apple wegbassen. Das ist ein Flashmob, wo alle dann so die ganze Zeit...
Vielleicht kann man ja auch irgendwas machen. Also eine Demo für diese armen, prekären Apple Store-Mitarbeiter. Dass die mal mehr Spaß haben. Also ich meine, mir geht es ja jetzt nicht darum, nach den Schleckerfrauen, die Apple-Jungs, die... Es sind ja nicht nur Jungs, es sind ja auch Mädels. Wobei, da sind auch echt viele, oder sagen wir mal, echt wenig Mädchen eigentlich in diesen Läden. Ob das zwangsläufig ist irgendwie? Allein schon von der Bewerbungslage her? Heute halten sie einfach nicht so lange auf. Na gut, wir hören mal auf, oder? 23.42. Besser jetzt nicht. Genug gerantet. Ich hoffe, ihr hattet euren Spaß. Ich hatte meinen Spaß. Und wir müssen unbedingt nochmal David loben.
Ja, für den Trailer.
Dafür gibt es jetzt von mir einen Applaus.
Und auch den Christian, der das gesprochen hat. Ganz großartig. Und das wird noch lustig.
Lasst flattern.
Lasst flattern. Genau. So wie ihr uns ja hier auch generell mit dem Projekt immer wieder unterstützt und hier den prekären Mitarbeitern von Mobamex auch immer wieder an meine Pizza zukommen lassen könnt zu Beginn der Sendung. Hier gibt es ja noch. In der Meterebene, da kümmert man sich ja noch.
Um die Meter weiter.
Aber so weit von.
Die Überwachungskamera bleibt.
So ein Lebkuchen-Link gepostet.
Stimmt, eigentlich haben sich da gleich schon ein paar Leute gemeint, dass sie mal was zu... Hast du ein Lebkuchen bekommen Tim? Zufällig zugesendet?
Jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht so bewusst, nein.
Okay, also passt mal auf. Wenn ihr die Meterebene unterstützen wollt, dann gibt es hier einen Link im Chat und später den Show-Notes von der Lebkücherei Wojtinek. Ich weiß, die Leute, die jetzt aus Nürnberg kommen, die sagen, nein, das sind nicht die besten Elisen Lebkuchen.
Aber die sind geil aus Nürnberg?
Doch, aber es gibt natürlich, wenn man in Nürnberg ist und noch seine Nachbarbäckerei kennt, das ist noch alles.
Also bei mir im Bioland gibt es auch eine andere Sorte, die ist voll geil, aber da weiß ich jetzt ihren Namen nicht. Aber es sind halt sozusagen auch Original-Nürnberger Elisen Lebkuchen. Da isst man einen und dann denkt man, das sind die gleichen Teile wie bei Herr der Ringe, wo die so plat sind, wo die sofort satt sind. Das muss rein und dasselbe sein, ich sag's dir.
Also hier so die Original-Elisen Lebkuchen, da gibt es auch hier so schön diese Mischbox, auch gleich mal den Link, wenn ihr da uns...
Jetzt habe ich extra auf die Seite geschrieben, man soll uns keine verderblichen Waren schicken, aber mit Lebkuchen geht es eigentlich noch.
Da wird nichts verderben, wir essen die sofort. Ich will mit Schokolade übrigens.
Ja, das ist jetzt die Mischpackung, da gibt es dann von allem einen.
Ja, wir sind ja auch mehr als bei Not Safe For Work.
Also nur so als Tipp, falls ihr denkt, ich würde gern was schicken, aber ich weiß einfach nicht was.
Oder falls ihr sowieso das Gefühl gehabt habt, dass hier zu wenig geschmackt wird.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade noch bei Kulinarik sind, ich muss noch ganz kurz noch was zum Thema Bier sagen. Und zwar gibt es auf Kickstarter momentan ein Projekt, wo Leute, ich hab's gerade in den Chat gepostet, wo Leute ein Gerät bauen wollen, mit dem man den Brau-Vorgang seines Biers überwachen kann.
Auch das, was du schon gebaut hast?
Nee, das war das Meischen, das ist das eigentliche Gären. Genau, wie der Stammwürzegehalt am Anfang ist und welcher Endstammwürzegehalt und so weiter. Der Bier-Bug. Genau. Ich hab mir ja so einen Teil schon bestellt.
Die sind ja schon voll durch mit ihrem Plätsch.
Ja, six days to go. Also wer noch einen haben will, der kann noch sechs Tage lang da klicken. Ja, da gibt es irgendwie zwei Varianten.
Was macht dich glauben, dass das gut funktionieren wird?
Was macht mich glauben? Ich denke einfach, ich probier's aus und dann wissen wir mehr.
Und worauf soll das dann laufen?
Das Ding, das läuft irgendwie autonom und den gibt es in der Bluetooth-Variante und in der WLAN-Variante. Also die Bluetooth-Variante kommt wohl relativ schnell. Da wird aber nur Windows und Android unterstützt. Schreiben sie so und in der WLAN-Variante unterstützen sie dann irgendwie alles. Und ich hab mal die WLAN-Variante geordert. Ähm, 250.
Kein Pappenstil.
Verstehe ich jetzt auch nicht, warum Bluetooth ausgerechnet beim Mac nicht gehen soll oder beim iOS?
Du, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall, es klingt sehr interessant. Man kann das Ding halt dann, schmeißt man einfach quasi rein in die Brühe. Und dann lockt der halt Daten mit über die Woche oder die zwei Wochen oder wie auch immer, wie lange auch immer das dann tatsächlich so vor sich hingeht.
Ja, man merkt, dass Bierbrauen so in der Gegenwart angekommen ist. Ja, vor allem in den USA. Also da gehen ja total alle ab irgendwie auf Bierbrauen.
Naja, Andreas hatte einfach total recht, als er gesagt hat, das ist ein super Nerdsport.
Ja, den Eindruck gewinne ich in zunehmendem Maße.
Also da hat er einfach sowas von Recht gehabt. Das macht einfach eine unglaubliche Laune. Und es gibt so viele Parameter, die man messen kann und an denen man rumdrehen kann, wo man dann hinterher Kurven machen kann und so.
Ich bin durch.
Ja, und wir müssen auch überlegen, was wir zur 100. Sendung machen.
Genau.
Stimmt, wir können ja noch gar nicht gehen. Wir quatschen jetzt erstmal noch.
Da ziehen wir uns jetzt mal zur Beratung zurück.
Ins Hinterzimmer zurück.
Stell ich schon mal den Whisky warm.
Genau. Und wir sagen einfach mal Tschüss.
Danke fürs Kommen und wir sehen uns bald.
It's not copying if it's better!
I'm telling you, it's all about widgets.
It's just a standard micro USB cable.